[музика]
пані та панове запрошуємо вас займатися
в залі Біля головної сцени вже за 5
хвилин розпочнеться
наша зустріч звісно розпочнемо з
презентації бачення майбутнього освіти і
науки в Україні тому звісно ви нам всі
потрібні Біля головної сцени проходьте
займайте місця є з усіх боків від сцени
тому проходьте далі і знаходьте найкраще
місце для себе 5 хвилин і будемо
розпочинати і ще раз і ще раз хочу
нагадати що задля спільної безпеки
просимо вас утриматись від публікацій
фото відео та інших матеріалів серпневої
до закінчення заходу орієнтовно до
18:00 Дякуємо за розуміння
[музика]
Доброго ранку Доброго ранку шановні пані
та панове
щиро ради вітати вас на серпневі
щорічний конференції для освітян як же
приємно всіх вас бачити давайте гучно
привітаємо одне одного і таким чином
скажемо що ми готові розпочинати
Чудово дякую надзвичайно а спочатку
трошечки інформаційної частини пані та
панове ви всі розумієте що ми з вами
зустрічаємося в умовах війни в умовах
воєнного стану тому безпека понад усе Я
ще раз і ще раз хочу вас попросити про
те щоб ви утрималися від публікації
будь-яких фото
відеоматеріалів Stories а стрімів в
Instagram Facebook Today до завершення
нашої конференції тобто орієнтовно до
18:00 після того Звісно можна вже буде
поділитися усіма світлинами ну і звісно
Іще один важливий момент - це в разі
повітряної тривоги ми обов'язково всі
маємо попрямувати до укриття знову ж
таки на ваших бейджиках є схема є
вказівники І звісно наче волонтери Вам
допоможуть знайти укриття якщо воно нам
сьогодні знадобиться але я сподіваюсь що
такого не буде в будь-якому разі якщо
станеться ми тимчасово призупинемо тобто
але потім повернемося не обіцяю що з
того ж місця але як вже буде складатися
ситуація будемо вірити в найкращої що
сьогодні нам ніхто і ніхто не зможе
завадити класно і плідно найголовніше
провести час ну що ж давайте знайомитися
ближче Мене звати Тімур Мірошниченко
сьогодні цілий день разом із вами і я
щиро радий такій можливості тому що
надзвичайно ціную і шаную вашу роботу
Дякую вам за все
Отже нагадаю що сьогодні кожну годину
буквально у нас надзвичайно насичений
графік кожного годину будуть відбуватися
різноманітні події як тут на головній
сцені так і в усіх робочих зонах або
секторах так вони почнуть працювати з
12:00 тому уважно Стежте за
графіком сьогоднішнього дня аби бути
залученим максимально в усі процеси і
звісно максимально плідно провести цей
день а бачу що майже майже всі готові
добігаєте займайте місця Ну а ми тим
часом як годиться справжньому українцям
коли збираємося разом і розпочинаємо
серйозну справу маємо звісно всі разом
виконати державний гімн України
[музика]
[оплески]
Слава Україні
Ох як ви надзвичайно гарно співаєте пані
та панове до мурах до мурах дякуємо вам
за це
під час Другої світової війни коли
Вінстон Черчилль знаходився в кабінеті
міністрів Великої Британії і йому
докладали про те що необхідно
скорочувати видатки бюджету він гостро
відреагував на пропозицію скоротити
видатки на освіту і культуру Тоді він
сказав скоротити видатки на освіту і
культуру За що ми тоді ведемо війну і
мені здається що цей вислів ця фраза
сьогодні як ніколи актуальна для нашої
країни майбутнього майбутнього нашого
народу гартуються в запеклій боротьбі з
невігласом та диким можна сказати
варварським ставленням до прав кожного
обирати свій життєвий шлях бути вільним
та щасливим війна звісно забирає життя
найкращих українців вона руйнує
абсолютно все на власному шляху вона
прагне позбавити майбутнього
ми згадуємо загиблих але шануючи їхню
пам'ять ми сміливо йдемо вперед пані та
панове вшануємо пам'ять українських
дітей
студентів вчителів директорів які
загинули внаслідок війни
дякуємо
але власне заради них ми дійсно мусимо
йти вперед І будувати нову круту країну
якою будуть пишатися абсолютно всі в
першу чергу ми Українці Ми розпочинаємо
хочеться побачити інтро таке Вхід в наш
захід якщо можна будь ласочка на екрани
У нас є те що не дало опустити руки коли
прийшов найтемніший лютий
сміливість і ти туди куди ніхто б не
пішов
впевненість в ідеях які житимуть і після
нас єдність людей які стоять до кінця
і воля до перемоги і до нової країни
країни які потрібна нова вільна освіта
[музика]
освіта яка про тебе яка не створює зайве
не дублює вивчення не навчити якимось
щось давно написано яка і в смартфоні і
взумі через екрани і тривоги освіти яка
при покликання а не просто роботу про
безпеку й довіру про жарти про незвичні
підходи про науковців не в кабінетах не
на нарадах без Виноградів А про новий
герой нового етапу
технологій та інновацій яка спершу про
людину а потім про конспекти і папери
яка про Сашу з першого класу про Катю
яка вчить пайтон про Вову який вступає
знову про Інну про Колю і люду про
Сергія Івановича про маму Максима про
людей яким потрібна Нова Освіта
вільна в яких країнах
[музика]
Отже ми розпочинаємо і розпочинаємо ми з
дуже важливої теми бачення майбутнього
освіти і науки в Україні власне її
представлять
віце-прем'єр-міністр з інновації
розвитку освіти науки та технологій
міністр цифрової трансформації пан
Михайло Федоров
Всім доброго дня я почну і Міністр
освіти вже розповість більш більше
деталі про те що ми будемо робити в
найближчий час разом з вами хотів би
почати здячності за те що ви сьогодні
тут за те що ви в залі онлайн в Україні
і знаєте Я сьогодні себе зловив на такі
думці що наша сміливість наші воїни які
сьогодні йдуть в бій наші громадяни які
забезпечують надійний тил наче волонтери
наше вміння робити трансформацію під час
повномасштабної війни наше бажання
боротися за незалежність і свободу це
результат вашої роботи тому що ви
освітяни люди які вкладали в нас в наших
дітей в тих сьогодні на фронті зробили
все для того щоб у вас була щоб в них
сьогодні було бачення візія нашому
нашого майбутнього і вони за нього
боролися Тому це ваш результат я вам за
нього Дякую І те що ми сьогодні будемо
презентувати Якщо ми будемо робити ми
будемо
втілювати всі ці ідеї сміливістю як
втілюють наші воїни на полі бою робити
це для вас з вами і для наших майбутніх
поколінь Я хотів би почати з того чому
Сьогодні я тут чому сьогодні в мене
збільшилася повноваження І я опікується
також питанням освіти технології і
інновації
Цей діалог почався
в мене з президентом з парламентом
взимку 23-го року і
зрозуміло що нам під час повномасштабної
війни потрібно трансформуватися потрібно
будувати нову економіку потрібно
розвивати військові технології нам
потрібно працювати далі і нам потрібно
дбати піклуватися про людський капітал
тому що це основа нашої країни і це
основа нашого майбутнього і президент
поставив задачу розробити чітке бачення
де ми будемо через 5-10-15 років що ми
будемо робити Які наші наступні кроки І
звичайно що освіта - це фундамент
розвитку
людського капіталу і
одне з перших завдань - це звичайно що
було скажемо створити умови для
реалізації візі тобто створити візію і
створити умови для реалізації сьогодні
ми будемо говорити з вами про нашу візію
яку ми формували спільно з експертами з
командою Міністерства освіти Всім дякую
хто долучився до розробки цього бачення
і також ми будемо сьогодні говорити з
командою яка прийшла реалізувати цю
візію тому спершу було розуміння куди ми
рухаємося і потім як ми будемо
перезавантажувати Міністерство освіти
хто нам потрібен для того щоб досягнути
цього бачення хто зможе операційно це
втілювати не просто говорити а робити
тому що це сотні тисячі різних проектів
і Якщо говорити про глобальне бачення
чого ми хочемо досягнути тим що ми
сьогодні тут презентуємо плани вже
почали щось втілювати Що ми будемо
робити в найближчий час ми хочемо
побудувати систему яка здатна формувати
націю людей громадян які є професійними
щасливими найголовніше щасливими які
здатні втілювати себе реалізовувати в
сучасній інноваційній технологічній
економіці яка генерують регіоні компанії
мільярдні компанії і люди які знають
в силу України вміють себе захистити
вміють захистити своїх дітей і ніколи не
допустять знову повторних таких війн які
є І це це все що ми будемо про що ми
будемо говорити Те саме про це як
сформувати людей щасливих професійних
які зможуть втілювати себе в сучасній
економіці і вміти захистити себе Ви чули
про різні плани там різні екологічні
стратегії які презентувалися за останній
час і про те що потрібно побудувати
трильйонну економіку і А це збільшити в
чотири рази економіку Яка є сьогодні А я
б сказав А давайте ще більше мріяти
Давайте давайте зробимо собі таку
створимо собі мрію щоб в нас була ВВП на
душу населення на 4,000 $, а 100 000 А
давайте потрапимо в в десятку країн з
найбільшим рівнем ВВП і туди можуть
потрапити країни які трансформувалися
економічно які відкрили зробили
повноцінну ринкову економіку де
створюються компанії з високою доданою
вартістю такий як Тесла компанії такі
компанії як віза компанія які заробляють
технологіями а такі компанії створюють
люди які швидко навчаються які вміють
приймати рішення з аналітичними даними
які мають певні компетентності і
насправді ми можемо побудувати не тільки
систему освіти яка дозволяє генерувати
Нове покоління людей які досягають таких
цілей А ми також Можемо і допомогти
світу поділитися через певний час своїм
досвідом тому що сьогодні ми отримуємо
унікальний досвід сьогодні те що ми наш
наші практичні кроки ми можемо втілювати
в освіті для військових Ми сьогодні
отримуємо неймовірний досвід на полі бою
який не отримує будь-яка країна і
військові будь-якої країни Ми детально
розуміємо як планується сучасні бойові
дії що таке ситуаційна обізнаність як
працюють дрони ми вміємо координувати
людей під час такої технологічної війни
і це також потрібно втілювати в нашій
системі освіти і потім масштабувати і
ширити на всі країни світу тому що ми
зможемо цим поділитися Сьогодні ми
отримаємо унікальний На жаль досвід і
медичній сфері Тому що наші лікарі наші
хірурги Вони отримують Той досвід який
за який будуть боротися багато країн
цього світу і для нас дуже важливо щоб
люди залишилися в Україні вони впливали
на те як формуються нова система
медичної освіти і потім ми мали цю
цінність і могли могли її транслювати в
інших країнах світу ділитися з іншими це
також система освіта тому що сьогодні
Україна активно розвивається як цифрова
країна як it країна ми є одним із
лідерів в світі за аутсорсингом
it-продуктів ви бачите що Ми зараз
робимо в напрямку побудови цифрової
держави Естонія впроваджує дію вже 50-та
країни які готові також це розвивати
використовуючи наші продукти які Ми
створюємо в Україні і тому це також те
що ми будемо робити те що ми будемо
презентувати це перше сьогодні буде
казати міністр більш детально
розкладаючи на проекти все це ми зможемо
потім також транслювати світ ну в першу
чергу працювати для українців і звичайно
що нам потрібно
розвиватися в напрямку англійської мови
нам потрібно
говорити з іншими країнами
на одній мові для того щоб досягати
результату в побудові нової економіки
без цього неможливо Але звичайно що в
першу чергу ми повинні продовжити
активно впроваджувати українську мову і
Нам потрібно вже в принципі закінчити з
цією трансформацією від радянської
системи освіти зараз за останні роки
зроблено дуже багато і ще раз
повертаючись до мого початку виступу
результат сьогоднішньої сьогоднішня
сміливості українців технологічності
українців це результат ваш це результат
українських освітян і потрібно його
масштабувати продовжувати і звичайно що
ми повинні продовжити не зупиняти
фундаментальні реформи ними ми не
повинні думати про те як зупиняти нуш а
повинні думати як проаналізувати його
результати доопрацювати маштабувати
впровадити і знову аналізувати
моніторити результати коригувати і знову
продовжити впроваджувати Ми повинні
продовжувати розвивати ЗНО І це ті
надбання які ми маємо за останні 10
років
надалі продовжити їх розвивати тобто
трансформуючи систему створюючи нові
умови нам потрібно бетонувати те
найкраще що було вже створено і Це
важлива і це нас меседж нашого спільної
команди
які є які ми хочемо також
використовувати основні принципи
трансформації я б Напевно закреслив все
що тут написано і сказав би найголовніше
чого ми хочемо і там може це зібратися
багато різних принципів це щоб кожен
українець зміг стати тим ким він хоче
стати Це найголовніше ця ідеологія яка
також покладена в систему яку ми будемо
сьогодні вам презентувати в ті проекти
які ми будемо презентувати кожен
українець повинен стати тим ким він хоче
стати неважливо де він проживає Я з
маленького містечка яка на жаль зараз
окупована де ми на три роки не було
англійською мовою де не вистачало
педагогів і систему освіти яка вона була
на цей момент але вона мені допомогла
стати тим ким є сьогодні і я далі
навчаюся протягом всього життя тому що
це тепер скажемо наша реальність і я
зустрічаю багато талановитих педагогів
які мені сьогодні дозволяють отримувати
нові знання навички і людина з
будь-якого містечка з селища неважливо
де вона повинна отримати Рівне доступ до
освіти де є
педагоги з енергією з високим рівнем
заробітної плати з бажанням розвиватися
і розвивати інших ось це ми повинні
побудувати
якщо подивитися на ключові напрямки
і дивитися на кожну Ланку освіти що ми
будемо робити і проекти в яких напрямках
реалізовувати це наша така певна
метадологія для себе самих як будувати
роботу як втілювати проекти Як
переходити від стратегії до конкретних
дій це починається з менеджменту якщо
дивитися на будь-яке підприємство на
будь-яку організацію на будь-який
навчальний заклад все починається з
лідера все починається з директора все
починається з керівника він запалює цю
організацію в хорошому сенсі він створює
умови що всі працювали він підбирає
кадри наскільки це можливо да про діючий
автономії він
в нього є скажемо ця енергія для того
щоб досягати певних результатів і Наша
задача на кожному
на кожній Ланці освіти починаючи взагалі
навіть від інфекційних таких речей як
Міністерства зробити так щоб у всіх були
можливості всіх менеджерів були
можливості втілювати конкретні проекти
конкретні результати не мати тих людей
яких вони хочуть для того щоб досягати
поставлених цілей Наша задача збільшити
рівень навичок знань менеджменту
освітніх менеджерів зробити так щоб вони
мали їду заробітну плату вони мали певну
автономію все про що я говорю Ви
сьогодні побачите в конкретних проектах
моя задача розповісти про візію але ви
сьогодні побачите конкретні проекти щоб
оцих людей з'явилися можливість
втілювати всі інші проекти про які ми
сьогодні будемо говорити тому що я як
менеджер знаю коли ти делегуєш задачі
менеджеру але не даєш для нього не даєш
йому умов щоб він їх реалізувати не даєш
йому можливість сплачувати нормально
заробітну плату команді не даєш
можливості приймати рішення наймати
людей звільняти людей неможливо
побудувати ефективну організацію друге -
це Педагог - це людина яка по суті і як
ключовим
джерелом нашої системи освіти мене
запалюють конкретні люди надихають
конкретні люди мою дитину в садочку вже
в школі також надихають конкретні люди
Моя дитина займається фортепіано тому що
їй подобається людина яка викладає
фортепіано кожна кожен з вас кожен з тих
хто ділиться своїми знаннями і веде
наших дітей ви є особливими від вас
взагалі залежить е майбутнє нашої нації
моя далі буду говорити про те що
професія вчителів взагалі про професія
педагогів і вона повинна стати
найкрутішою найсучаснішою професією в
нашій країні це освітяни повинні бути
рок-зірками І саме блогери повинні про
них розповідати вони повинні розповідати
про це максимально
на великі аудиторії вони повинні бути
зірками але про це ми сьогодні
поговоримо Що стосується педагогів я
найголовніше
це там і позиція президента - це позиція
міністра освіти Ми звичайно що повинні
змінити умови праці Ми повинні змінити
е-е правила формування заробітної плати
не може бути 50 видів доплат і
врешті-решт отримання такої заробітної
плати Ми сьогодні будемо говорити також
про наше бачення в цьому напрямку в нас
є конкретні напрацювання Ми зібрали
найкращий досвід в світі ми
проаналізували як функціонує сьогодні
е-е процес формування заробітної плати і
у нас є чітке бачення і сили і енергія
добиватися змін в цьому напрямку буде
багато ще е пропозиції щодо
змін скажемо
функціональних обов'язків але ну
розширення там можливостей ми будемо з
цього сьогодні це говорити Але
найголовніше нам потрібно для людей які
є сьогодні в системі освіти створити
умови щоб вони не думали про якісь інші
потре себе окрім про те як надихати
дітей навчатися Це найголовніше і
зробити так щоб люди які сьогодні не в
системі або покинули систему а хочуть
служити дітям і батькам І нашій країні
Вони повернулися в цю систему і без змін
заробітної плати цього просто неможливо
зробити наступне це я б тут з п'ятого
пункту підняв би його на третій пункт це
з міста санкція освіти
починаючи від того що потрібно
продовжувати впроваджувати нуш потрібно
аналізувати
ті результати якісь які є сьогодні
потрібно продовжити впроваджувати
моніторингове дослідження потрібно
зрозуміти що що було зроблено так що
було зроблено не так і продовжити
формувати стандарти аналізуючи постійно
покращуючи і звичайно що закінчити
стандарти для профільної старшої школи і
після цього продовжити постійний
моніторинг
освітній простір коли ми говоримо про
компетентності про нові стандарти про
те як їх впроваджувати в реальне життя
про програми про контент-освітній Ми
повинні також бра- дбати про простір де
ми з вами знаходимося тому що це впливає
на те як ми мислимо е-е проте як який
рівень енергії в нас для того щоб
досягати певних цілей і звичайно що
сьогодні важко говорити про освітній про
простір коли відбувається повномасштабна
війна Сьогодні ми повинні дбати про
бомбосховища про безпеку наших дітей про
захист але Наша задача і Ми віримо всі
що війна закінчиться нашою перемогою в
найближчий час Наша задача за короткий
період часу трансформувати кожен
навчальний заклад кожен навчальний
заклад І зробити його сучасним і зробити
так щоб його дизайн його
User xperience він був поєднаний з
новими стандартами щоб діти у дітей була
Було відчуття Свободи в просторі де вони
знаходяться і
якщо іти далі то є коротко розповів вам
про те що ми будемо робити в напрямку
освітнього менеджменту сьогодні будуть
більш детально презентовані проекти як
ми будемо навчати як ми йдемо в першій
пілоти вже в цьому році щоб в наступному
тестувати нову систему управління що ми
будемо робити в напрямку заробітної
плати як буде формуватися заробітна
плата що буде з годинами для викладання
і так далі про систему та мережу Що буде
як буде формуватися
нова мережа тому що нам потрібно
запускати профільну школу нам потрібно
враховувати що є певна внутрішня
міграція людей нам потрібно розуміти що
сотні тисяч дітей батьків знаходяться за
кордоном і нам потрібна ефективно
використовувати ресурси планово п-
планувати мережу таким чином щоб кожна
дитина отримала рівний доступ до знань і
до і була певна мобільність і звичайно
що про трансформацію навчального
простору Але сьогодні ми фокусуємося
якраз на бомбосховищах і в чіткий план
як зробити так щоб максимальна кількість
людей почали навчатися офлайн і почали
навчатися офлайн в безпечному середовищі
я скажу чесно що ми почали займатися
після того коли було попереднє бачення
що ми будемо робити в якому напрямку
рухатися щодо трансформації системи
освіти і після того як було
перезавантаження Міністерства Ви
побачили Да щоб відбулося тотальне
перезавантаження Міністерства і
продовжується тому що там є багато
процесів які роками просто не
змінювалися Їх потрібно змінити
Ми почали занурюватися більше в деталі
не просто поверхнево приймати якісь
рішення і думати про те що ми знаємо всі
деталі Ми почали їздити по школам
спілкуватися з директорами по садочка
спілкуватися з учнями з батьками вивчати
дослідження вивчати всю літературу яка
доступна вивчати всі надбання аналітичні
які були створені до цього і сьогоднішні
результати
будемо презентувати і проекти вони також
побудовані на цьому вже досить які ми
отримали і звичайно що на експертах а їх
біля 2000 які були залучені у І
продовжують бути залученими у формування
нової візи всіх ланок освіти
трансформації нашої системи освіти якщо
знаєте в мене говорити про таке відчуття
що повинно відбутися з нашою системою
освіти в мене вже особисто як у
менеджера є певний досвід Да ми
побудували дію цифрову державу Працюємо
з телекомом дія там впроваджується в
інших країнах майже 20 млн користувачів
ще потрібно зробити багато чого але
багато чого вже зроблено наша нашім
мережі Телеком працює під час
повномасштабної війни ми працюємо з
супутниками та технологіями які
впливають те що відбувається на те що
відбувається на полі бою ми впроваджуємо
технологію війну тобто в нас вже є
певний досвід є певні результати але
якщо робити швидко резюме чому Нам
вдалося Що найголовніше найголовніше що
ми зробили цифровізацію поп культурою
для чиновників і державного управління
тепер кожен міністр перед тим як
запустити будь-який сервіс для громадян
він думає А як це зробити в першу чергу
цифровим сервісом А як зробити так щоб
людині було зручно і тоді коли почалася
вторгнення швидкі виплати для людей які
на території де відбуваються бойові дії
отримати електронний статус внутрішнього
переміщеної особи сповістити про
пересування ворога тобто десятки
сервісів які націлені на те А як зробити
так щоб українцю було зручно і якщо ми
повертаємося до візії до реформи система
освіти Наша задача зробити щоб освіта
стала новою поп-культурою не для
чиновників а встала для всього населення
щоб батьки були більше залучені у освіту
що там відбувається по яким стандартам
навчається діти чим відрізняється Росток
від нушу і так далі для того щоб вони
могли розбиратися в тому що відбувається
і для того щоб приймати рішення для того
щоб наші діти знали А куди рухаються
наша країна щоб наші вчителі чітко
розуміли Взагалі всі педагоги розуміли
чіткі план коли що буде зроблено і
навіщо вони повинні продовжити
інвестувати своє життя в наших з вами
дітей тому Наша задача зробити і засвіти
певну поп-культуру і ми будемо це робити
І знаємо як це зробити один із перших
продуктів які стосуються цифровізації ми
зараз над ним працюємо це буде проект
мрія Якщо коротко в чому ідея коли ви
вивчаєте досвід різних країн чому одні
країни стали багатими а інші країни
залишилися бідними це все сходиться до
того що потрібно будувати інклюзивні
інституції незалежні на яких спирається
суспільство де вони можуть себе
самореалізувати так робили Штати
наприклад так робить Британія так робить
всі країни де активно зростає рівень ВВП
і звичайно що це інвестиція в людський
капітал і розвиток людського капіталу
так от наша ідея для якщо ми хочемо
побудувати багато щасливу країну нам
потрібно розвивати людський капітал і
потрібно будувати інклюзивні інституції
також для взаємодії з інклюзивними
інституціями є дія де ти заходиш
реєструєш бізнес бачиш податки якщо в
тебе якісь проблеми подаєш в суд все що
стосується інклюзивних незалежних
інституцій для цього є дія є цифрова
держава і повний реінженерних всіх
процесів якщо ми говоримо про те як себе
реалізувати як дізнатися що є події на
яких я можу Де я можу взяти участь про
грантові програми А хто мій вчитель А
яка моя освітня траєкторія для цього є
мрія і тому в нашій державі для
самореаліза році повинні бути і ми
бачимо що будуть два таких великі
проекти це дія і це Мрія і якщо говорити
коротко про мрію я поки що не буду
робити там детальних спойлерів про це
буде окрема презентація але в чому суть
в тому щоб якщо ми говоримо про навчання
протягом життя про те що людина може
стати щасливою тільки тоді коли вона
себе знайшла зрозуміла чим вона може
займатися і присвячує своє життя цій
справі і розвивається в гармонії Наша
задача щоб дитина якомога раніше
зрозуміла все-таки свої сильні сторони і
що їй подобається так от задача мрії
аналізувати стандарти освіти тому що ми
це розуміємо де навчається дитина Хто в
неї Хто в неї вчитель або вчителі які
оцінки які контент вона додатковий
дивиться і що вона читає які в неї цілі
і на основі штучного інтелекту
допомагати через розуміння освітньої
траєкторії знаходити контент який буде
корисний і ми це все злегко зможемо
зробити і допомагати нашим дітям
знаходити інформацію що вони не сиділи в
тіктоках стільки щоб вони не сиділи
тільки в соціальних мережах а вон А ми
розуміли що їм потрібно і допомагали їм
розвиватися тому в мрії будуть і
щоденники мрії будуть буде і контент в
мрії буде можливість дізнатися більше
про свого педагога в мрії буде
можливість запропонувати якусь інновації
в навчальному закладі де навчається
дитина в мрії буде можливість знайти
грант в мрії буде можливість знайти
спортивний майданчик де можна займатися
в мрії буде якісна інформація про
систему освіти тому що неможливо
побудувати мрію без якісної системи без
якісної інформації і ми над цим працюємо
і думаю що вже наприкінці осені можливо
взимку Ми запустимо MVP тобто перший
версію цього продукту і Я впевнений що
він буде ще більш успішним аніж дія і це
буде можливість збирати якісну
інформацію для того щоб приймати як
якісні управлінські рішення тому що
неможливо
будувати
великий проекти робити великі
трансформації якщо не приймати рішення
на основі даних і дійсно точно не
розуміти що саме так втілюється цей чи
інший проект І наостанок Сьогодні ми з
вами багато говорили про те що
які ключові принципи на що ми будемо
спиратися зараз перейдемо до конкретних
проектів міністр буде про це розповідати
сьогодні будуть панелі вся ця візія буде
розшиватися далі до конкретних проектів
від онлайн Я хотів би сказати що
звичайно мотивує трильйона економіка
звичайно мотивує 100 тисяч доларів на
душу населення звичайно мотивує країна
яка може виробляти технології які не
дозволять щоб Росія знову на нас напала
але я хотів би щоб увімкнули відео Я
сьогодні зранку його побачив в чаті
батьків моєї дитини Я хотів би сказати
показати вам його
[музика]
і я хоть там якщо ви бачите дитинко в
окулярах із прапором то це моя донька я
хотів би сказати що ми будемо дотискати
цю реформу до результату цю
трансформацію Це бачення ці проекти які
будуть реалізовуватися тому що ми вміємо
це робити тому що ми знаємо навіщо ми це
робимо тому що в нас є діти які
навчаються яких ви сьогодні навчаєте
Дякую всім
[оплески]
Михайло Федоров Дякую вам дякую
за дію за мрію та за все просто
подякуємо ще раз Михайло Федоров
Будемо продовжувати без перерв
продовжуємо далі І я хочу під ваші
пухливі Оплески запросити до слова
Оксана лісового міністра освіти і науки
України
раз раз Доброго дня шановні колеги я
надзвичайно радий бачити вас всіх в
офлайні бачите вас вживу
однією з наших цілей коли ми приходили
командою Міністерство це було саме знову
подивитися очі в очі педагогам
директорам шкіл управлінням дітям дітям
найперше звичайно нашим дітям нашим
підліткам це те чого так бракувало нам
всі ці роки це те що так об'єднує нас і
так надихає нас дає нам сили дає нам
енергію я надзвичайно радий бачити вас Я
дуже радий тому що до нас в онлайні
доєдналися велика спільнота педагогів і
я хотів би
продовжуючи тему мрії
тему освіти і тему Перемоги трошки дуже
Коротко розказати вам про
іти внутрішні мотиви і
тілі задачі які ми ставимо перед своєю
командою на службі вам на службі нашій
системі освіти на службі нашій країні на
службі нашим майбутнім поколінням отже
освіта переможців ви бачили Це цей
цю назву цей лозунг на початку виступу
віце-прем'єр-міністра бачите його зараз
чому освіта переможців тому що ми з вами
чи іноді здається чи не забігаємо ми
наперед чи не поспішаємо ми з цими
переможними реляціями але насправді Ні
друзі мої ми з вами
проявили неймовірну силу витримку і
сміливість для того щоб протистояти тим
речам які здавалось яким здавалось
протистояти абсолютно неможливо ми з
вами маємо досвід
столітніх поразок ми з вами маємо досвід
терору і знищення нашої нації здавалось
би що десь на рівні прошивки У нас є
якийсь страх перед цим злом з якими в
черговий раз стикаємось але ми знову
встаємо і знову боремося і знову
проявляємо сміливість і знову ми стаємо
переможцями тому що ми подолали свій
страх в черговий раз і сьогодні коли ми
з вами фантазуємо да іноді абсолютно
фантастичні речі говоримо тому що я не
скажу що
віце-прем'єр-мініст Федоров він генерує
абсолютно унікальні ідеї і іноді Ми
слухаємо і думаємо це фантастика але це
точно стане реальністю і для цього
просто треба сміливість переможців І
зараз я хотів би показати вам такий
слайд
це моя фотографія Це е-е трошки більше
року тому рік і один місяць
Донецьк село Долина школа Долинська
зруйнована чотирма ударами ракети
ударами чотирьох ракет
в школі не стояв контингент
всі хто працює на нулі знають що ні в
школах ні в дитячих садочках стояти не
можна тому що туди прилетить в
будь-якому разі тому що противник так
само знає що там не стоїть Континент Він
б'є по світі Він б'є в саме це він б'є в
наше майбутнє Він прагне нас
демотивувати і прагне нас деморалізувати
ця школа буде відбудована як і сотні
інших повністю зруйнованих шкіл які
тисячі пошкоджених шкіл вони будуть
відбудовані Питання в тому Про що ми
мріємо коли говоримо про відбудову ми
так знаєте ради інтересу поставили
завдання штучному інтелекту відбудувати
школу в Долині на основі цих даних
вийшло смішно вийшло смішно І це точно
не те чого ми прагнемо ми точно не
хочемо такої відбудови ми точно не
хочемо таке оновлення бо це оновлення Не
єсть і це до речі ще одне свідчення чому
штучний інтелект ніколи не замінить
людину повністю штучний інтелект - це
інструмент на службі людини Сьогодні ми
на панелях про це поговоримо штучний
інтелект - це інструмент який буде
інтегрований в мрію для того щоб служити
нашим живим людям серцями з емоціями з
тими самими мріями відбудувати краще ніж
було build Back Better Ми всі з вами
часто чуємо цей лозунг
що ми вкладаємо в цей сенс перш за все
Який сенс Ми вкладаємо всі слова
перш за все звичайно відбудова
інфраструктури це те що нас турбує
найбільше на сьогодні найбільше турбує
безпека наших дітей Ми знаємо ми з вами
маємо ось абсолютно свіжу біду яка
трапилась на Сумщині у нас Ми маємо з
вами достатньо таких прикладів і ми
думаємо про те як зробити нашу
інфраструктуру безпечною
друге Ми хочемо зробити нашу
інфраструктуру сучасною ми мріємо про
абсолютно нові простори але ми також і
мріємо про нові сенси Ми також мріємо
про нову культуру ми мріємо про новий
зміст освіти ми мріємо про нову
методологію ми мріємо про все це і ми
працюємо на це все працюємо вже працює
вже не одне покоління педагогів Це не
значить ні в якому разі не подумайте що
ми тільки мріємо Так ми ви прекрасно
знаєте скільки ви вже зробили сьогодні
тут присутні попередні міністри освіти
прогресивні міністри освіти які багато
зробили для модернізації освіти і ми
сьогодні всі єдиною командою міністри
попередніх
департаменти управління освіти відділи
освіти директори шкіл педагоги батьки
громадські організації диміломатичні
представництва які підтримують Україні
це все ті люди які хочуть от одержати
новий результат А ось ще одна людина яка
хоче одержати зовсім інший результат
Максим Нагорний військовослужбовець
боєць збройних сил України
він каже багато говорить про відбудову
України після війни про відновлення
економіки зруйнованих міст але я не
згодний відбудовувати країну в якій я
зростав Я мрію про нову зовсім іншу і
набагато кращу країну яку варто
побудувати заново
це те чого очікує від нас суспільство
воно очікуємо модернізації
запит суспільства нам всім відомий ми
будуємо нову країну ми будуємо нову
систему освіти важливо усвідомлювати
одну річ Україна
успадкувала систему освіти Радянського
Союзу
давайте визнаємо це ми не будували
систему освіти для нашої країни і тим
більше ми не будували систему освіти для
країни Європейського Союзу для країни
яка входить в євроатлантичні альянси
перспективі для країни
демократичної для України
людинацентричної наша система
послуговуємось мережею закладів і самими
закладами і системою освіти яка була
збудована свого часу радянським союзом
Ми модернізовуємо її ми надзвичайно
багато робимо для того щоб змінити її і
ми повинні продовжувати цю роботу цього
очікують Такі люди як Максим Нагорний
цього очікують мільйони наших бійців для
себе для своїх сімей тому що ветерани
повернуться з фронту їм потрібно буде
вони здебільшого Це я вам кажу як людина
з того середовища вони здебільшого
переосмислюють свою роль роль Вони
шукають для себе нові призначення і їм
потрібно буде освіта
всі хто пройшов Випробування багато
переосмислювали із сьогодні вони бачать
себе інакше в майбутньому світі І
сьогодні вони бачать Україну іншою
так щось мене з презентацією так
поки перезавантажується презентація ми з
вами можемо говорити про
ми можемо говорити про будь-які
інновації сьогодні в освіті так
дякую дякую Отже ми говоримо про те що
ми трансформуємо освіту від радянської
спадщини видаляємо метастази радянської
системи і будуємо формуємо нову освіту
так що з моїм
дякую
коли команда Міністерства прийшла
5 місяців тому до Міністерства і я був
запрошений Президентом України і
проголосований урядом з обійняти цю роль
перше на чому ми зосереджувались це на
формуванні Перше завдання яке нам було
поставлена це формування візії
майбутнього
нашої Української освіти
тієї нової освіти для нової країни
на протязі
кількох місяців ми працювали над візією
працювали з широкою командою з
міністерством цифровізації під
керівництвом віце-прем'єр-міністра мали
консультації на рівні президенту України
на рівні комітету з питань освіти
України на рівні Верховної ради на рівні
прем'єр-міністра щодо того якими будуть
соціальні наслідки таких бачень щодо
того якою буде економіка майбутньої
освіти щодо того що ми можемо дозволити
собі А що ми не можемо дозволи собі під
час війни
ми презентували візію після того як ми
отримали загальну підтримку на
політичному рівні Ми почали рухатись
далі в своєму стратегуванні і залучили
велика експертне коло до обговорення
цієї візи той хто не долучений був з
присутніх залі або з тих хто дивиться
нас в онлайні не був долучений до роботи
над візією можуть перейти по qr-коду і
ознайомитись з усіма деталями тим більше
Також ми будемо на панелях сьогодні
розкривати елементи цієї візії і
обговорювати їх тут
Головне що Нам вдалося на сьогодні ми
залучили більше тисячі 700 експертів
до обговорення візії Ми отримали понад 6
тисяч проблем які були озвучені в ході
цього обговорення Ми отримали більше 11
тисяч пропозицій і рішень ми провели 14
силіційних онлайн сесій у нас було шість
блоків якісь із цих блоків і кожна із
них кожен блок присвячений певній галузі
освіти позашкільна дошкільна школа
профтех вища наука якісь з них пройшли
досить успішно в якихось був досягнутий
консенсус якісь проходили досить складно
наприклад в школі у нас
310 учасників було в дискусіях і ця
дискусія проходила досить складно досить
напружена і вона має бути продовжена і
вона буде продовжена тому що це важлива
складова для формування це обговорення
це суспільна дискусія це важлива
складова для формування національної
стратегії розвитку освіти на
до 2030 року
стратегія такої складної галузі як
освіта не народжується просто і не
народжується швидко будь-яка стратегія
яка народжена за кілька тижнів або за
місяць в таких галузях це профанація
Тобто ми сьогодні говоримо що ми
працюємо
над стратегію залучаючи експертне
середовище залучаючи громадськість
залучаючи всі сфери суспільства тому що
освіта стосується всіх і Ми продовжуємо
цю роботу і вона буде тривати стільки
скільки необхідно для того щоб ми
досягли зрілого і якісного результату
щоб ми досягли суспільного консенсусу в
тому якою буде освіта в 2030 році а
освіта повинна бути спрямована звичайно
на людину на людину креативну на людину
вільну на людину базовану на системі
цінностей демократичного і вільного
суспільства
це те
ради чого не будувалась попередня
система освіти і якщо ми говоримо що ми
послуговуємось з певними залишками такої
радянської системи освіти то ми говоримо
в першу чергу про стіни в яких зростали
наші діти в яких зростав я в тому числі
моя школа хороша Я дуже люблю своїх
вчителів я ціную і так згадую
згадую той час з епітетом шкільний Але
тим не менше Моя школа була більше схожа
на тюрму насправді вона мабуть
проектувалась одними і тими ж
архітекторами
багато таких шкіл працює і досі І от
Сьогодні у нас є шанс
Сьогодні у нас є можливість сьогодні
величезні інвестиції будуть іти в
відбудову України і перше і важливе що
повинно відбудовуватися це повинні
відбудовуватися заклади освіти дитячий
садочки які повинні бути спрямовані на
такий закладення такого ядра для
подальшого розвитку дитини
щось у мене зависає презентація школи
які повинні бути середовищем креативу
середовищем розвитку особистості
середовищам і соціалізації Ми хочемо щоб
школи були транспарантними щоб в них
було багато соціальних просторів щоб ним
в них були просторі для розвитку ми
хочемо щоб профтехосвіта так само була
середовищем для професійного зростання
для чіткої ясної профорієнтації для так
само соціального зростання і закріплення
особистості
ми можемо ви скажете що тут якісь
фантастичні кадри та коли це все буде І
чи буде це взагалі але насправді
насправді Це дійсно е-е шанс сьогодні
історичний шанс України збудувати
фізично збудувати такі школи модерні
школи тому що такі інвестиції які ми
хочемо освоїти сьогодні Які Україна буде
освоювати вони дають цю можливість
ключові зміни які ми е-е будемо
обговорювати з вами і в контексті візії
і в контексті
сьогоднішньої серпневої конференції що
стосується дитячого садочку це перехід
від
принципів догляду до принципів розвитку
дитини це гарантоване місце в закладі
дошкільної освіти це нова система оплати
праці педагога-дошкільника дошкільного
ми взагалі приділяємо особливу увагу і
це доручення президенту України тому що
у нас навіть вперше мабуть в історії
Міністерства освіти є заступник з
дошкілля і це була вимога і Це була
пропозиція президента України щоб у нас
був окремий заступник з дошкільної
освіти
дошкільники відреагували так
аплодисменти президенту України в даному
випадку це його була ідея я її
задоволенням звичайно підтримав і у нас
дуже креативна заступниця от сидить
Євгенія Смірнова
[оплески]
дуже активна Я переконаний що ми зробимо
унікальну унікальні речі в дошкільній
освіті
легкий вхід у професію ми знаємо
продефіцит кадрів в дошкільній освіті і
ми хочемо зробити доступ до цієї
професії легким швидким який буде
озброєний відповідними відповідними
навчальними програмами
розробка концепції дизайну нових форм
закладів дошкільної освіти те що
стосується школи Михайло Федоров уже
говорив про особливу увагу новій
українській школі Ми продовжуємо цю
реформу ми працюємо над нею ми її будемо
реалізовувати і зараз ми до речі Комітет
з питання освіти присутній тут Комітет з
питань освіти і голова і члени комітету
вони вже зробили дуже багато для того
щоб нуш продовжив фінансуватися
півтора мільярди передбачено уже в
бюджеті піднято субвенції передбачено в
бюджеті Міністерства освіти Зараз ми
працюємо разом з Кабінетом міністрів над
механізмом фінансування і найближчим
часом будуть прийняті одна або кілька
постанов щодо виділення цієї субвенції
тому готуйтеся ми навчаємо педагогів ми
закуповуємо обладнання Ми продовжуємо
трансформувати простір але в школі
[оплески]
але в школі ми також прагнемо повністю
трансформувати шкільний простір і для
цього сьогодні уже теж під е-е
ініціативою віце-прем'єр-міністра
укладений договір з рядом громадських
організацій та архітектурних компаній
щодо розробки нових типових проектів
закладів загальної середньої і
дошкільної освіти
це проекти які будуть використовуватися
вони багаторазового використання які в
першу чергу ми спрямовуємо на
трансформацію на реконструкцію
старих радянських типових шкіл ви знаєте
типові проекти ті п'ять
дехто говорить п'ять дехто говорить сім
типових проектів які єсть Ну ми ми
готуємо п'ять реконструкцію 5 типових
проектів робота над цим уже триває
фінансування цього цієї програми уже
розпочалося продовжується робота над
новими стандартами
для профільної старшою профільної школи
Ну і звичайно
нова система оплати праці для вчителів і
директорів Ця програма вже запущена ми
всю 23-24 рік це робота
формування політик і експертизи в
24-25 році ми виходимо на пілотний
проект
плануємо попередньо реалізувати його в
500 школах
щодо нового формату оплати праці і тут я
зупинюсь детальніше трошки буквально
трошки тому що ми будемо багато говорити
з вами і в рамках серпневої і потім в
процесі обговорень підходів до зміни
оплати праці а і ще кілька наскрізних
речей так створення сучасної ефективної
мережі закладів це той виклик який
стоїть перед нами
зміна принципів підбору та навчання
працівників та менеджерів освіти це те
про що говорив Михайло Федорів і це
такий проекти та велика така Підводна
частина роботи над якою працює сьогодні
Міністерство освіти цифровізація і
моніторинг якості освіти Ми хочемо
базуватися на якісних даних для цього ми
повинні провести повну цифровізацію
тотально цифровізацію системи освіти ви
розумієте Наскільки ці речі змінюють в
принципі
який вплив Вони мають на подальше
управлінські рішення на фінансування
найефективність на швидкість прийняття
рішень Ну і зміна в принципі оплати
праці щодо оплати праці в експерименті
Ми хочемо вийти з єдиної тарифної сітки
Ми хочемо щоб
базова частина заробітної плати була
біля
80% біля 20% надбавки і ще кілька
надбавок регіональних доплат і доплати
від директора школи Тобто ми робимо її
зрозумілою прозорою
прогнозованою І
саме головне Ми прагнемо підвищити
заробітну плату Питання в тому Наскільки
швидко нам вдасться зробити це в
контексті вини якщо б ми сказали зараз і
говорили зараз про підвищення зарплати
то було б очевидно що під час війни в
економіці яка працює на фронт це зробити
Ну практично неможливо але змінити
систему і змінити підходи і поступово
готуватися до
введення нового підходу і нових
принципів - це те над чим ми зараз
працюємо
власне от той слайд який присвячений
цьому тобто кілька премій регіонально
надбавка премія від директора школи до
20% різноманітних доплат і базова ставка
посадовий оклад 80%. це те над чим ми
думаємо і те про що ми з вами будемо
говорити і обговорювати разом далі Отже
шановні друзі для того щоб ми з вами
досягли тої мрії майбутньої освіти Ми
повинні бути такими ж сміливими якими ми
були коли розпочалася Нова хвиля агресії
Ми повинні мати ідеї працювати над цими
ідеями І вірити в ці ідеї але саме
головне що я хотів сказати
освіту майбутнього не сформують люди
майбутнього які прилетять сюди до нас
там я не знаю користуючись машиною часу
і не сформують люди які приїдуть до нас
із-за кордону освіту майбутнього
формуємо ми з вами якщо відмовляємось
від своїх стереотипів якщо починаємо
мислити креативно і критично якщо в
наших серцях є сміливість робити
неймовірні речі тому я дякую кожному з
вас Я сподіваюсь що ми це зробимо заради
майбутніх поколінь заради Максима
Нагорного і тих хто зараз воює заради в
кінці кінців наших з вами дітей і онуків
і заради нашої країни заради України
Слава Україні
[оплески]
Олександр
ви далеко не йдіть тому що ми переходимо
знову ж таки без перерв до першої
дискусії У нас цілий сет сьогодні
дискусій і перша відбудеться прямо зараз
отже вона буде присвячена викликам
звісно навчального року
2023-24 років як складнощі та проблеми
перетворити в можливості та переваги які
вони власне наші українські діти як
відбувається менеджмент освітньої
діяльності як забезпечити безпечний та
ефективний навчальний процес в абсолютно
різних умовах от це так в двох словах
про це і не тільки звісно далі піде мова
я з величезною радістю хочу запросити на
цю нашу імпровізовану таку сцену
модератора цієї панелі - це під ваші
Оплески Nomi на звання найкращий студент
світу 2023 року марівець ян стародувець
так
так Доброго ранку пані та панове Я радий
вітати сьогодні кожного і кожного з вас
Якщо чесно ще я ніколи не був серед
такої кількості освітян одночасно
так
але я знаю як важливо для нас усіх Ось
такі зустрічі особливо перед навчальним
роком особливо перед навчальним роком
який На жаль починається не так як мав
би не так як хотілось би
як для вас освітніх управлінців вчителів
так і для учнів але ми українці як ніхто
вміємо гуртуватись правда ж І цього в
нас правда не забрати ми стаємо опорою
для кожного для своїх близьких А
упродовж наступної години ми спробуємо
пошукати відповіді на запитання які
турбують усю освітянську спільноту разом
зі мною я вам стародубцем
випускником європейського колегіуму та
київської мою Академії наук і нашими
прекрасними спіраками а саме Михайло
федоровим віце-прем'єр-міністром з
інновацій розвитку освіти
науки та технології так Добрий день
оксаном лісовим міністром освіти і науки
України
Сергій бабаком головою комітету
Верховної Ради України з питань освіти
науки та інновації
андріям закалюком директором
департаменту освіти міста Львів
та прекрасною Наталією малець
директоркою школи номер 20 міста
Чернігів
[оплески]
Так отже пані Наталія тоді певне перше
питання до вас Якщо ви звісно не проти
на початку повномасштабного вторгнення
Чернігів став Північною фортецею не
тільки Києва а і з цієї України його
активно обстрілювали та руйнували з 24
лютого до кінця березня місто було в
оточенні але взяти його росіяни так і не
спромоглися увечері 6 березня 2022 року
як відомо вашу школу бо два прямих
влучення я не можу тільки уявити що від
чого Вита ваша команда у той час і
поділіться як до нового навчального року
готувалися ви як мотивували свою команду
і у чому можливо Потребуєте ось
найбільшої допомоги чи підтримки
Дякую за запитання Вітаю всіх освітян
які присутні в цьому залі і вітаю всіх
освітян України і звичайно хочу сказати
дякую тим хто боронить зараз наші
кордони завдяки кому ми сьогодні тут
насправді дуже важко говорити про те як
ми пережили останній рік адже наш заклад
півтора року
відбудовувався і це можна говорити не
тільки про наш заклад а багато закладів
України 6 березня 22-го року дійсно були
прямі перельоти на території нашої школи
але це було навіть не два А4 і в той час
в закладі були люди це були працівники
освіти і звичайно дуже боляче згадується
зараз той ранок 7 березня 22-го року
коли я приїхала вранці до школи і
побачила стіни але стіни я побачила І це
мабуть це звучить дивно але це в мене
порадувало тому що
я бачила в Чернігові зруйновані школи це
два заклади освіти які були вщент
зруйновані вже до цього випадку
дуже багато було пошкоджень ворожі
снаряди зруйнували дах було пошкоджено
систему опалення виведено з ладу дуже
багато кабінетів і звичайно здавалося що
все це відновити просто неможливо але
треба було зібратися з думками
мобілізувати всі свої сили і працювати
далі тим бачиш що нас захищало місто
вистояло і звичайно це також мотивувало
як ми прожили цей рік цей рік ми прожили
звісно досить важко тому що всі сили
були кинуті на відбудову школи і дуже
багато було витрачено всіх зусиль і тут
я хочу сказати про відновлення школи
саме місцевою владою тому що капітальний
ремонт який потребувала школа відбувся
саме за рахунок місцевого бюджету але
неможлива Скажем так відбудова школи
просто одним із зусиллями І звісно я тут
хочу згадати всіх благодійників
меценатів долучились до цього процесу
тому що у мене відразу Я хочу згадати
пані Ганну Новосад яка приїхала до нашої
школи влітку 22-го і сказали ось тут
кабінет найбільш пошкоджений це нова
українська школа А це ж наша реформа
тому давайте збирати кошти Це був єдиний
день народження і вона оголосила збір на
ремонт просто одного кабінету це було на
той момент знаєте просто хотілось
плакати тому що підтримка Вона звісно
важлива і ми хотіли відчувати і Це
звісно надихало далі це були фонд сейвед
який нам допоміг його відбудові
кабінетів зараз це надсучасні кабінети
інформатики хімії фізики
за підтримки Цей вид було організовано
та за сейф за Чілдрен освітній простір
який існував У нас в школі і почав
працювати з 3 жовтня і ось тут наприклад
дуже цікавий момент ми працювали
дистанційно навчальний рік 22-23
розпочали в дистанційному форматі але
саме завдяки освітньому центру який був
у нашій школі ну це було таке
надолуження освітніх втрат Це була
соціалізація це була психологічна
підтримка як спеціалістами так і одне
одного тому що ми приходили в школу із
своїми переживаннями стражданнями А
разом ми переживали все це досить легко
уже через рік 6 березня 23-го року наша
школа змогла відкрити свої двері для
офлайн навчання це були учні молодших
молодшої школи та середня ланка але це
було знаєте уже через рік ми змогли
вийти паралельно з цим ремонти ще
відбувалися Але це вже була така знаєте
маленька велика перемога тому що ми
прийшли в наш заклад
наразі ремонт триває ми розпочинаємо
новий навчальний рік і мені хочеться
також Сказати що дуже багато організацій
долучається до відбудови
всіх кабінетів всі і фонд сягання без і
ми розпочинаємо звісно знову ж таки
разом з ремонтами переживаннями
емоційними
фермертуванням класів тому що ми маємо
врахувати думки всіх учасників
освітнього процесу яку форму навчання
вони обирають
Мабуть що я складним в цей момент це те
що
наші рішення думки вони можуть
змінюватись кожен день тому що буквально
ви знаєте ситуацію в Чернігові території
стався 23 19 серпня І була пошкоджена
школа яка була прекрасна готова до
навчання були
поранені вбиті люди і ми маємо дуже
швидко реагувати на цей і ми наприклад
плануємо одне і Буквально через день Це
все міняється це все має команда
управліннянців і директорів керівників
шкіл на це все швидко реагувати тому що
думка суспільства змінюється в зв'язку з
тими чи іншими подіями мабуть в цьому
складність але ж якщо є команда якщо є
підтримка і держави і благодійників і
батьків
дітям треба йти в школу і треба
готуватись до нового навчального року я
розумію так дуже дякую Це
справді сильно Так звісно війна вносить
свої корективи але ми адаптуємось і дуже
вам дякую за те що ви поділились своїми
емоціями Андрію а якщо Чернігів став
все-таки Північний фортецею України то
Львів домівкою і прихистком сотень тисяч
тих хто втікав від обстрілів Мені
хотілось би чесно сказати що у Львові До
речі що однак це літо і цинічно ракетний
обстріли от як наприклад у 6 липня під
час якого загинув у Львові на жаль 10
людей довели що ні одне місце в Україні
на жаль зараз не є 100% безпечним і
віддавність лінії фронту все-таки нічого
не гарантує як до нового навчального
року готуєтесь ви особисто як очільник
Департаменту освіти міста І як воно
масштабна війна вплинула на освіту міста
чи готові Львівські школи до такого
припливу ВПУ будь ласка поділіться
Дякую за запитання найперше Напевно що
потрібно згадати те що ми найскладніший
шлях в тому як ми маємо вчитися під час
війни ми прийшли Минулого року тому що
ми ціле літо Минулого року мали велику
дискусію це певно була одна з
найскладніших дискусій в місті як має
відбуватися навчальний рік чи діти мають
йти у школи чи діти мають вчитися
дистанційно все ж таки позиція міста
була такою створити максимальні умови
для того щоб максимально повернути дітей
з Арт якщо ми станом на початок вересня
Минулого року мали близько
75 80% дітей які повернулися у школи то
вже до жовтня Фактично це було близько
95%. тому що батьки побачили що укриття
готові є можливість навчати дітей і це
був пріоритет міста повернути дітей за
парти Особливо я буду дуже відверто
говорити якщо це стосується учнів
початкових класів тому що роки ковіду
роки війни дуже дали великий негативний
результат на початкову школу
стосовно зараз Звичайно що пріоритет не
змінився безпека на першому місці так
морально ми трошки здали тому що в липні
і два тижні тому коли постраждав дитячий
садочок дуже 6 липня в нас постраждало
дві школи в одній з них 210 вікон Просто
всі повилітали це трошечки нам додало бо
ми не зустрічалися детально так як школи
у Чернігові з такими речами і тепер теж
маємо нові виклики переглядаємо питання
безпеки доробляємо укриття готуємо але
однозначно повертаємо дітей за парти
тому що це пріоритет номер один Ми не
можемо втрачати цей час і ці місяці діти
мають бути у школі але в безпеці
однозначно і ще один дуже важливий
момент про який я завжди говорю і буду
говорити це те що ми максимально маємо
ці речі комунікувати зі всіма говорити
проговорювати чути думку інших
переконувати тому що не можна просто
прийти і сказати що ми вчимося ми
минулого року відкривали укриття два
місяці і казали батькам ходіть дивіться
тут безпечно діти можуть вчитися і ми
повністю від страхи люди мають свої
переживання зрештою будемо чесні дорогі
друзі батьки віддають найцінніше що є І
це треба завжди цей Фактор психологічний
розуміти і його враховувати тому так
готуємося і в принципі готові і
починаємо новий навчальний рік Дякую
звісно так ну і правда все-таки і
батьками освітянам потрібно перейматися
за укриття самим допитуватися з цього
питайте у директорів шкіл і вчителів Чи
все безпечно адже ми всі розуміємо що
діти це наші найцінніше що ж тепер
питання до вас пане михайле буде таке
бліц-питання ви надзвичай цікава людина
і дуже багато молоді саме ви мотивуєте і
ось питання до вас якими були учнем Чи
ви би шкідливим чи пропускали можливо
уроки от поділіться з нами адже ви
справді мотивуюча людина цікаво так
повернулась підготовка до навчального
року
та й в принципі напевно я був дуже
активний і ходив на всі гуртки Які можна
було ходити і там вишивав і шахи і
футбол там і боротьба ну тобто все чим
можна займатися я займався і там Добре
що такі можливості були різні гуртки
тому якщо так коротко зробити резюме
мого дитинства це активність постійна
тобто пошук себе змагання
дізнаватися розбиратися методологічно
якщо побудовано як там досягати
результату в принципі я потім і на
соціологію також на соціології почали
навчатися тому що це також якраз про те
як е-е
розібратися з різними сферами Чому вони
так функціонують які правила і так далі
тому в принципі як звичайно дитина всі
Так звісно я теж помітив що я прогулював
Дякую що ви на відміну тебе Я теж
насправді помітив що активність дітей
Вона справді важлива коли дитина справді
зацікавлена Ось це те що мотивує діяти
далі а ось пане Оксана а ось розповісти
розкажіть про ваш досвід адже ви певний
час був керівником А ну який якраз дає
ці можливості спробувати дитину себе в
чомусь новому ось розкажіть ви чим ви
цікавились в дитинстві і чи уявляли себе
міністром освіти
Ні я точно не уявляв себе міністром
освіти в дитинстві яким завгодно не
уявляв себе космонавтом і міністром
освіти знаєте от але насправді Я вчився
в радянських школах мені довелося
повчитися і всебіру свого часу в
забайкалі і я навчався в самій звичайній
Радянській школі в місті Києві
єдиний хороший вибір який був це було Це
було багато роботу в того часу спорт був
активний він постійно пропонував
пропонував
заняття в гуртках і секціях я пробував
багато занять зупинився на фехтуванні
але займався Мені легше сказати чим я не
пробував займатися і все мені було
цікаво Насправді е-е те що стосується
того що вплинуло на моє формування школа
мала впливала на моє формування Бо
насправді я навчався добре там де мені
подобався вчитель і я погано навчався з
математики але я добре навчався з фізики
Як не дивно при тому що в мене мама
вчитель української мови Я погано
навчався з українською мовою бо в мене
був конфлікт з вчителем я гарно навчався
з російською мовою і літератури яка тоді
була яка тоді була обов'язково в школі і
все залежало від того чи вчитель надихав
чи Вчитель був відкритий дружелюбний чи
він помічав хороші риси учнів і я
помішав що це стосується не тільки для
мене тому безумовно А на світогляд мій
перш за все вплинуло читання літератури
тому що а насправді знаєте ми зараз дуже
часто порівнюємо себе з поколінням а-а
нинішнім от моє покоління там років 50+,
кажуть от Ми багато читали от ми були
іншими звичайно ми були іншими жили в
іншому світі звичайно ми багато читали в
нас не було взагалі ніякої альтернативи
книга це було Єдине вікно в світ вікно в
щось в якісь інші світи в якісь інші е-е
інші виміри і тому читав як неймовірно
багато і це те що розвинуло мою там
креативність і світогляд Так звісно я
повністю згоден що зацікавленість дитини
вона дуже залежить від вчителя і важливо
щоб вчитель він був не просто викладачем
предмету а й викладачем громадянство що
насправді вчителі вирощували класних
громадян і зацікавлювали дітей от але
математику теж треба вчить Я звісно вірю
те що українська література надзвичайно
класна Тому потрібно цікавитись звісно
усім А вчителям потрібно зацікавлювати і
пане Сергію питання до вас якщо в нас
вже така відверта е-е розмова Я Як
вчорашній школяр в мене таке питання чим
саме займається Комітет Верховної Ради
України з питань освіти науки та
інновації
чудове запитання Я дуже радий що воно як
ви сказали на початку турбує всіх
освітян дивіться як коротко спробую
відповісти в комітету є дві функції
законодавча і контрольно
законодавче ми пишемо закони ми їх
вносимо Верховну Раду ми їх адвокуємо ми
переконуємо колег ми забезпечуємо
голосими забезпечимо їх прийняття це
одна функція вона дуже важлива друга
Мені здається більш важлива це
контрольна функція тому що ми
контролюємо виконання законів це як
сказав Михайло Федоров своїй промові це
оцей алгоритм коли ти аналізуєш як
виконується закон бачить слабкі місця
Шукаєш Як його підкоригувати вносиш
зміни і знов приймаєш і це безкінечний
процес по великому рахунку і оця
контрольна функція вона нам дозволяє
вона насправді є найголовнішою тому що
вона нам дозволяє не тільки дивитися як
виконується чи не виконується закони а
брати окремі питання де ми бачимо що в
перспекти можуть бути якісь проблеми але
або вони вже починають починають
назрівати І ми тоді збираємо всіх з тих
ходерів вирішуємо що ми з цим будемо
робити проводимо комітетські слухання
Запрошуємо експертів Я думаю що більша
частина тих хто в залі колись були
долучені до цих експертної роботи до
цієї і потім даємо рішення але це
формально а насправді якщо простими
словами пояснити Це то от зараз от
Враховуючи те що парламент як правило
каденція парламенту значно більше ніж
каденція складу Кабінету Міністрів Ну от
зараз в нас вже ну при нашій каденції
вже третій Міністр освіти да то Наша
задача ми є по суті такою
фундаментальною командою підтримки
реформ
або запобіжником залежно від того яка
команда що хоче зробити хтось хоче одні
реформи хтось хоче інші реформи Наша
задача забезпечити наступність цих
реформ Ну наприклад розпочали в минулому
скликанні парламенту реформу нова
українська школа Наша задача ми можемо
підкорегувати але Наша задача
забезпечити наступність щоб незалежно
від складу Міністерства це реформа
продовжилась Тому що вона є
фундаментальною це саме стосується
зовнішнього незалежного оцінювання і
інших подібних реформ тому з одного боку
ми є командою підтримки а з іншого боку
є запобіжником бо можна мати хороші ідеї
під час реформування але знаєте як то
кажуть але випадково зробити щось
трішечки не так От для цього і є
насправді комітет який має досить
глибоку експертизу в своїй сфері і якраз
забезпечує оце прийняття оцей фундамент
який ми забезпечуємо прийняття
фундаменту на якому потім базується всі
реформи Так Дуже дякую в жодному разі не
ображайтесь але нормально так я вважаю
що це важливо щоб справді люди і учні
знали як працює освіта як працює ось це
в державі тому Дякую вам за відповідь і
повертаючись е-е до вас пане Михайло
сьогодні презентували бачення освіти
воно сміливе досить амбітне проте роз-
можете детальніше розповісти хто над нею
працював чи багато ви там опитували
вчителів директорів чи можливо навіть
долучали досвід міжнародних якихось шкіл
там інститутів і так далі ось важливо
знати це знаєте як там є в соціології
такі підхід коли ти використовуєш багато
різних методів для того щоб досліджувати
певне питання Так тут було саме
побудовано там полісімейкінг Аналогічно
тобто був окремий великий трек коли
Міністерство освіти залучало там майже
сьогодні були цифри 2 000 експертів які
були залучені там класно Міністерства
побудували роботу робочих групи
модиратори збиралися там проблематика
потім проговорювалися певні політики там
і так далі окремо була робота в групах
там
громадськими організаціями які вже там
досягнули там певного результату вони
були там постійно на радарах тобто
знаєте є такі гарячі теми які просто
потрібно брати і приймати наприклад як
розблокування субвенції нужда яку просто
там Постанову на днях буде прийнята з в
першу чергу гроші ну це термінове
питання які потрібно робити або там
доопрацювати стандарт Е нуш для старшої
професійної школи тобто є такі гарячі
питання де потрібна експертиза е-е
швидка
фундаментальна і просто брати і робити
звичайно ж ми спілкувалися багато із
міжнародними колегами і контент-аналіз
це знаєте коли ти від того що ти береш
книжку Про яку побудована система освіти
і Фінляндії там закінчуючи тим що ти
спілкуєшся там робиш Коли з колегами з
різних країн і просто робиш краш-тест
Без певних моделей тому що те що
сьогодні наприклад акцент показував по
моделі заробітної плати ну це там
піввідсотка від того ще насправді там
відбувається в цьому напрямку просто там
немає часу саме зараз це буде окрема
тема окрема панель там окремі дискусії
але це проектна робота щодо одного
питання зібрати найкращих експертів хто
в цьому розуміється Хто знає Там
світовий досвід змоделювати все потім
зробити там 100 разів краш-тест Тобто
всі методи всі методи використовувалися
і використовуються сьогоднішня наша
зустріч - це також тестування гіпотези
хтось з вас вийде в фейсбук і скаже Ах
ви ж там хочете так зробити і ми це
також будемо аналізувати або наприклад
ви напишете через там платформу там був
qr-код е-е там через Міністерство освіти
через де можна надавати зворотній
зв'язок до візі і скажете А давайте Я
хочу долучитися більш активно до цього
процесу ми зустрічалися з директорами
Їздили по школам тобто
комплексний підхід до формування
політики ми так робимо по кожній послузі
які яку запускаємо трансформуємо так
само робимо по кожному проекту який
стосується освіти Ну звичайно що добре
будуються зараз менеджмент в
міністерстві і є відповідальність за
кожен напрямок залучається багато
експертів донора активізувалися і те про
що говорив Сергій я там вважаю що він
один з найбільш ефективних голів
комітетів в нього цей національна
пам'ять є вони по кожному напрямку люди
і вони також не дають забути певні речі
які потрібно підняти і впрова-
впровадити тому такі комплексний підхід
він дозволить щоб ми досягнули
результату Але найголовніше Я не перший
рік вже на жаль чи щастя працює там в
уряді і
я бачу багато класних ідей концепції
проектів які не закінчувалися
провадженням от найголовніше чого
постійно не вистачає багатьом урядовим
командам це команди реалізації
впровадження Я наприклад досліджував
практику Британського уряду при уряді
Тоні Блера була побудована команда
впровадження яка брала кожен проект який
проговорюється аналізує його
впровадження так само ми наприклад
зробили в мінсорі У нас є таке певний
відділ теж саме ми точно побудуємо в
Міністерстві освіти і будемо
контролювати впровадження і це незалежна
команда яка проти Міністерства і за
людей для котрих ця реформа
впроваджується щоб не було багато
обговорень або в контроль за конкретним
результатом І ми також тут точно це
зробимо і точно буде публічний держборд
з проектами з з деталями реалізації і
системно-комунікація щоб залучати всіх
ключових людей до до цієї до цього
проекту так дуже дякую Це справді
важливо для батьків звісно щоб ось
освіта проходила декілька етапів
перевірок не хочеться звісно щоб на
дітьми якось експериментували і так далі
тому справді Дякую Ось за краш-тест Як
ви сказали насправді тут ще чомусь там
наприклад важливий проект мрія тому що
ми хочемо спілкуватися постійно з
батьками з учнями з вчителями напряму Ми
хочемо говорити що вашій школі 100
наприклад шкіл в вашому регіоні з точків
проходять Пілот нової системи оплати
праці Подивіться результати або
наприклад розуміючи що у дитинки є
системні покращення результатів
математика казати Дивись ось є гра це ж
Це елементарно робити якщо ти володієш
інформацією подивись є Гранд певний для
талановитих учнів або Олімпіада є певна
або там є певні певні конкурси або
Дивись в цій та школі дитина з такого ж
класу як і ти з паралелю умовно
досягнула результату там та там то що
мотивувати дітей тобто тому дуже важливо
в цифрову епоху мати цифровий інструмент
для того щоб бути постійно на зв'язку з
усіма Так звісно то ще правильно розумію
батьки теж повинні приймати дуже активну
участь у формі в культуру саме тому
освіта повинна бути покультура так я
саме Абсолютно згоден і давайте на цій
точці певно перейдемо до питання
надзвичайно важливого саме до питання
ментального здоров'я і ось Пане Андрію
як я знаю ви як директор Департаменту
освіти велику увагу приділяєте ось
освітнє управління міста і наприкінці
минулого навчального року організували
виїзд до Карпат спершу декількох сотень
директорів Шкіль Львова і згодом і для
керівників закладів дошкільної освіти з
якою мето ю і чимається якесь результат
все-таки
Я думаю що я повторю ці речі які
сьогодні говорили теж
найперше потрібно розуміти насправді що
в нас справді є проблема в питанні
освітнього менеджменту
велику великий період розвитку нашої
освіти цьому не приділялося великою
уваги і взагалі на це не ставилися жодні
акценти тобто так було насправді що ми
собі поставили за Ціль найперше
наших дітей і наших батьків
директори і вчителі мають в тому числі
дуже сильно підтримувати і ми собі
задаємо питання А хто підтримує наших
директорів і хто підтримує наших
вчителів а вони так само потребують
підтримки постійної І тому ми поставили
собі за Ціль створювати умови для того
щоб а мати абсолютно багато неформальних
майданчиків для спілкування керівників
шкіл тому що дуже часто наше спілкування
директорів шкіл може зводитися знаєте до
таких дуже формальних нарад де вони
прийшли ми їм сказали що робити І ми
розійшлися на цьому воно так не працює
насправді люди мають мати майданчик для
вільного спілкування ділення досвіду
другий момент Який теж є насправді дуже
важливий такі речі виїзди спілкування
конференції вони дозволяють людям
почуватися вільними і я взагалі кажу і
повторюю із своїм директорам кажу і
вчителям кажу друзі ключове що ми маємо
з вами робити це створювати умови щоб
кожен міф себе вільно почувати не зможе
творити Людина яка не свобідна не зможе
творити директор який не відчуває
Свободи волі і ці речі дуже важливі щоб
керівники шкіл просто теж побачили що ми
для них партнери і Ми для них підтримка
Ми ні в якому разі не жоден там
контролюючий орган чинов Херсонський
орган і тому подібне ми є ці люди які
насправді спільно разом з ними творимо
екосистему освіти міста і коли ми не
будемо мати таких майданчиків для
спілкування таких виїздів таких навчань
таких тренінгів підтримки нам буде дуже
складно тому що ми просто поглинемо
знову в рутину і в рутині будемо
крутитися обговорювати це все але ми
якби свіжого повітря ніхто не отримає а
його мають отримувати директори мають
дотримувати гарні досвід ми з вами маємо
всі разом працювати так щоб створити
умови для того щоб директор міг отримати
максимальний досвід з різних куточків
світу
побачити його пережити його
переусвідомити його і дальше друге
завдання наше просто створити йому умови
що він це міг робити дальше оце про що
сьогодні говорили і це дуже важливі речі
тому ми з своєї сторони це і робимо воно
часом знаєте не завжди може виглядати
так знаєте поїхали на чотири дні
директорів Карпати результати
фантастичні
фантастичні люди приїжджають зовсім з
іншим мисленням люди приїжджають вільні
свобідні слухайте вони горять і летять і
наше завдання не не не заважати їм тому
це важливо Так Дуже дякую за вашу таку
демократичну думку я теж вважаю що це
справді важливо особливо в XXI столітті
цьому обов'язково повинні приділятися
увага пане Наталія А ось ви спростуйте
чи підтвердили ось теж попередню думку
ось зсередини Як ви теж Бачите як
взагалі зараз вчителі налаштовані ось
звісно початок нового року шкільного і
все-таки всі почу звісно збільшує
енергію ніж наприкінці ось якщо коротко
То як ви бачите це з середини
на Андрія Мені дуже подобається є
підтримаю на 100%. але я почну саме із
емоційної складності наших дітей тому що
починаючи з найпростішого коли ми
переформатовуємо класи і повідомляємо
батькам що ми будемо переводити вас із
класу в клас тому що наприклад на
паралелі не утворюється дистанційний
клас або ж батьки не можуть обрати
дистанційну форму Тому що хочуть очну
або коли не можуть Приступити до очного
навчання хочу дистанційну А класу
дистанційного не можемо відкрити ці
батьки змушені переходити на
індивідуальну форму здобуття освіти або
ж переходити в інший Заклад як би для
нас освітян не звучало це досить просто
батьки напишуть заяву підуть Але це вже
стрес для самих дітей тому що діти
кажуть Ми тут звикли Ми не хочемо Ми
хочемо навчатись у цьому класі а тим
паче в цій школі переходити в інший
заклад Тобто це Такі емоції які не можна
сказати що вони позитивні це більш такі
стресові емоції можливо вони і не є там
занадто чим страшним але все ж таки вони
є коли ми переходимо до педагогів то
педагоги говорячи з класом дітей і
батьків переживають ці емоції внутрішні
і також ці емоції не завжди є
позитивними тому що батьки приходять і Я
особисто ж знаю коли вони йдуть до
класного керівника тоді вони йдуть до
керівників і всі керівники Я думаю мене
зараз підтримають тому що це Буря емоцій
це хвилювання батьків чому я не можу
залишитися у цьому класі Чому я маю
перейти чому не можуть відкрити
дистанційний клас Ми пояснюємо наприклад
що ми не можемо відкрити на паралелі з
трьох класів четвертий клас правильно
тому що це збільшення має бути субвенція
вона є така яка вона є або це може бути
ще її зменшення ми маємо бути в рамках
того що є правильно і тому це теж емоції
і ці всі емоції Вони вже так і
докочуються до кого До керівника або
директора закладу і ось тут директор має
з керівник має так скажемо так все
закрутити зробити щоб всі були
задоволені були задоволені всі своїм
вибором були задоволені те що сталось
там і так далі але це одна сторона інша
- це те що ми постійно всі уже не перший
рік перебуваємо в стані стресу Ми живемо
в стані війни і ми маємо навчитися бути
стресостійкими ми маємо вчитись долати
оті труднощі зовнішні і впливи зовнішні
негативні які є збоку і я розумію як я
можу сказати Я звісно коли вчитель плаче
і каже що моя сильна виходить третій
день на зв'язок коли дитина чекає батька
з полону оце все цей клубок емоцій
стресу він накопичується і ми маємо бути
настільки стресостійкими долати і
адаптуватися під ті умови для того щоб
потім ми
вижили і це заради нас самих нас і
заради наших дітей тому що ми маємо іти
до дітей з Позитивом ми вдома пошепки
говоримо про якісь негативні речі щоб
наші діти не сприймали тому що вони
сприймають наших хвилювання сприймають
на себе Так же само в класі діти які є
перед нами наші діти вони не мають
відчувати хвилювання і я не маю нести
якісь емоційний сплеск негативний на
свій колектив Я думаю зі мною погодяться
всі керівники і вчителі також дякую
звісно
Так Дуже дякую Знаєте тут Я перейшов
навіть до статистики пана Оксана згідно
дослідженням яке проводило освітня
фундація go-global наприкінці 22-го року
більше ніж
80% учителів відчувають емоційне
виснаження 61% батьків вважають що їхні
діти мають симптоми стресу так як
погіршення сну тривожність труднощі з
концентрацію проблеми з комунікацією
йдеться в досвідчення благодійного фонду
сейв на своїй сторінці у Фейсбуці ви
нещодавно написали що не піти на перший
урок віддати перевагу сну в разі якщо
Була нічна тривога це нормально Що
здоровий Хуст має перемагати що робить
держава собі мон для того щоб
підтримувати ментальний стан учителі від
дітей адже ми розуміємо наскільки це
важливо чи будуть якісь рекомендації як
діяти в тих чи інших ситуаціях очікували
і директор школи та просто будь-якій
людині адже у наш період це надзвичайно
важливо Дякую Ну я почну з того що
взагалі динамізм і гнучкість - це та
властивість яку
яку ми повинні плекать в освіті які в
будь-якій системі ви бачите Ми там це
літо займались
сховищеми займались перші блоком
безпековим Там блоком е-е Там доступу до
онлайн навчання рішення ми пов'язаними з
навчанням дистанційним людей які
знаходять за кордоном людей які
знаходяться на окупованих територіях і я
вам скажу що постійно виникають ситуації
які змінюють правила гри ми розробили
певний підхід трапляється ситуація
чергова Атака російська на наш- ми
бачимо Як це працює ми бачимо відстані
ми бачимо що вони використовують і ми
повинні змінити свої стратегії те що
стосується ментального здоров'я Ми
повинні розуміти одну річ
наша нація буде довгий час страждати від
е-е
посттравматичного синдрому
навіть ті хто зараз говорить що в мене
все Ок вони
Несвідомо ще не свідомі того наскільки
травмованих психіка і безумовно що
вчитель тут несе
подвійне навантаження він не може вилити
свої емоції не може випустити їх назовні
він повинен тримати себе в рамці цій
темі приділяється велика увага Ну
по-перше звичайно я хочу сказати одну
річ не треба очікувати папірця на кожен
проблему це треба звичайно керуватися
здоровим глуздом і вчитель і директор
школи дуже добре відчуває ситуацію у
себе і він може і має можливості вжити
тих заходів необхідних керуючись
здоровим глуздом яких потрібно вжити для
того щоб нормалізуватися ситуацію в
школі в класі нормалізуватися
психологічний стан самої дитини але з
іншого боку на рівні держави величезна
увага цьому приділяється єсть окремо цим
займається перша леді України єсть
окремий проект який стосується
ментального здоров'я е-е разом з Юнеско
розробляється цілий комплекс рішення
пов'язаних з роботою в цьому напрямку і
тут звичайно Міністерство освіти є
учасником цього процесу
Ну і звичайно перед це стосується
взагалі перезавантаження психологічної
служби в системі освіти цей проект Ну і
друге - це
прості прикладні речі скільки у нас
психологів в школі півставки тобто Зараз
ми працюємо над тим щоб і один психолог
дуже часто працює на дві на три школи
Зараз ми працюємо над тим щоб був як
мінімум один психолог на одну школу щоб
він міг охоплював своєю увагою колектив
педагогічний колектив
учнівський і колектив батьківський Так я
розумію наскільки це важливо Хоча і з
тим щоб проте я розумію природничник Я
розумію що психологія це теж є важливим
чомусь в нас все-таки стереотип що
психологія - це другоряни чи навіть
третій рядними предмет Проте це
абсолютно неправда психологія є
надзвичайно важливою і трохи додам до
вашої відповіді правда що вчителі якщо
ви думаєте чи діти якщо ви думаєте що у
вас немає можливості отримати
психологічну допомогу то знайте що до
речі от юнісеф які є партнерами сьогодні
нашого заходу розробили всеукраїнський
урок ментального здоров'я який
називається зробити як повертаємось до
школи розроблений Універсал до 1 вересня
щоб розказати про важливість піклування
про своє психічне здоров'я та як це
зробити за допомогою досить простих
практики досить простих кроків вчитель у
кожному класі зможе запустити
відеоматеріал психологів та разом з
учнями навчитися кільком практикам саме
підтримки от матеріал розмістять 28
серпня на сайті мон тож обов'язково
Слідкуйте ми розуміємо наскільки це
важливо і будь ласка підтримуйте дітей і
запитання до вас в Сергію не менш
важливою за ментальне здоров'я безпека
звісно фізична безпека тих хто
навчається і ми знаємо що цьогоріч з
державного бюджету було виділено півтора
мільярди гривень на обладнання укриттів
також за облаштуванням укриттів суттєво
допомагали благодійні фонди які ми дуже
дякуємо місцевим бізнесом Утім все-таки
немає єдиного стандарту укриття як би
там не було яким на вашу думку воно має
бути щоб там було комфортно от як воно
виглядає для вас Якщо коротко чи бралами
якісь приклад можливо з Ізраїлю
гарне запитання насправді коли ми
говоримо про стандарти укриття то можна
розглядати його в двох аспектах перша от
як воно має виглядати які до нього
вимоги по ДСТУ ДБН Дана з книги якій
глибині Вона має бути як воно має бути
взагалі виглядати з точки зору прямої
безпеки від влучань наприклад ракет і це
окрема дуже важка тема Ми намагалися До
речі ще перед тим як формували цю
субвенцію в державному бюджеті ми
намагалися би і говорили з міністерством
інфраструктури з ДСНС щоби зробити якісь
один типовий план яким має бути укриття
але потім ми в е просто вперлися в
проблему да Що окремо таким можна
запланувати такі речі Наприклад в селі
якщо є скажімо стадіон на вулиці да під
ним можна побудувати справжнє укриття
або ну розібрати стадіон з потім знову
зібрати і це спрацює але наприклад в
містах це неможливо особливо в великих
містах от я вам Для прикладу скажу Я
кожного дня з роботи їду приїжджаю по в
школу яку я закінчу Вона знаходиться в
Києві на круглоуніверсите там вже давно
забудували за останні там 20 років і
спортивний майданчик і там маленькі
парки який був там тільки будівлі
залишилися навколо сама Школа 50-го року
приблизно будівництво от як зробити там
укриття ніяк її треба розібрати і
побудувати укриття а потім знову зібрати
там школу тобто для міст це насправді
велика проблема з типовими укриттям ми
на них кожне місто Я знаю що Харків - це
окремо вирішує Львів окремо вирішує Київ
окремо вирішує Мені здається що напевно
всі проблеми вирішити не вдасться Але
наблизитись до цього можна да А з точки
зору яким має бути укриття щоб там було
комфортно перебувати всередині Да но тут
не якраз таких прикладів на щастя дуже
багато в Україні і в кожному місті
великому в якому я був е-е я просто
бачив зусилля місцевої влади або
благодійних фондів або окремих фундацій
не буду казати кого навіть народних
депутатів деяких які займаються укриттям
ми це справді хороші комфортні укри
сказав Яким є нормальний вентиляція де
куди кондиціонування і водогін і
каналізація і все обладнано і там є
місця комфортні не тільки для
перебування а для проведення занять і
власне це те що ми намагаємося зробити в
укриттях для шкіл для взагалі для
закладів освіти тому що ми розуміємо в
деяких регіонах тривога може бути
годинами і там в цих укриттях потрібно
не просто перебувати там має бути
комфортно продовжувати навчання щоб
навчальний процес не зупинявся діяти
просто переходять в укриття і там він
далі продовжується от власне на для
цього ми і дали цю підтримку з бюджету в
півтора мільярди якщо чесно Це дуже мало
І треба збільшувати і мені шкода чесно
що в нас напевно трішки теж сил не
вистачило до давити що це на минулий
бюджет щоб все ж таки було більше бо
зараз ми бачимо як збільшується
кількість укриттів по Україні ми бачимо
скільки дітей зможуть отримати офлайн
освіту завдяки наявності цих укриттів і
ми чесно трі шки шкодуємо що виділили
так мало і будемо домагатися в
наступному бюджеті в рази підвищити тому
що наша мета в результаті зробити в усіх
100% закладів освіти укриття
Так Дуже дякую вам але от чи я пам'ятаю
свій досвід теж навчання в укритті і я
Ось недавно теж був на міській освітній
конференції міста Києва і насправді
майже кожен третій Кожен другий день На
жаль дітям доводиться спускатися в
сховища і таке питання от Якщо коротко
на вашу думку чи можливо щоб от прямо в
укриті зберігалася Ось ця освітня
атмосфера тому що все одно діти
починають ну бігати втрачати увагу Як ви
думаєте чи зможемо ми все-таки до цього
ось дійти щоб ви знаєте Я думаю що
насправді Все можливо мені здається що
ми за як нація за останній півтора роки
довели що в принципі Можливо все і ми
можемо все І це один з них з елементів
який я думаю на всіх не просто
об'єднаний він ми ним пронизані це
власне єдність у вирішенні проблем тому
я впевнений що наші талановиті вчителі
зможуть об'єднати дітей продати їм
комфортне перебування комфортне
психоемоційний стан для під час
перебування в укритті для того щоб все ж
таки продовжились заняття це насправді
дуже важливо причому для кожного
учасника освітнього процесу ми цього
прагнемо впевнений вчителі і директорі
це ж це цього правила Так я розумію і
ось До речі от тільки коротко бо в нас
не так багато часу Андрію і потім пані
Наталія чи справді ви можете підтвердити
думку от зсередини чи справді в укриттях
стає краща чи справді відбувається ось
ці зміни в укриттях чи ну все-таки є
певні складнощі і далеко не усі укриття
так гарно облаштовані як хотілось би
Давайте почнемо з вас Я думаю що вони
однозначно стають кращими і ми це
розуміємо тут дуже важливо щоб ми
насправді зберегли
динаміку цього і зрозуміли що щоб ми
знаєте я завжди кажу що ми не дійшли до
моменту нашої Перемоги і про це забули і
знову почали ми з вами в укриття зносити
все що треба і не треба Як в нас так
було насправді як тому дивіться
однозначно динаміка нас є однозначно
вона позитивна є тому що кожен на своєму
рівні розуміє керівник школи розуміє що
це потрібно начальник управління розуміє
місцева Влада розуміє зрештою ми маємо В
цьому плані дуже консолідоване
суспільство тому що ми не знайдемо в
місті щоб хтось був проти того щоб вчити
дітей
всі за навчальний процес а зараз
навчальний процес нам передбачають
безпечні умови тому батьки за учні за
місцева Влада За Тому це дуже
консолідоване питання тут просто питання
дуже багато технічних моментів я то що
пан Сергій сказав Я на своєму досвіді
скажу Це справді не просто тому що
надзвичайно у Львові теж у Львові є
школи де укриття їм 600 років які
будувалися в центральній частині міста є
будинки пам'ятки архітектури де не так
просто провести і провести якісь теж
будівельні роботи а є звичайні панельні
школи і це теж має бути дуже
Ми теж цей кейс якби проходили Тому то
дуже важливо мати індивідуальний підхід
до кожного питання бо дуже легко
насправді можна знаєте часом так
підвести все під одну риску і воно не
працює Так тут треба кожну історію кожну
школу кожне укриття якби дуже
індивідуально розглядати і тоді можна
виходити абсолютно на здоровий глуз на
здорове здорові нормальні укриття які
будуть а і безпечними б якщо є
можливість вчитися Окей не має
можливості то робити ті речі в укриті
які все ж таки в першу чергу будуть
знімати стрес дітей так тобто дитина в
укриті має займатися дуже раціональними
речами тому що мозок так працює що тоді
стрес падає дитину і простіше Так бо ми
знаєте зійдемо в укриття дитина в стресі
нам пізніше потрібно коли ми виходимо
закриття ще час щоб вивести дітей стресу
А ми знаєте дуже часто виводимо дітей з
укриття і зразу крім контрольну роботу з
математики
і потім часом думаємо чому дитина не
окна писала і тому ці моменти дуже
важливо враховувати комплексну і
підходити до цього І знову ж таки це
дуже індивідуальна робота нам дуже
багато потрібно ще навчати вчителів цих
речей ми насправді не приділяли справді
і психології дуже багато часу
стресостійкості в тому числі вчителів
нам потрібно самим вчитися вчити наших
вчителів і відповідно бо тут теж може
важливий момент вчитель у нас ключовий у
цьому однозначно прямий контакт з дітьми
має лише вчитель лише вчитель здатен з
комунікувати ці всі речі звести їх
докупи абсолютно і пройти цей весь
непростий шлях з дітьми під час
обстрілів під час повітряних тривог Тому
потрібно це робити так Дякую І наостанок
Бо як я вже казав час летить скажіть от
вашу думку як в Чернігові
відбудовується ось укриття і чого може
вам хотілось би додати
дуже Так я ж актуальне питання але тут
знаєте ми є такими заручниками ситуації
Всім би хотілось ви на початку задали
питання які ми мають бути укриття якби
укриття будувались всі з нуля із нової
будівлі то вони могли би бути
уніфікованими мати певні стандарти
рішення і так далі І звісно тоді все це
обговорили і було би правильно якби там
були окремі кімнати для певних класів
або хоча би для паралелей правильно для
тих мешканців сусідніх будинків які
могли би туди зайти і так далі наразі Ми
практично не маємо такої можливості ми
переобладнуємо ті приміщення які є в
закладах освіти Ми переобладним
найпростіші укриття і Відповідно ми вже
виходимо з того що в нас є а не будуємо
нове тому
особлива і тут скажемо так фантазії Ми
не можемо в цьому приділити що
стосується міста Чернігова то пишаюся
нашим містом і у нас є укриття і хоч би
воно не таке в навчальному закладі
особисто яке б воно хотілось бути тому
що воно не вміщає повністю всіх дітей Ми
маємо навчатися по змінах А але це є
укриття і це велика велика досягнення
всіх і міської влади і всіх
благодійників тих фондів які долучились
до відбування укриттів саме закладах
освіти Так звісно Ми теж надзвичайно
пишаємось з Черніговом надзвичайно
пишаємось кожним нашим містом адже ми
справді цього заслуговуємо ми всі багато
працюємо далі нашої Перемоги проте час
така штука що під час розмови з такою
кількістю розумних людей він летить
надзвичайно швидко дуже дякую вам за
увагу але ми мусимо закінчувати ось цю
панель проте попереду в нас ще дуже
цікавий насичений день Впродовж якого
детально говоритимемо про відновлення і
відбудову
дошкілля нову українську школу І кого ж
майбутнього Отже Натали Андрію Михайло
Оксана та Сергію Дуже дякую вам за цю
розмову Мене звати стародавцян Дуже
дякую вам і до зустрічі
Дякую вам Дякуємо Яни і Дякуємо всім у
твоєму учасникам я все родовий збирав
Дякуємо блискуче проведення а цієї
дискусії Дякуємо вам пані та панове
дивіться буквально Зараз ми зробимо
невеличку перерву Але перед тим давайте
перенесемося буквально на тиждень вперед
на перше власне вересня І от 1 вересня
дорогі друзі спитайте своїх учнів як ти
адже починається новий навчальний рік в
умовах війни і пропонуємо всім освітянам
долучитися до нас і провести з учнями
перший урок із ментального здоров'я Ти
як повертаємось до школи цікаві відео із
психологами розробили в межах
всеукраїнської програми ментального
здоров'я Ти як ініційованої першої леді
України Оленою зеленською у співпраці із
мон та юнісеф сценарій і відео до уроку
буде опубліковано на сайті Міністерства
освіти і науки 28 серпня а 1 вересня
трансляція на сайті партнерів Megogo
Отже дорогі друзі за 10 хвилин
за 10 хвилин ми знову збираємося тут а
далі у нас важлива дискусія діти в
умовах війни та їхні потреби вона
розпочнеться на головній сцені о 12 Ну і
нагадаю що з 12 починають працювати всі
секції Якщо хтось хоче попрацювати там
або мусить попрацювати там зробіть це ну
і поки ви розходитесь ще одна важлива
інформація в секторі фотовиставки ви
можете долучитися до акції яка
спрямована на збір донатів для
облаштування укриття ліцею номер 55
міста Миколаєва акція відбувається за
ініціативи Міністерства освіти і науки
України та фонду сейф Запрошуємо
долучитися до акції до натом та стати
володарем спеціальних подарунків з
ексклюзивними автографами Тараса тополі
лідера гурту Антитіла та міністра освіти
і науки України Оксана лісового а
підходьте до сектору фотовиставки
дізнавайтеся деталі беріть участь Ну а в
самому завершенні нашого сьогоднішнього
дня ми тут прямо і розіграємо ці класні
подарунки серед тих Хто візьме участь
дякуємо вам за 8 хвилин зустрічаємося
[музика]
[оплески]
шановні пані та панове в першу чергу
всім смачної кави або Смачного перекусу
Я хочу нагадати що О 12-й а це прямо
зараз розпочинають працювати тематичні
клубні зони нагадаю зелений сектор - це
нова українська школа жовтий сектор
коледжі майбутнього фіолетовий сектор
цифровізація освіти або Dji рожевий
сектор дошкілля синій сектор відбудова
освітніх закладів червоний сектор
простір презентацій при реєстрації ви
всі отримали навушники І власне у цих
клубних зонах вони вам знадобляться тому
що це головна умова участі у цих
дискусіях Адже тільки в навушниках ви
зможете чути кожного спікера кожного
окремого сектору то має сподіваюся що ви
навушники Не загубили вони десь поруч і
вони вам стануть в нагоді на тематичних
клубних зонах Ну а на головній серії
буде розпочинатися па нельна дискусія
діти в умовах війни та їхні потреби
[музика]
[оплески]
пані та панове за хвилину на головній
сенери буде розпочинатися дискусія діти
в умовах війни та їхні потреби тому
звісно чекаємо всіх охочих взяти участь
у
дискусії на головній сцені Біля головної
сцени за хвилину будемо розпочинати
[музика]
вітаємо Вітаємо дорогі друзі ще раз і ще
раз Дякуємо Хто тут разом з нами
безпосередньо на головній серії вітаємо
всіх хто зараз дивиться нас в онлайні
наскільки мені відомо це декілька тисяч
людей а учасників серпневої хто не зміг
особисто приїхати Але тим не менше Я
впевнений ви А надзвичайно активні перед
екранами своїх моніторів всіх хто ще
десь затягнувшись на камеру брейку
Повертайтеся назад хто ні то звісно в
онлайн-трансляціях на youtube-каналах і
Facebook сторінці Міністерства освіти і
науки ви теж нас можете бачити Отже тут
у нас на сцені ви вже бачите класних
наших дітей і це не просто так а тому що
я нагадаю Зараз у нас буде дискусія діти
в умовах війни та їхні потреби і власне
діти безпосередньо братимуть основну
участь у цій дискусії і вони підготували
силу-силенно різноманітних запитань Ну
насправді На мою думку саме
вміння стану дітей пошук важливих слів а
інколи Ну от навіть просто Усмішка
підтримки можуть надати дитині важливо
опору в наші часи і те що ця тема
висвітлюється тут на головній сцені
серпневої дуже важливо тому не випадково
власне основними спікерами у цій розмові
будуть Михайло Федоров та Оксан Лісовий
запрошую вас
тата всіх хто тут можете аплотувати
Дякую
пане вакцини Я знаю що це можна сказати
була ваша пряма особиста ініціатива Так
ви наполягали на обговоренні проблему
стану дітей в такому форматі чому
насправді
Серпнева конференція традиційний формат
який
щороку проводиться
освітянами про освіту про початок
навчального року насправді це все про
дітей про молодь про підлітків це все
для них і коли я дуже боюся знаєте
такого якогось маніпулятивного залучення
молоді до якихось процесів тобто якщо Ми
запрошуємо школярів якщо Ми запрошуємо
молодь у неї повинна бути роль у неї
повинен повинен бути голос Ми повинні
Цей голос чути Ми повинні сприймати
дитину і підлітка як повноцінного
громадянина як громадянина в першу чергу
і чути його і спілкуватись з ним і
давати йому мікрофон і давати йому право
голосу і давати йому право впливу на
наші рішення тому що освіта - це перш за
все про них
тоді коротке запитання це разова акція
Чи все ж таки буде на постійній основі
залучені дітей безпосередньо до
покращення Скажімо так процесу освіти ну
для мене в моїй роботі освітянській
роботі Це була взагалі постійна практика
Ми весь час спілкувалась з молоддю весь
час спілкувались з підлітками в
основному Малій Академії Наук були
підлітки так з 12 років починаючи Хоча і
молодші діти от особливо Музей Науки
охоплював молодших дітей тому Ну для
мене це просто ну норма Я не розумію як
можна формувать освіту будувать освіту
Не маючи діалогу з тими хто в цій освіті
перебуває безпосередньо хто є цільовою
аудиторією цих цієї сфери Дякую
надзвичайно Отже час розпочинати
безпосередньо дискусію і прошу власне
зустріти оплесками модераторку дискусії
діти в умовах війни та їхні потреби а
радниця уповноважена президента України
з прав дитини та дитячої реабілітації
пані Дарія Герасимчук Дуже дякую Тимур
ви забрали в мене половину моєї роботи а
щаслива щаслива сьогодні що маю
можливість таку почесну місію модерувати
чудову розмову між
неймовірно крутою українською молоддю та
аж двома міністрами
Отже колись Насправді я би на початку
відберу у вас буквально 5-6 Обіцяю не
більше хвилин часу і Поділюсь власним
досвідом тому що За освітою я вчителька
і колись коли я ще провадила свою
Вчительську діяльність і це було власне
в сільській звичайній школі а для мене
Серпнева конференція це було щось
неймовірне це означає що ми будемо
говорити про те власне як ми будемо
навчати а отже як ми будемо жити
наступний навчальний рік і вже потім
коли Два роки тому я стала радницею та
уповноваженою президента України з прав
дитини та дитячої реабілітації
Я знову готувалася до серпневої
конференції але вже в інший ролі і скажу
вам що це дещо інші відчуття але
насправді і в першому і в другому
випадку я ще і навіть уявити не могла
про те що
попереду величезна жахлива війна своїми
викликами з обстрілами не завжди
ракетними але з такими завданнями які
потрібно буде вирішувати реактивно і
навіть не здогадувалась що буду сьогодні
сидіти на цій сцені і модерувати панель
яка буде називатися діти
діти в умовах війни і їх потреби страшна
назва але потреба дітей завжди потрібно
вирішувати за участі відразу двох
міністрів А це віце-прем'єр-міністр з
інновації розвитку освіти науки
технології України Міністр цифрової
трансформації України Михайло Федоров
будь ласка прошу аплодувати та міністр
освіти та науки оксен лісовий
і нашої неймовірної української молоді
це Ілля Даша Філіп Яна Ян Кирило та Ілля
А на жаль
Ці діти пережили важкі Випробування Вони
живуть і навчаються в умовах війни
особливо складні умови ці умови завжди
носять різний контекст але і ті і ті
складні Я дуже вдячна вам за те що
сьогодні ви готові поділитися власним
досвідом навчання власне у військовий
час а також хочу попередити про те що
вони мають до вас запитання Я думаю що
ви не будете проти якщо вони їх будуть
сьогодні задавати Ми також маємо до них
тоже Чудово Ну прийдеться мені
модерувати Я сподіваюсь що буде досить
активна розмова Отже сьогоднішня бесіда
вона є надзвичайно важливою тому що
Україна стикнулася не лише на полі бою з
підступним ворогом який порушив кордони
Та напевне на нашу країну але і не
передбачені до цього виклики власне в
освіті
таке питання як навчати і навчатися коли
діти роз'їхались хто куди за офіційними
даними лише за рік від початку ширину
широкомасштабного вторгнення У нас в
Україні було зареєстровано майже 5
мільйонів тому що вимушених переміщених
осіб а фактично кількість їх це 7
мільйонів і серед них 25% це діти
водночас за даними міжнародної
організації міграції тимчасовий притулок
за межами України знайшли аж понад 6
мільйонів українців і щонайменше третина
з них це діти Отже кожна четверта
українська дитина змушена була покинути
власну домівку і переміститися в інші
регіони України і кожна п'ята українська
дитина змушена була виїхати за кордон
при цьому на думку юнісеф наших добрих
партнерів двоє з трьох дітей переміщені
за кордон і досі збираються не включені
в систему освіти країни яка їх прийняла
на жаль це величезна проблема друге
питання яке сьогодні ми маємо
активізувати це власне як навчати і
навчатися коли ворог постійно обстрілює
нашу нашу освітні заклади обстрілює
енергетичні інфраструктуру коли немає
електроенергії та тепла на Сьогодні ми з
вами маємо страшну статистику адже
сьогодні нам відомо про щонайменше 3750
закладів освіти які отримали пошкодження
361 заклад освіти був зруйнований вщент
і тут я знову процитую юнісеф тому що
вони застерігають війна поставила під
загрозу освіту а відтак і майбутніх
дітей в Україні Я абсолютно погоджуюсь з
цією тезою трохи більше 5 мільйонів з
них стикаються з перешкодами в доступі
до навчання і зокрема приблизно 3,5 млн
безпосередньо постраждали від власне
закриття
через це українські діти ризикують
втратити неймовірно важливий час для
навчання соціального розвитку і власне
Не зможуть повноцінно збудувати своє
майбутнє саме з цими викликами нашим
українським освітянам довелося
стикнутися І вести свою особисту
освітянську боротьбу І вести свій
освічанський фронт На жаль наші діти
змушені ховатися в бомбосховищах вчитися
в підвалах та метро діти залишились без
можливості спілкуватися з однолітками
без дозвілля без спорту І власне без
дитинства Сьогодні ми з вами почуємо ці
історії з перших вуст як і різні інші
історії про контекст та умови навчання в
цілому адже власне між навчанням
спеціалізовані та спеціальній школі є
велика різниця між навчанням дитини тут
в Україні і дитини за кордоном між
навчання дитини масовій школі дитина яка
має свою родину і навчання дитини
дитячому будинку за принципом де жив
власне там і вчився і пропоную вам
панове міністри сьогодні не звучати так
голосно як зазвичай і не бути
таким
найголовнішими дійовими особами звучати
трошечки тихіше бо сьогодні у вас є
Чудова нагода стати підсилювачами
дитячих голосів Я сподіваюсь що ви не
проти Отже тоді розпочнемо
переходжусь до вас далі вас чудове ім'я
давайте розпочнемо з того що на жаль я
знаю про те що 10-11 класи вашого
навчання ваші випускні роки пройшли в
складних умовах
нещадних обстрілів вашого рідного міста
та інших міст України Отже я прошу вас
розказати Більш детальну історію Звідки
ви
власне Що Що змусило пережити вас війна
І власне які найбільші Випробування були
саме випускних класах будь ласка Доброго
дня шановні присутні Мене звуть в Регіна
Дарья Я з міста Миколаїв В цьому році я
закінчила Миколаївський класичний ліцей
і вступила в державний
торговельно-економічний університет на
спеціальність міжнародні відносини ця
спеціальність є дуже близькою для мене
вже зараз тому що я є представницею
активної молоді в своєму місті разом ми
намагаємось відновити культурне життя в
Миколаєві І звісно ж залученням також
міжнародних партнерів тож я часто
залучена до бесід часто залучено до
зустрічі із зарубіжними партнерами тож я
дуже Я маю глибоку віру в цю
спеціальність і хочу розвиватись в цьому
напрямку для того щоб розбудовувати
стійкі свій разом Як виявилось дуже
важливо і я на свою історію з напевно
довоєнного часу я завжди була завзятою
ученицею тому що мені завжди було цікаво
як влаштоване світ і я хотіла я в першу
чергу робила це для себе я хотіла
дізнатись
пізнати світ з різних точок зору і також
з 9 класу я була долучена до свого
шкільного самоврядування а згодом 10 з
10 класу до Миколаївського обласного
учнівського самоврядування ця діяльність
мене повністю охопила я була дуже
включена в це я намагалась
запроваджувати якісь нові модерні класні
заходи
заходи з неформальної освіти так як я
бачила самостійно потребу в цьому і
хотіла щоб інша молить також була до
цього долучена
але так не було так було не завжди до
того як обрати свою спеціальність я
прийшла доволі великий шлях і
зараз я Поділюсь своїми напрацюваннями
саме з соціальною сферою так як я багато
спілкуюся з учнями так як я багато
спілкуюсь з вчителями я бачила наскільки
на стопорила в певний час пандемія а
потім звісно 24 лютого 22-го року
раптово припинилось моє навчання на
цілий місяць і ще найбільший термін
припинилась моя соціальна діяльність Я
була в Миколаєві понад три місяці Згодом
я виїхала але за три місяці я встигла
пережити багато страшних ситуацій
прильоти поруч з будинком
артилерія і це був доволі стресовий
період для мене
але освіта була для мене важливою завжди
Тому я кожного дня кожного ранку брала
себе в руки і намагалась
намагалась старанно вчитись старанно
розвиватись але ми знаємо що кожна
особистість вона є індивідуальною у
кожного своя історія У кожного свої своя
стресостійкість і як саме по роботі з
молоддю я бачила наскільки молоді важко
Я чула багато скарг на втрату
концентрації у дітей Я чула багато скарг
на перегруз інформаційний особливо
випускних класах так як ми намагались
відходити від формату 24/7 за ноутбуками
багато інформації приносилось формат
самостійного опрацювання і я скажу що це
було дуже важко для мене і я уявляю
наскільки це було важко для моїх
однокласників і я це бачила Я це чула і
від вчителів і від батьків від освітян
Я також
перебуваючи за кордоном Це був такий
доволі напружений період для мене так як
я була одна без батьків і з вересня
місяця я прийняла рішення що нам треба
повертатися самоврядуванням до нашої
активної роботи Ми знов почали
впроваджувати якісь заходи мені було
дуже приємно що це допомагає молоді Вони
почали комунікувати між собою це те що
їм дуже сильно не вистачало я бачила
багато сліз у дітей які знову ж таки
повернулись до комунікації так як
Миколаїв це особливий регіон І ми довго
не виходили навіть на онлайн-зв'язок з
вчителями Вони теж були в скрутних в
скрутних становищах
Тож я можу сказати що
соціальна сфера особливо мене бентежить
і потім повернувшись до Миколаєва я
доєдналась до активної молоді Зараз ми
намагаємось відновити оцю офлайн
комунікацію не тільки між учнями а й між
містями і я бачу наскільки це є
потрібним наразі і наскільки я це на
часі особливо в Миколаєві Тож я можу
переходити до свого питання А так Дарія
Дякую вам ваша історії насправді
надихають що коли ти думаєш про те що
вдається пережити розумієш наскільки
багато У тебе є сил тож Дякую вам за цю
мотивацію особисто для мене і я знаю про
те що у вас є запитання до пана міністра
освіти будь ласка Так пане Оксана я б
хотіла поцікавитись чи вже є якісь
напрацювання стосовно
більшої соціалізації та понурення таке
понурення
дітей в навчальний процес адже як я
сказала Це доволі я доволі важким етапом
для кожної дитини
зібрати себе та посадити за ноутбук і чи
є якісь напрацювання Можливо в DJ у
світі можливо є якісь вже кейси за
кордоном і ви хочете їх використовувати
Ну по-перше дякую дякую Дарья і за
запитання і за вашу історію
по-перше Ви
маєте свої запитання безумовно так і ви
генеруєте їх від себе і виходячи з того
що у вас турбує і це дуже важливо нам
нам важливо розуміти що це були саме
ваші Запитання Ви не боялися не
стіснялись їх задавати а друге що хочу
сказати не завжди у нас будуть відповіді
на ваші запитання тому що ви насправді є
ті люди майбутнього які живуть уже зараз
в іншому світі ніж там жив живу
наприклад я Тому що все одно певна
тяглість досвіду вона заставляє старших
людей відставати від темпу сучасного
світу і тому
для мене важливо щоб ви теж зрозуміли що
я можу не мати всіх відповідей на ваші
запитання і я буду відверто про це
говорити те що стосується вашого
запитання Дарія
ми говоримо про перш за все наскільки я
його зрозумів це перш за все про саме
психосоціальні навчання ні про
психосоціальні навички про те чи є
проекти спрямовані на компенсацію втрат
психосоціальному психосоціальній сфері
так про це
ви розумієте ми сконцентрували свою
увагу на одній такій проблемі про яку
говорили всі і говорять зараз і працюють
над нею це освітні втрати чули про це
так і освітні втрати це дві два ключових
аспекти над якими треба працювати
вимірювання освітніх втрат і
подолання освітніх втрат якими
інструментами і коли ми якими
інструментами Ми долаємо їх і коли ми
говорили про це ми дуже
багато часу втратили
тому що саме втратив психосоціальному
розвитку вони не були в фокусі уваги Але
нещодавно розпочалось дослідження за
підтримки ряду міжнародних організацій
зокрема і юнісеф який підтримує нашу
серпневу конференцію щодо і методів
вимірювання оцих саме психоемоційного
розвитку психосоціаційного розвитку і
щодо інструментів подолання те що
стосується онлайн освіти ми все-таки
розуміємо що саме внаслідок
онлайн-освіти значною мірою і виникла ці
втрати в цій сфері розвитку особистості
і ми розуміємо все-таки що наші ключове
завдання в подоланні цієї подолання
втрат в цій е-е складовій це повернення
до офлайннового навчання якомога більшої
кількості дітей це той пріоритет який
поставив перед собою уряд а воно в свою
чергу зав'язано на безпековій можливості
безпекові умови От і Миколаїв це те
місто де Ну перед яким стоїть досить
складний виклик тому що не тільки
наявність укриттів але і час підльоту
ракет визначаємо можливість повернення
до е-е до аудиторного навчання але
звичайно ми розуміємо що є цілий набір
інструментів і нормальної неформальної
освіти позашкільної освіти яка дозволяє
сьогодні компенсувати втрати саме в цій
сфері і в цьому напрямку ми маємо певні
напрацювання в політиках які ми зараз
реалізовуємо саме інструментами
позашкільної освіти компенсувати оці от
втрачені можливості спілкування розвитку
м'яких навичок і всього іншого Про що ви
говорите Дякую пане Оксана Я сподіваюсь
далі що отримали відповідь на своє
запитання Отже ми з вами продовжуємо
серед наших учасників юнак у якого 24
лютого 2022 року мала відбутися перша
Всеукраїнська олімпіада з хімії вона на
жаль не відбулась за зрозумілих причин
це власне Ян саме той хлопчина який
навчався у двох навчальних закладах в
українській та американській школі у
якого Я особисто маю взяти кілька уроків
як модерувати панель і я це обов'язково
зроблю після нашої події я не я хочу
попросити вас розказати нам більш
детально чому ви обрали такий формат
вчитися в двох школах тому що насправді
зараз дуже багато українців які
тимчасово вимушені ховатися від
російських атак за кордоном вчаться в
двох школах і в місцевій школі в
іноземній і поєднувати це з українською
освітою Скажіть будь ласка яким чином ви
прийняли рішення вчитися двох школах які
були в цьому власне напрямки а особливо
складнощі особливо якщо ми говоримо про
навчання онлайн звісно Так отже як же
значення Мене звуть Ян Мені 17 років у
лютому 2022 року 24 числа в мене повинна
Так Якраз бути Всеукраїнська олімпіада з
хімії до якої Ну я чесно кажучи дуже
довго прямував проте На жаль я
прокинувся не від звуку будильника від
звуку вибухів звісно перші тижні далеко
було не до освіти які в більшості людям
зі своєю сім'єю так як ми жили в
Київській області нам довелося переїхати
у чарівне місто Трускавець проте вже за
декілька тижнів
все-таки почав поставати питання освіти
Наша школа які більшість перейшла на
онлайн навчання але багато вчителів вони
не виходили на уроки через свої причини
багато вчителів через страх а деякі
загалом звільнилися і тому виникав дуже
великий дисбаланс тобто умовно в нас
могло бути 5 років математики але там ну
близько там тільки двох років
української мови тому що вчитель не міг
чи робитися більше особливо для мене
була проблема в хімії тому що Звісно
Мені хотілось і далі продовжувати своє
навчання поглиблене навчання тому що це
мій основний напрям розвитку Але просто
не було можливості тому що вчитель не
міг давати мені Там звісно індивідуальні
уроки Я звісно підлаштовуватись під
рівень класу ніби воно звичайно Ну
складно тому що він був Ну все одно
вищий як я казав і в інших дітей було
проблеми адже наприклад якщо це
українська література Багато в нас було
олімпіадників які на жаль не мали змогли
Далі розвиватися
і крім того був ще викидиснанс в
математиці а саме в темах 10-й клас
другий семестр математика на жаль
найскладніший там є як і найвищі теми
тригонометрії найскладніші так і
найскладніші теми математичного аналізу
І виходило Так що просто кожного дня в
нас була нова тема діти ще не могли
розібратися з попередньою як починалося
нова і поставала питання сенсу такого
навчання адже багато дітей вирішували
навіть не починати нові теми А ще далі
продовжувати самі досліджувати попередні
і
на жаль Ось такі проблеми За освітою
змусили мене подаватися в школу
міжнародні я подався багато онлайн шкіл
і мене на грант взяли в онлайн-школу в
США і вже 11-й клас я вчився у двох
школах паралельно це офлайн близько з
9:00 до 15:00 у київській школі потім
приходив додому із п'ятої близько до
години ночі на жаль я вчився в
американській школі про те якби не
американська школа Я впевнений що рівень
моєї освіти На жаль би дуже погіршився
адже не лише приклад ось такого свого
наприклад як знають інтеграл це
математичний оператор і в українській
школі через тривоги Наприклад ми його на
жаль розбирали ну буквально пару днів і
Діти все ще встигають вивчити Це тільки
його
американській школі ж так ми не брали
наприклад я не взяв собі курс вищий
тригонометрії але там цілий рік ми
розбирали от тільки математичний аналіз
тільки інтеграли тільки похідні і ось в
них такий підхід можливо нехтувати
вищими темами математики якогось іншої
теми але приділити більш уваги от цій
темі і Якби я не пред'явив то звісно Ну
мені був надзвичайно складно
орієнтуватися в українській школі Так
само і з хімії Так я нехтував якимось
високими темами там з біології якимось
дуже глибокими але в мене була
можливість більш глибше зануритись у
хімії яка мені була потрібніша і ось це
моя така історія я вже закінчив ось
українську школу в мене ще 12-й клас в
школі США проте Ось так нам ні довелося
вчитися
я хочу сказати про те що на вашому
прикладі ми бачимо як українські діти як
українська молодь прагнучи здобути
знання ну знаходить шляхи Як це зробити
головне мета мета у вас точно є я
впевнена що у вас точно Все буде добре
але знаю про те що ви маєте запитання до
пана Федорова будь ласка Так звісно
питання наступне все-таки ще якась
країна чи якийсь напрям з якою ви берете
приклад в майбутньому світі України що я
маю на увазі якщо це більш західний
підхід як я вже казав там іноді нехтують
якимись височими вищими темами якихось
предметів і на противагу щоб діти могли
вибирати що їм більше подобається умовно
Це можна взяти найвищу хімію там в них
навіть три рівні але ну трошки менше
вивчити матеріалу з біології чи з фізики
Чи вам все-таки більш імпонує ось такий
східний підхід з азіатських країн де
кожна дитина повинна надзвичайно багато
вчити в принципі кожного предмету щоб
все було порівно що все було рівноцінно
от і все-таки от цікаво вашу думку Чи є
у Вас якісь моделі країн світу які вам
подобаються найбільше які ви хотіли
влаштувати її ввести в реалізацію в
українські освіти дякую дякую за питання
цікаве питання насправді ми його також
дискутуємо Зараз розробляється новий
стандарт вищої профільної школи і якраз
у нас тільки вчора з оксидом зустріч з
розробниками цього стандарту Тобто ми
багато приділяємо цю е-е часом якщо ми
хочемо побудувати
таку освітню траєкторію де дитина
справді знаходиться себе розуміє своє
сильні сторони може себе реалізувати то
потрібно робити те про що ви говорите і
в рамках стандарту в рамках програм і в
рамках бачення потім переходу вищі
навчальні заклади або профтех якраз такі
Так ми плануємо рухатися коли дитина
зможе набирати предмети і
самостійно формувати і обирати швидкість
навчання по цій освітній траєкторії
тобто приходячи в університет вона потім
зможе зараховувати навіть те що вона ті
знання які вона отримала в 11-му і в
11-му класі тому дійсно ми тут
орієнтуємося більш на західні моделі
навчання і але потрібно ще врахувати Ну
коли ви порівнюєте сьогодні українську
школу і там американську школу і
говорити що там деякі предмети не
вдається Та поглибитися в нас є питання
повномасштабної війни і питання
адаптації для тих умов Де ми є насправді
е-е ми не повинні жалітися говорити що
нас там ну в нас такі умови у нас так не
виходить ми повинні ставати ще більш
сильною нацією нам потрібно вивчати
досвід Ізраїлю Що вони робили для того
щоб адаптувати свою систему освіти і
зараз є задача запустити процес навчання
офлайн на загнати ті втрату освітній
якій є завдання Сьогодні ми про це
говорили
навчити освітніх менеджерів щоб вони
могли організовувати навчання в такий
складний період щоб директор школи де ви
навчаєтесь він зрозумів що так вчитель
не зміг адаптувати математику під ці
умови що Чому він не зміг тому що в
нього не вистачає компетенції або в
нього немає місця де він знаходиться
безпечного місця звідки вести заняття
е-е або йому не вистачає там ще якихось
факторів і він зміг прийняти
управлінські рішення або навчити цього
вчителя або наприклад там
збільшити заробітну плату ну на більшу
заробітну плату не мати людини яка зможе
вирішити цю проблему враховуючи
державний стандартні програми і все-таки
вирішити це питання А Міністерство
освіти і певні інституції проаналізувати
чи по всій країні Скільки є ситуації
коли директорів вчителі не можуть
вирішити
система і коли в нас є потужна
it-база де ми моніторимо в режимі
реального часу як навчаються діти які
оцінки які проблеми в конкретних школах
з конкретними вчителями в чому проблема
де ми можемо змінити в полі сімейкінги
що ми можемо покращити для того щоб там
були умови краще і тоді ми зможемо
коригувати цю освітню траєкторію всієї
нації тому якщо коротко резюмувати дамо
відповідь ми дивимося Звичайно що на
західні країни і дивимося досить там в
тому числі Сполучених Штатів але з точки
зору безпеки ми дивимося на досвіти
Ізраїлю і все-таки Ми формуємо унікальну
систему освіти Ми повинні до неї прийти
Де ми в режимі реального часу розуміємо
проблеми які виникають створюємо
найкращі умови для вчителів і директорів
де вони можуть себе самореалізувати і де
наші діти мають високий рівень мотивації
тому що насправді для вас сьогодні кожна
криза - це можливості Ви повинні для
себе поставити нові цілі і максимально
взяти
з цієї ситуації Де Ви знаходитесь ви
перемістилися значить добре інший рівень
соціалізації Хто тут найкраще вчитель в
що я можу зробити ким я хочу стати
з'являються нові професії країна починає
риностувати гроші в іншій сфері Куди не
інвестувала що я можу робити пі- Які
з'являється програми міжнародних
партнерів під час війни Тобто потрібно
зробити певний свот аналіз свого життя
ситуація Де Ви знаходитесь поставити
цілі і рухатися криза - це можливість і
будемо разом шукати вихід з цієї кризи
для того щоб з'явилося більше
можливостей Дякуємо михайли продовжуючи
тему яку ви розпочали з приводу
менеджерів освіти який надзвичайно
важливі А ми власне переходимо до
спілкування з нашим наступним панелістом
і це Кирило саме Кирило Ще не закінчив
школу і цього року 1 вересня піде вже в
11-й клас але Кирило має дуже
травматичний досвід навчання тому що під
час його навчання в ліцеї його ліцей був
під
окупацією і певний період часу там
відбувалися страшні речі тому що росіяни
влаштували саме в ліцеї з пункт свого
перебування і використовували свої
приміщення для різних страшних речей тож
Кирило переходячи до вас я прошу вас
поділитися своїм досвідом того як вам
вдалось пережити ті складні часи як
відбувалося ваше навчання тоді і власне
як зараз після деокупації населеного
пункту ваш ліцей продовжує своє навчання
і як ви взагалі пережили це
Добрий день пане міністр п
віце-прем'єр-міністра всі присутні тут
Мене звати гарна Кирил Я учень 10 класу
катюжанського опорного ліцею що на
Київщині Моє село було окуповане
протягом 36 днів і увесь цей час школа
належала Русі і слугувала їм умовним
штабом виходить класи якісь кабінети
службові приміщення все було пограбоване
у підвалах катували людей до медпункту
школи звозили трьох сотих
після закінчення періоду окупації
дирекція разом з за підтримки юнісеф та
інших благодійних фондів розпочала
відновлення школи
ось виходить школа відновлюється
навчання дітей налагоджується приходить
до ладу Ми вийшли навчатися
оновлюються кабінети завозиться новітнє
обладнання Але є одне оце Але чому я
сюди прийшов вчителі не можуть всім
обладнанням впоратись це такі вчителі
пенсіонерки які можливо були б і раді
вже покинути школу адже вже зробили свій
величезний внесок освіту звісно не
говорю про всіх обов'язково будуть
вчителі які
не дивлячись на свій вік ідуть в ногу з
часом і
можна так сказати тримають нашу наш
ліцей на собі але всі ж розуміють що їм
також колись потрібен буде відпочинок
і
наш навчальний колектив дуже сильно
потребує в таких молодих енергійних
кадрах проблема В чому проблема в тому
що такі молоді енергійні кадри до нас не
йдуть Чому Тому що в Україні на даний
момент
надзвичайно малий рівень заохоченості
випускників якихось педагогічних ВНЗ чи
коледжів йти навчати в державні школи
особливо якщо ця школа знаходиться в
селі чи в Малому містечку
цілковито це полягає від зарплатні та
непристижності навчати в селах
молодий вчитель з якимось новітнім
поданням предмету він обов'язково обирає
На мою думку обов'язково бере якісь
приватний навчальний заклад адже хоче
передавати свої знання віддавати сили та
час за кошти на якій він принаймні зможе
про харчуватися на жаль зараз в Україні
такі реалії що
з посадовим окладом
5-7 тисяч гривень навіть Я перепрошую
двірники не підуть працювати адже в
середньому Вони мають вдвоє менше
сучасна Україна зараз полягає так що ну
середньостатистична сім'я тут вона на
такі кошти ледь себе прогодує а ще
потрібно на щось розважатися та
вдягатися це ще не кажучи про якісь
неочікувані витрати я Звісно знаю про
обіцянку мон підвищити зарплату вчителям
після перемоги до 40 тисяч гривень і
свято чита
Я читав і свято вірю в те що
до кінця мого навчання у школі ми
переможемо у цій війні але я попрошу
жити тут і зараз постало питання
ставте питання І це буде мабуть Михайло
Федоров так
поставила питання чи планує Чи плануєте
ви підіймати зарплату вчителям під час
військового стану якщо ні то як
Міністерство планує заохочувати молодих
спеціалістів йти до сіл працювати на
таку зарплатню
до мене питання Да ми плануємо запустити
Пілот п'ятиста школах в наступному році
вже Ми готуємося до цього пілоту ми не
просто хочемо готуємося ми зараз будемо
запускати навчання для директорів це
комплексний Пілот не тільки система
заробітних плат а також і навчання
менеджерів освітніх Там будуть багато
нових нововведень вони будуть судово-
стосуватися і вашого вашої проблематики
яку ви до цього говорили бій більш
гнучкого менеджменту в цих школах і
можливості директору приймати рішення
якщо наприклад хтось не досягає певних
цілей з його команди і додаткова
мотивація як додатково доплата до
заробітної плати і якраз ту систему яку
сьогодні показував президент структури
заробітної плати Тобто ми не хочемо
чекати е-е поки переможемо нам потрібно
змінювати систему вже зараз Звичайно що
це буде над важко тому що весь бюджет
він є зараз сьогодні йде військовим Але
ми хочемо в наступному році відтестувати
нову заробітну плату і нові підходи до
освітніх менеджерів і і по результатам
цього тестування звичайно дивіться я
максимально оптиміст для ді Навіщо жити
якщо не ставити амбітні цілі то ми не
важливо скільки буде
воєнний стан Нам потрібно буде проти ми
рухаємося по моделі що ми спершу
тестуємо а потім маштабуємо на всю е-е
країну цю систему заробітних плат тому
що Знаєте як Бісмарк казав що він не
виграють не виграють не генерали а
вчителі священики Тому нам потрібно як я
казав сьогоднішню сьогоднішньому виступі
я казав про те що сьогоднішня сміливість
і стійкість суспільства це
велика заслуга нашої системи освіти і
наших освітян вони виховали патріотичні
молодь яка сьогодні захищає на полі бою
і в тилу формує все для захисту сплачує
податки відкриває компанії і так далі
Тому потрібно продовжувати цей процес і
можливо ми взагалі переможемо остаточно
на кордоні 91-го року вийдемо з
результатами реформ які ми зробимо зараз
тобто вони впав впливають на те Хто буде
що виробляти де буде служити і як
захищати країни різними способами
засобами для того щоб перемогти тому ми
нічого не чекаємо рухаємося вперед Я
впевнений що у нас настільки
кристалізоване бачення що робити далі що
і нам її міжнародні партнери допоможуть
десь ми зможемо потрібно зменшувати
взагалі частку держави в економіці нас
три з половиною тисячі державних
підприємств потрібно їх всіх закривати
там 99% залишити тільки стратегічні
потрібно скорочувати видатки на те що не
потрібно і більше вкладати в освіту
Звичайно що продовжувати вкладати гроші
у військових і взагалі воєнну сферу тому
що це питання нашого майбутнього Ну а я
ще доповню е-е ви знаєте зарплата
вчителям підвищується постійно вона
підвищується дуже незначним чином Тобто
Це невеликий коефіцієнти щорічно даються
і в цьому році також бюджет субвенції
збільшений саме на цей коефіцієнт
невеликий це там до семи відсотків
підвищення заробітної плати але це щось
змінює
треба
ви можете сказати ми з вами можемо
сказати що треба Ну значне підвищення
зробити але Давайте подумаємо а впевнені
що це щось змінить це якщо ми зараз ну
от давайте уявимо у нас немає війни у
нас є там е-е високий рівень доходів
бюджету і ми можемо собі дозволить
підвищити зарплату удвічі втричі в
п'ятеро чи зміниться ситуація можливо з
часом почнуть цю професію приходити люди
так може починати думати з іншого що і
можна зробити поки немає грошей для того
щоб професію проходили люди які як
вибудувати цей алгоритм як змінити
систему педагогічної освіти тому що ми
знаємо що і тут ми маємо проблеми Бо ми
знаємо що нова українська школа і
підготовка вчителів для нової
української школи формувалася не
системою педагогічної освіти вищої
педагогічної освіти вона формувалась
громадськими організаціями донорськими
організаціями типи Гёте інституту
British counc але інших ті хто проводив
тренінги і навчання для вчителів і зараз
коли ми виділимо субвенцію на навчання
вчителів в рамках нової української
школи я боюсь що нам доведеться йти тим
же шляхом і тому Михайло Федорович
говорить що Пілот який будує принципово
інший підхід до оплати праці вчителів є
важливим
комплексна реформа тому що ми сьогодні в
рамках серпневої говоримо про дошкільну
шкільну позашкільну освіту позашкільну
меншою мірою на жаль Але тим не менше
вона у нас фокусі уваги Але ми не
говоримо про вищу освіту але ті
трансформації які ми обговорюємо зараз
на урядовому рівні на рівні команди
Міністерства на Громадському рівні вони
стосуються вищої освіти значною мірою і
в тому числі вищою педагогічної освіти
тому що до закладу до професії педагога
в заклад вищої освіти повинен прийти
дуже мотивований до цієї діяльності
мотивована людина а вона повинна
звичайно бути впевнена і в кар'єрному
зростанні своєму і в своїй свободі
творчості і так в соціальних стандартах
але коли ми дивимось на те як
працевлаштовується сьогодні Молодь не
тільки в педагогіці то молодь ставить
фінансову складову не завжди і далеко не
завжди як перший чинник
Свобода самореалізації свобода і
можливість бути долученим до класного і
крутого процесу до до значимих
суспільнозначимих е-е сфер до спільного
суспільного значимих проектів от що
мотивує сьогодні молодь насправді І от
тому в презентації Михайло ви бачили той
вчитель рокстар так тобто
і тому от освіта як поп культура так
тобто щось Що в свідомості суспільства Я
високозначим і це не тільки про зарплату
Дуже дякую вам дякую абсолютно підтримую
слова тому що
я 18-річна Дар'я працювала 9 років в
школі в сільській місцевості І абсолютно
погоджуюсь з тим що зарплатня монетоді
мало хвилювала але мені дуже сподобався
процес і я бачила що я дотична до чогось
неймовірного хоча на сьогоднішній день
звичайно це максимально важливо мати
фінансове забезпечення для того щоб мати
вільні руки розв'язану розв'язані думки
в голові які можуть творити креативити і
проживати щодня своє життя поруч з
молодим поколінням Дуже дякую вам
нагадую про те що поки що ми трошечки
перебираємо наш таймінг Я сподіваюсь що
ми трошки з вами прискоримо сюди чудова
розмова і Я переходжу до наступного
панеліста і хочу представити вам Іллю
Іллю Я знаю трошки
більше ніж арешту тому що чотири роки
тому ми познайомились з Олею в таких
досить цікавих обставинах Ілля це той
підліток якого двічі зрадили дорослі
вперше зрадила своє власне біологічна
родина а вдруге це були люди які його
усиновили так Ілля навчався в
школі-інтернаті і я не буду про нього
розповідати багато адже він сам може
розказати про себе Ілля будь ласка
поділися своїм досвідом того наскільки
було важко навчатися там де ти жив і
наскільки
була важка конкуренція коли змінилася
умову навчання І власне що ти думаєш про
це
Добрий день Мене звати Ілля мені 19
років і Зараз я навчаюсь на менеджера
коли ми їх батьків позбавили
батьківського піклування я попав у
Луганській школу-інтернат
[музика]
там я навчався до 14 років навчання було
надто легке
було все зрозуміло в моєму класі було 8
дітей і так було в кожній в кожному
класі десь там 10 дітей Ну це стандарт
такий був з приводу домашнього завдання
його майже не було але воно було але
легке
потім коли мене встановили я попав у
школу для мажорів де в школі було у
класі було 32 дитини де заробити якусь
гарну оцінку було надто складно
мені реально було складно Я намагався
якось встигати у школі намагався
встигати адаптуватися у новому
середовищі із батьками і взагалі в місті
Ось так потім коли вже був суд коли мене
раз засунули
вчителі дізналися про те що я сирота і
те що в мене така от історія
вчителі почали
завищувати мені оцінки
тобто просто завищували оцінки від того
що мали якесь життя це теж було досить
неприємно відчуттям саме для тебе а я
даю тобі можливість задати питання пану
міністру освіти яке тебе турбує я знаю
точно бо ми не один раз з тобою говорили
про цю тему
чи розглядають питання інтеграції дітей
щоб дітям було легше адаптуватися чи є
підтримка чи робота з батьками
на максимально актуальне питання зараз
так державна політика спрямована на те
що називається де інститутулізацією
освіти Тобто ми не передбачаємо що в
Україні будуть інтернати в майбутньому
ми працюємо державна політика
Міністерство освіти міністерство
соціальної політики уповноважена з прав
дитини є окрема інституція зараз ось
буквально на минулому тижні була
презентована яка створена за ініціативи
президента України
як вона називається
так так так так складна назва навіть
його директор которола отець
коронасійний центр
з розбудови так кращої турботи про дітей
Це
насправді велика мрія президента України
Володимира Зеленського тому що він і
Дарія Герасимчук багато років вже
співпрацюють і це було Перше завдання
яке він поставив Мабуть коли прийшов на
цю каденю одне із таких перших завдань
він дуже послідовний в цьому попри війну
Україна працює над тим щоб кожна дитина
отримала родину І ця родина була якісною
ця родина ці умови в яких перебувають
діти були якісними умови навчання були
адекватними можливостями дитини і е-е
щоб ці можливості постійно розширювались
тому тут є тверда і чітка чи державна
політика і вектор на от цей на цю мету
Можливо сьогодні ми не маємо всіх
відповідей на всі запитання які звучать
але це максимально важливо
запам'ятовувати підкреслювати ті питання
які з'являються які ми сьогодні чуємо А
це щонайменше питання дійсно створення
програ адаптація для дітей які
переміщаються в інше місто переселяються
приходять з однієї школи в іншу в рамках
навіть одного міста тому що саме в той
момент вони також потребують критичної
підтримки адаптації А що можна говорити
якщо тут змінюється ще й повністю умови
життя від дитячого будинку до родини
нової школи нового міста і таких
обставин тож я думаю що це питання точно
підкреслили сьогодні червоним маркером і
обов'язково воно буде в напрацюваннях в
найближчим часом тому що дійсно це
пріоритет державної політики а-а
Сьогодні я хочу представити вам ще
одного панеліста що у мене забагато
сьогодні чоловіків панелі Але я думаю що
це не вплине на суттєво на нашу розмову
Отже переходимо до наступного учасника
це Іще один Ілля Ілля Сьогодні має
помічника помічник - це власне пані
Ірина перекладач жесто частини мови як
ви могли помітити Він користується саме
для спілкування жестовою мовою Він
перейшов у десятий клас і через своє
порушення слуху навчається в
Житомирській спеціальній школі але
сьогодні Ілля готовий поділитися з нами
всіма нюансами як це здобувати освіту
Коли твоє навчання проходить не такою
мовою як спілкуються більшість українців
як власне далі дійти до своєї мрії якщо
вона чітко поставлена Але ти знаєш що до
неї багато перепон і тому Ілля будь
ласка тобі слово поділись з нами
по-перше своєї мрією а по-друге тими
важливими аспектами які ти бачиш щодня в
навчанні і які перешкоди зараз є при
підготовці до вступу
для того щоб здобути і дійти до своєї
мрії
Добрий день Мене звати Ілля Мені 15
років
Я маю порушення слуху і майже нічого не
чую Мої батьки
чуючи і я спілкуюся з ними двома мовами
жестовою мовою і також словесною мовою
я навчаюся в Житомирській спеціальній
школі
Я дуже люблю ходити до школи але я
ненавиджу дистанційне навчання
Чому Тому що коли слабкі інтернет то
брати участь в навчанні практично
неможливо
щодня я ходжу
волейбольну секцію Я мрію пов'язати своє
життя з цим спортом
Зараз я навчаюся в десятому класі
у мене Попереду ще два роки
щоб точно визначитися з професією
Не хвилюйся все добре
Я хочу поділитися з вами своїми думками
своїми роздумами
чи знаєте ви
як обирають професію нечуючи випускники
шкіл
професія обираються не згідно талантів
можливостей а вибирається із переліку
професій де ну якби там де працюють
перекладачі жестової мови наприклад цих
професій дуже мало
наприклад я хочу бути вчителем
фізкультури
але мені пропонують бути оператором
комп'ютерного набору взуттєвиком
і перелік цих професій не такий великий
і ще приблизно плюс 5-7
А я ж хочу бути вчителем фізкультури а
перекладача там немає А чому немає тому
що для того щоб перекладач потрібно щоб
не було 10 нечуючих абітурієнтів А якщо
четверо і п'ятеро то не передбачений
перекладач
у мене запитують чи можна вчитися без
перекладача
Так звичайно можна вчитися без
але це дуже складно
дуже багато інформації
проходить повз
нечуючи людину
У мене є одна знайома яка зараз
навчається без перекладача
і таких
випадків дуже мало їх одиниці
моя знайома дівчинка Вона навчається на
третьому курсі університету
здобуває професію психолога
як вони навчаються хто їй допомагає і
допомагає мама бабуся брат А що вони
роблять вони просто передають інформацію
від викладачів і фактично Вони працюють
перекладачами жестової мови
Добре що у цій дівчині є сім'я яка може
допомогти А якщо немає то що ж робити у
мене Попереду ще декілька років
щоб
змінюватися ставати кращим здобувати
знання розвиватися але я дуже боюсь що
не зможу вступити в університет через
брак інформації
і я дуже не хочу щоб наявність порушення
слуху
визначало майбутню професію людини
максимально соціальна тема і сьогодні
всі теми наші максимально важкі але я
прошу вас Ілля задати питання Я думаю що
це буде буде пан Міністр освіти
Мені цікаво чи зараз в Україні
розробляються якісь діжутальні програми
які будуть допомагати нечуючим студентам
навчатися в будь-яких ВУЗах
якісно Навіть якщо там немає перекладача
от я не готовий відповісти на це
запитання на жаль Я переконаний в тому
що технології сучасні дозволяються
робити Я думаю що можливо Михайло мене
поправиться в світі такі підходи єсть
так Михайло доповнить мене але
однозначно те що ця проблема є важливою
її потрібно вирішувати вирішувати нам в
системі освіти
Головне що сьогодні ми знову
ознайоми які мають бути в повістки дня а
особливо сьогодні коли ми маємо так
багато ветеранів які повернулися з
фронту які будуть проходити перенавчання
які будуть змінювати свої професії які
будуть вступати в ВУЗи так багато дітей
які потребують різних програм які
адаптовані до для кожного ми ж країна
можливостей я переконана що ми сьогодні
програми для незрячих бійців так само
які різко втратили зір які не
адаптувалися до цього які потребують так
само перенавчання тому що вони втратили
разом із зором можливі займатися тою
професією до якої Вони готувалися і
освіту по якій вони отримали тому я
думаю що це потребує окремої так само
державної політики сьогодні інклюзивна
освіта розвивається Ми сьогодні
створюємо централізовану таку структуру
яка буде
займатися організаційно-методичним
управлінням мережею інклюзивно-ресурсних
центрів і звичайно що це завдання буде
стояти у нас
стоп завдань
рішення будуть завжди залишатися діти
які потребуватимуть молодь які
потребують потребуватимуть якісної
спеціальної освіти тож Дякую вам Ілля за
те що сьогодні ви там так будь ласка
приємно познайомитися
Я не буду називати прізвища але є один
топ-менеджер в нашій країні він керує
великою організацією однієї найбільш
впливовою в нашій країні і він втратив
слуг Він взагалі нічого вже не чує і
побудував свою роботу таким чином що
99,9 громадян взагалі під про це не
знають А вся команда і менеджмент працює
досить ефективно і він робить такі речі
зараз під час війни що він просто там ну
для мене є прикладом людини яка з в
таких умовах організувала свою роботу
це вдалося завдяки технологіям
Я особисто шукав йому продукти він мене
просив тому я трохи розбирався в цій
сфері І наприклад побачив що Google
створив і тестує спеціальні окуляри які
допомагають
розшифровувати все що говорять люди і
швидко розуміти е-е читати те що
відбувається і він використовує
технології п спеціальний телефон який це
тренувальна система яка в режимі
реального часу там допомагає все це
зрозуміти і
аналізувати інформацію Я впевнений що є
ще десятки технологій які зараз
розвиваються ми працюємо над стратегією
новації Зараз ми її повинні презентувати
десь в листопаді і там є один із
напрямків якраз Він має назву медтек
тобто технології в медицині ми розуміємо
що буде багато ветеранів які постраждали
під час війни ми розуміємо що потрібно
створювати для всіх громадян рівні
можливості для розвитку і це буде
окремий напрямок де ми будемо шукати
найкращі можливості в світі для того щоб
їх використовувати в Україні Я вірю в
технології вірю в те що завдяки
технологіям будь-яка людина може стати
тим ким вона хоче стати тому я впевнений
що ми з аксеном будемо працювати над
окремими стратегією як проводити
технології допомогти кожній дитині яка
потребує бути рівною і розвиватися
отримувати освіту тому Дякую за те що ви
сьогодні за те що організували там цю
розмову це наш таку також надихає швидше
рухатися в цьому напрямку і Я впевнений
що в цій стратегії новації буде окремий
напрямок який буде допомагати тобі і
людям які мають схожі проблеми Дякую я
дозволю собі назвати цю людину про яку
ми говорили це голова національного
банку України Андрій пишний оскільки для
нього максимально важливо також
соціально говорити про те що люди
рішенням слуху вони можуть досягати
будь-яких вершин як і люди без порушень
слуху як і люди з порушенням зору і
будь-які будь-які інші люди тому що
людина це в першу чергу людина тож дякую
Я сподіваюсь що щонайменше технологія
титрувальних систем вже піде в
скарбничку і системи освіти для
покращення можливостей для усіх і
переходимо з вами до останнього нашого
панеліста Вибачте філіппи що змусила вас
так довго чекати цієї розмови але
ваша історія справді неймовірна після
того як ви закінчили школу ви обрали
далі шлях свій навчання в українській
академії лідерства а Хм Цікава історія
цікавий шлях від школи до оал яким був
цей шлях власне
які були нюанси саме вступу в оал під
час повномасштабної
повномасштабної війни І власне яку що ви
бачите що робить молодь для того щоб
допомогти
нашим українцям зараз
дякую пані далі за запитання з вашого
дозволу буду робити це стоячи мені так
зручніше псене пане Михайло ради вас
бачити Вітаю всіх освітян України
Мене звати Філіп Слабошпицький Я
випускник Української Академії лідерства
студент києво-могилянської академії за
спеціальністю політології та член
всеукраїнського молодіжного екологічного
руху додають Ukraine і ось моя історія
25 лютого перший раз в моєму житті
пролунав сигнал повітряної тривоги моя
сім'я поїхала в паніці купувати продукти
а в цей час мені пише Євгеній Матейчук і
питаю в мене
філіпи а Ти в безпечному місці наша
співбесіда в силі
вже тоді мене вразила життєва стійкість
людей З академії
далі були довгі напружені місяці
покинута домівка друзі та кохана дівчина
екзамени у школі виїзд за кордон до
Польщі та Іспанії
весь цей час мене в душі гнитило наче
якась лихоманка ми не покидали важкі
думки про моє майбутнє про майбутнє моєї
країни
вже у Європі я остаточно вирішив
моє місце в українській академії
лідерстві А моя душа в Україні бо Хто
візьме відповідальність за країну якщо
не я
вересень перший день академії
на годиннику 2 години ночі А підйом вже
у шостій я настрій замазаний багнюкою
мокрий лежу в палаці і думаю Боже що я
тут роблю Що це за скажені люди Мене
оточують і як я на це підписався
вершина гори Петрос
2020 метрів над рівнем моря
навкруги мене більше сотні людей це за
студенти випускники команда академії ми
стаємо у коло і співаємо пісню Тараса
Петриненка Україно
і у такі моменти відчуваєш гормонію з
собою і з іншими і з усім оточуючим
світом
але це все емоції справді попереду На
мене чекає крутий спуск гори і ще 300
днів в академії
друга історія починається морозний
мовленнєвим ранком
сонце сліпить мені очі холод пробирає
моє тіло а я до інтерв'ю для телебачення
біля мене стоїть БТР Так вам не почулося
ми купили придбали І привезли у Львів
БТР завдяки таким колосальним зусиллям
Він опинився саме там що це навіть
складно уявити але ми це змогли разом Ми
зібрали 1 млн 200 тисяч гривень
ціла купа людей доклала зусилля до цього
бо ми розуміємо що це краплина в морі
але хоч якось ми Захистимо тих хто День
і ніч боронить нас на фронті
і розповідає чи про цю історію Я хочу
відзначити внесок шестикра на чемпіонки
України з гладкої атлетики моєї
улюбленої менторки і людини Без котрої
нічого всього не сталося реальністю у
рисі Дем'янюк
А ось вже літо Я випускник Української
Академії лідерства лунає дзвінок від
друга дитинства і радісні слова до мене
Філіп мене прийняли до академії і далі
Він додає я повернувся з Європи в
Україну в мене два варіанти вступити в
університет Чи подати документи в
академію
Але чесно кажучи я не зовсім певен що
таке вал на практиці
в той момент на моєму обличчі з'явилися
Усмішка Бо саме рік тому я був на тому
на тому самому місці І я без жодних
вагань одразу ми відповів подавай
документ бо рік в академії це
найскладніший рік мого життя це не
складніший рік для України
поки ми Україну обстрілювали ракетами я
навчався у кращих професорів та
викладачів поки ми і ми ставилися Нурі
не у темряву я переймав досвід провідних
політиків та підприємців поки у кранах
тепла холодна вода я бігав півмарафони
поки наші військові боронили нас на
фронті ми робили благодійні проекти на
їх підтримку у НАТО ОБСЄ європарламенті
на площі європейських міст ми адвокували
повернення викрадене в українських дітей
з на території Російської Федерації ми
навчалися 6 днів на тиждень сьомий ранку
по 10 годину вечора всі ми робили над
зусилля працювали навчалися ставали
краще
і розуміли що зараз ми просто не маємо
права на те щоб відпочивати бо ми
Україна народ борців земля добра край
гідності і свободи наша праця наша мрія
наша доля Слава Україні Героям слава
Дякую Філіпов знаєте
неймовірно приємно слухати ваші слова а
ще приємніше бачити Ваші дії і коли ви
говорите
вдумайтесь ми купили БТР Це Це просто
неймовірна Я дуже дякую вам насправді
неформальна освіта для кожної
української дитини це є можливість стати
кращими і здобути ще краще ще краще в
своїх ще більше своїх мрій наперед для
того щоб вони перетворилися в дію А будь
ласка ваше питання до кого воно буде
будь ласка адресуйте дякую питання до
пана Оксана
мене турбує
продовження освітньої реформи під час
військового стану Я хочу почути вашу
думку чи взагалі це реально
впроваджувати надалі нову українську
школу і які ви взагалі вбачаєте у цьому
виклику саме у військових реаліях дякую
А це реально і необхідно і ми сьогодні
багато говоримо про це окремо панель у
нас присвячена саме новій українській
школі
найкращий експерти два міністри
попередніх е-е освіти і науки задіяні в
цій панелі всі зараз вся все суспільство
працює на те щоб швидко відновити
реформу нової української школи
насправді вона перебуває в досить
складному стані ми знаємо що молодша
школа в молодшій школі була впроваджена
нова українська школа повноцінно вже
пішла друга хвиля набору дітей які
будуть навчатися за програмою нової
української школи хоча там є свої
проблеми наприклад немає посібників і
вони потребують досить Великого обсягу
фінансування і ті ж самі посібники
друкуються кожного року і кожного року
будуть
потребуватика ну е-е реформа яка
будь-яка реформа потребує фінансової
підтримки але виклик у нас основний - це
ба школа ми знаємо що після молодшої
школи діти пішли в базову школу і
реформа нової української школи не була
відповідним чином забезпечена не
відбулося повноцінного навчання вчителів
були сесії в онлайні так само з
навчанням вчителів але вони не були
повноцінними а-а але український
освітяни витягували реформу на своєму
ентузіазмі
вчителі шкіл самостійно опановували е-е
ті всі необхідні навички для викладання
в рамках реформи нової української школи
але ми з боку уряду сьогодні працюємо
над тим щоб повноцінно профінансувати
реформу і ви знаєте що от ми вже
говорили на попередніх наших е-е
діалогах про те що
заплановано і виділено вже Міністерство
освіти півтора мільярди Зараз ми
працюємо над постановою Кабінету
Міністрів щоб ці півтори мільярди
гривень на нову українську школу
спрямувати субвенцію до регіонів тому
реформи під час війни робити необхідно
не тільки можна їх робити просто
необхідно тим більше під час війни хоча
це і надзвичайно складно Дякую за
відповідь Дякую вам за ваш відгук про
вал бо в мене син також Зараз вступив на
ядерну фізику в університет і вступив
уал От і так само думає зараз куди йому
йти подав документи і туди і туди так
дуже приємно чути комусь в стані
перебувавши його колись Так так
яким би не було чудовим наше спілкування
але на жаль ми маємо завершувати нашу
панель а хочу підсумувати Сьогодні ми з
вами всі мали неймовірну нагоду
познайомитися з чудовими зразками
української молоді ми не встигнемо своїх
запитань
Давайте так іду на злочин даю вам тому
що якщо організатори будуть говорити що
Герасимчук порушує всі правила я скажу
що це винні будь ласка пане даю вам
можливість задати своє питання і
сподіваюсь що ми дуже швидко все дамо
сформуємо на нього відповідь ви знаєте
війна і ви от що мене цікавить війна і
ви е-е Я
співпереживав дуже підліткам тому що це
ті люди які я достатньо дорослими для
того щоб все усвідомлювати але не мають
всіх тих можливостей для того щоб
самореалізуватись в контексті війни
допомоги бойових дій
волонтерства не мають достатнього рівня
свободи не мають достатнього рівня
там фінансових можливостей не мають
можливості ще піти воювати
безпосередньої але Я переконаний що
кожен з вас співпереживав і переживав
всі ті події і шукав свою ро ль Скажіть
будь ласка роль якусь От ко- був той
момент коли у вас була дуже висока
тривога а потім ви знайшли щось за що
зачепились і І щоб визначило вашу роль в
контексті війни були такі моменти у вас
і як ви це переживали
Тільки дуже коротко що це було мікрофон
давно сидить без без можливості
висловитись будь ласка далі Та я у мене
був такий момент це був проект мико мрії
від українського академії лідерства і
українську данського молодіжного дому
Після чого я потрапила в класну команду
ми створили громадську організацію тут і
зараз
своїм покликанням я бачу
роботу діяльність для людей для містян
для миколаївців а саме по відновленню
культурного життя і нашої головної метою
є створення молодіжного центру дякую
дякую Дарія є ще додати будь ласка
насправді був такий момент
спочатку війни дуже сильно хотілося
якось повпливати тому що насправді події
після 24 лютого на жаль ті події на
Донбасі не змушували якось мене
переживати а після 24 лютого після цього
всього захотілося якось допомогти
Україні був такий момент що сиділи
думали і змогли реалізувати свою ідею на
підставі проєкту юектів створеного
спільно з сейв такого Глобал та з
передоформерика а-а моя команда речники
майбутнього
тут є декілька сьогодні
[сміх]
ми
вирішили знайти свою роль в волонтерстві
та благодійності і це більш до війни ми
переробляємо зараз пластик і робимо з
нього оці знаєте пластикові деталі на 3D
принтері для ЗСУ для тривога можливо
якихось і відправляємо їх туди на фронт
вже було декілька не декілька був з
десяток відправлень це ми бригадам і от
в цьому наше покликання в цьому Моє
покликання от отак от дякую
ще хочете додати
Насправді Я щодо війни працював вчителем
перших п'ятих класів вчителям
природознавства онлайн в школі проте
звісно коли почалась війна Я вже
благодійно намагався допомагати тим
особливо дітям з окупованих територій
які пропустили багато матеріалу Я
намагався їм допомогти з цим
природничі науки і математика
в коли вступав 11 клас Мені в мене було
запрошення вступити в англійській в
англійську школу на повний грант проте я
на той час відмовився тому що я розумію
що дуже багато активної молоді на жаль
виїхало тому я залишився намагався
підтримувати дебати культуру дебати
наприклад крім того ще звісно
продовжувати свою освітнівську
діяльність і ще я почав я взяв курс
Університетський курс філософії і я
намагався він був англійською звісно він
був досить складний але я все одно бачу
що багатьом дітям з України подобається
філософія але чомусь на жаль на з цього
предметом в школі немає і тому я почав
писати статті де я більш простими
словами українською мовою ось намагався
передавати деякі філософські статті
деякі філософські навчання щоб діти теж
могли трохи цим зацікавитися
А ви знаєте я завжди казала про те що
молодь потрібно дуже слухати тому що
вони неймовірно мотивують А я щоденно
отримую величезну кількість різних
повідомлень в усі можливі месенджери я
не знаю звідки люди знають Мій особистий
номер телефону але це якось так
трапилось і дуже часто
діти школярі пишуть про те що вони
змогли заспокоїтись коли знайшли себе в
благодійності в громадській діяльності
коли вони почали влаштовуватись на
роботу в благодійній організації хлопці
мовчать і я розкажу за них коли вони
влаштовуються і допомагають
пасувати благодійну допомогу гуманітарну
допомогу коли вони просто приходять до
сусідів посидіти з їх дітьми маленькими
поки дорослий може знайти час для себе і
сьогодні послухавши такі неймовірно
захоплюючі історії я зрозуміла сьогодні
Мені особисто треба негайно прочитати
плюс нову книжку подивитися Я ще обіцяла
власне сьогодні на попередньому
конференції Зранку я обіцяла подивитися
серіал Надія цифрова освіта кіберр няня
це те що в мене в планах сьогодні і
неймовірно захоплюючий історії ваші
мотивують Я думаю що те що прожила
проживають сьогодні наше молоде
покоління це та сила яка утримує нас
дорослих всіх освітян які сьогодні
слухали нас іще продовжують слухати для
того щоб 1 вересня ні насправді я
обманюю ми не ділимо на канікули 1
вересня освітян Такого не буває
насправді це пожиттєво А кожного дня іти
на роботу Кожного дня заходити до дітей
кожного дня допомагати їм тому в чому Їм
потрібна допомога або вони самі знають
як вони хочуть збудувати своє майбутнє
Дуже дякую сьогодні
панове міністри вам за участь в цьому
чудовому діалогу Я сподіваюсь що це буде
е-е не в останнє І хочу сказати що ми з
вами Дорогі українці дорогі освітяни
сьогодні проживаємо неймовірний час
випробувань але і неймовірний час для
того щоб мати нагоду збудувати нове
нереально круте майбутнє для наших дітей
і я впевнена що попри все ми впораємося
дякую всім і бажаю сьогодні ще активних
панелей
Дякую І ми надзвичайно і щиро дякую
Савчук нашим фантастичним просто молодим
українцям ви наше майбутнє і ми
пишаємося вже ним і панове міністри вам
теж Величезне спасибі
зараз важливе оголошення керівники
департаментів освіти керівники
департаментів освіти будь ласка
зберіться біля головною сцена або
безпосередньо на ній керівники
департаментів освіти якщо ви десь тут
разом з нами на головній сцені просто
Підійдіть поближче якщо ви десь почуйте
і підходьте
так ну і поки декілька хвилин у нас є
оголошення про те що буде далі у нас
дорогі друзі а о 13:30 за 8 хвилин
продовжать працювати клубні зони в
рожевому секторі Світлана ройз запрошую
до розмови на тему стійкість для стійких
практичне дитинознавство воєнного часу
та Турбота про тих хто піклується в
червоному секторі відбудеться дискусія
на тему Громадянської освіти та
презентація книги Ірини Озимок у міста є
я
тема Roll International Partner
буде розглядатися в синьому секторі мова
панелі англійська звісно із синхронним
перекладом також продовжують свою роботу
і інші клубні зони про тематику
наступних панелей ви можете дізнатися за
qr-кодами на ваших бейжах та
інформаційних стендах біля тематичних
зон
Ну а тут на головній серії о 13:30 Ми
раді представити вам дискусійну панель
реакція на світові кризи і стратегії
виходу з них освітній контекст яку буде
вести пан Сергій колибошин заступник
голови комітету Верховної Ради України з
питань освіти науки та інновацій ну і
звісно пані та панове звертаємо вашу
увагу що в секторі фотовиставки ви
можете долучитися до акції що спрямована
на збір донатів для облаштування укриття
ліцею номер 55 в місті Миколаїв акція
відбувається за ініціативи Міністерства
освіти і науки України та фонду сейвд
Запрошуємо долучитися до акції до НАТО
та стати володаром спеціальних
подарунків нагадаю із підписами Тараса
тополі лідера гурту Антитіла та Оксана
лісового міністра освіти і науки України
підходьте до сектору фотовиставки
дізнаватися деталі І беріть участь Ну а
додаткова інформація для керівних
керівників департаментів освіти на 14:30
це так репетиція була зараз буде ще одна
дискусія і після після неї в 14:30
збираємося Всі тут а в 13:30 за 6 хвилин
вже наступна дискусія
[музика]
[оплески]
шановні пари та панове дорогі друзі час
летить невпинно і за 5 хвилин на
головній сцені розпочнеться дискусійна
панель реакція на світові кризи із
стратегії виходу з них освітній контекст
тому всіх чекаємо Біля головної сцени
[музика]
[оплески]
пані та панове дорогі друзі за дві
хвилини на головній сцені розпочинається
наступна дискусія чекаємо всіх охочих
взяти в ній участь на головній сцені
займайте місця
[музика]
[оплески]
дорогі друзі знаю що багато з вас вже
пристойно так зголодніли і чекають обіду
але обід у нас за розкладом за годину
звісно каву тістечко чи що щось можна
перехопити але повноцінне обідня перерва
у нас за годину тому Майте це на увазі
дочекайтеся
[музика]
[оплески]
вже пані та панове Давайте так і так би
мовити звірімо годинники всі трошечки
вже втомилися але Попереду ще багато
цікавого тому мусимо бути в тонусі
дочекайтеся а офіційний обідньої перерви
Це буде десь плюс-мінус за годину а ну а
зараз Давайте так
13:405 а-а розпочнуть роботу наступну на
частину своєї роботи всі клубні зони в
двох словах що Де буде відбуватися в
рожевому секторі Світлана ройз запрошує
до розмови на тему стійкість для стійких
практичної дитинознавство воєнного часу
та Турбота про тих хто піклується у
червоному секторі відбудеться дискусія
на тему Громадянської освіти та
презентація книги Ірина озимук у міста є
я
далі тема Rolling International Partner
буду розглядатися в синьому секторі мова
панелі англійська але є можливість
синхронного перекладу тому долучайтеся
також звісно продовжують свою роботу і
інші клубні зони проблематику у
наступних панелей там ви можете
дізнатися за qr-кодами на ваших бейджах
та інформаційних стендах біля тематичних
зон єдине що там буде вказано 13:30 ми ж
домовилися що в 13:45 розпочинаються
наступні частини Ну а тут на головній
сцені Буквально за три хвилини Ми раді
представити вам дискусійну панель
реакція на світові кризи і стратегії
виходу з них освітній контекст за 3
хвилини Все це на головній сцені тому
Обирайте або клубну зону або Головно
сцену де ви плануєте провести найближчу
годину і долучайтеся ще дві-три хвилинки
чекаємо і розпочинаємо
[музика]
[оплески]
дорогі друзі Ще раз ще раз Дякуємо за
вашу активність і залученість займайте
місця тут на головній сцені ми будемо
продовжувати нашу серпневу і як і було
повідомлено раніше зараз ми вас
Запрошуємо до продовження конференції і
ще раз нагадаю що тематичні клубні зони
працюють за окремою програмою а визнає
можете ознайомитися в розкладі так за
хвилину буквально вони будуть
розпочинати ми ж продовжуємо тут на
головній розпочинаємо панель реакція на
світовій кризи і стратегії виходу з них
освітній контекст Ну а модератором цієї
розмови є заступник голови комітету
Верховної Ради України з питань освіти
науки та інновацій пан Сергій колибошин
Вітаю пане Сергію і передаю вам слово
Дякую Вітаю всіх учасників і учасниць
нашої серпневої конференції Як тих хто
тут зараз за нами слідкують так і тих
хто в онлайні і ми розпочинаємо нашу
сесію Як ви вже чули її назва освіти в
часи кризи світовий досвід і уроки для
України на початку я нагадаю про
протокол наших дій у випадку повітряної
тривоги Ми перериваємо цю сесію і
Відповідно ми потрапляємо всі в
бомбосховищі де чекаємо на Відбій Після
чого ми здається будемо мати надію
продовжимо але я сподіваюсь що ми
спокійно попрацюємо Дякуємо нашим ППО
Дякуємо нашим ЗСУ отже почнімо і я
спочатку представлю наше поважне
експертне коло буде робити це за абеткою
починаємо Сергій Бабак голова комітету
Верховної Ради з питань освіти науки і
інновації
Лілія Гриневич міністр освіти та науки
України
2016-2019 роки Перша проректорка
інституту Грінченка
оксен Лісовий Міністр освіти і науки
України
Марічка Падалко українська телеведуча
Мурат Шахін голова представництва
дитячого фонду ООН юнісеф в Україні і з
нами в онлайні зараз пан Андрес шляхер
Андре шляйхер - це директор з питань
освіти ос і дії організації економічного
співробітництва та розвитку вітаємо пана
адрес
[оплески]
фактично всі ми з вами вже відчуваємо ті
значні негативні наслідки для системи
української освіти які ми маємо через
пандемію ковід і особливо через
повномасштабне вторгнення за даними
інтерактивного порталу Міністерства
освіти і науки
341 українська школа зруйнована Ми
готували цей текст три дні тому і на
жаль ця статистика тільки збільшилась
всі ми пам'ятаємо трагічні події які
були на Сумщині
3241 заклад освіти пошкоджений їх всіх
необхідно буде відновлювати
перерви в освітньому процесі зміни
формату навчання психологічні проблеми
все це зумовлює суттєві освітні втрати і
розриви які ми маємо з вами долати усіма
можливими шляхами
водночас ми бачимо що ми не одні на
цьому не простому шляху Минулого року
організація економічного співробітництва
і розвитку та особисто пан Андреа шляхер
започаткували ініціативу освіта в часи
кризи ця ініціатива може дати Україні
цінну інформацію на шляху до освітніх
змін після нашої Перемоги У рамках
проекту 10 країн з різних куточків світу
я їх перерахую це Естонія Індія Ірландія
Канада Південна Корея Португалія
Туреччина Фінляндія Швеція та Японія
поділилася власним досвідом власними
ідеями та розробками як долати освітні
кризи причому спектр проблем був
абсолютно різний від просто падіння
результатів до реагування на стихійні
лиха до реагування на в тому числі і
військові конфлікти
дуже важливо щоб цей досвід пропустити
крізь себе та накласти на наше
українське реалії і цю почесну місію
Взяла на себе пані Лілія Гриневич яка
проаналізувала цей цю доповідь і
виокремила ті речі які будуть
найактуальніші для України коли ми
будемо коли ми вже фактично знаходимось
в процесі відновлення
тих викликів які з'явилися внаслідок
війни цю аналітику та досвіди оср
об'єднала велику доповідь велику
публікацію презентація перша презентація
цієї публікації відбулась в червні цього
року на національній події едкем Воля
цей документ вже доступний українською
мовою він розміщений або буде розміщений
найближчим часом на офіційному сайті
серпневої
серпнева.com або за прямими посиланнями
які теж ви зможете побачити найближчим
часом І власне ми маємо розпочати з того
щоб ознайомитись із тим що ж є в цій
презентації і кого покликати для цього
як не її співтворця нашого доброго друга
доброго друга України доброго друга
українського освіти я передаю слово
панові андреасушляйхеру пана андерса The
Flower is yours about fifteen mines
please
[оплески]
[музика]
стійкість стресостійкість оптимізм і
енергійність і оцей
тризостійкість
і
звичайно
Якраз для того щоб поліпшити взаємини
учнів і вчителів
освіта це завжди
соціальна
Фактор
соціальні відносини і наші спроможність
наша цікавість наша хоробрість наша
лідерство
все це народжується на основі соціальних
відносин соціальної емоційних відносин і
це прекрасна робота для вас допомогти
учням щоб вони знайшли себе допомогти їм
у цій подорожі І ось чому
Вчителі України дійсно ви заслуговуєте
усілякої підтримки і
щоб не те щоб зробити неможливо можливим
А щоб можливо бути щоб воно було
досягаємо
і забагато дуже корисних речей які ви
ваша команда робите для України власне
Зараз саме час повернутися до України і
подивитися проекцію тих результатів які
досвід у проекцію яка зробила пані Лілія
Гриневич будь ласка поділіться з нами що
є найважливішим з вашої точки зору на що
ми маємо звернути увагу який досвід
єрелевантним для нашої ситуації будь
ласка пані Лілія Так дякую Я дуже дякую
взагалі організація економічної
співпраці і розвитку директорату Андреа
сушляйхеру тому що ми зараз можемо через
цю оптику подивитися на ситуацію в
Україні відверто вам скажу коли я писала
цей розділ до цієї праці по досвідах
країн Для мене було ще особисте завдання
розказати про Україну тому що про це
будуть читати у світі а в Україні теж
відбувається багато дивовижних речей і
наш досвід кризи і виходу з кризи мабуть
є унікальний і жодна країна зараз 21
столітті нічого подібного не відчуває
звичайно цей вплив війни на шкільну
освіту і з одного боку а з іншого боку
освітні зміни які почалися
підвоєнній Україні і які мають велику
тривалість і зараз ми мусимо їх
продовжувати Я спробувала оці всі
інсайти з досвіду десяти країн
згрупувати за основними напрямками на за
якими ми впроваджуємо освітню реформу
цих напрямків 8 Ось вони на слайді і я
зараз спробую пройтися по цих напрямках
і розказати про релевантні Україні
досвіти Ну звісно всі ми мислимо про
подолання освітніх втрат і розривів І
хочу сказати що на цю тему є окрема
праця знову ж таки директорату
відновлення втрачених освітніх
можливостей в Україні і це про відкриті
платформи репетиторство Я думаю що це
надзвичайно релевантно для України з тим
рівнем цифризації яку ми маємо і є
прекрасна ініціатива платформи повір але
Сергій коли бувши натхненник цієї
ініціативи більше про неї може
розповісти е-е це продіагностичні Тести
які До речі в нас вже також появилися на
вшо це про додаткові цифрові освітні
ресурси літні школи табори адаптації
освітніх програм особливо це буде
важливо для деокупованих територій Коли
нам треба буде інтегрувати цих дітей в
українській контекст е-е і тут Швеція от
цікавий досвід Швеції що вони працюючи з
дітьми робили мапи їхніх сильних сторін
і потреб для того щоб опиратись на
сильні сторони дуже цікавий досвід
Туреччини яка пережила шалений землетрус
ви це знаєте Там було дуже багато жертв
і зруйновані повністю школи і їм треба
було швидко повернутися до освіти у них
також є цікаві інсайти коли вони
створювали мобільні школи в яких
безпосередньо навчались діти вчителям
забезпечували транспорт і проживання
тимчасове для того щоб вчителі змогли
доїхати до дітей і продовжувати з ними
освіту
важливим є оновлення змісту освіти Ми з
вами зараз хочу сказати в світовому
тренді
наша реформа нова українська школа пов
впровадженню компетентнісного навчання і
оцих ключових компетентностей зокрема
Європейського Союзу
надзвичайно релевантна до світового
досвіду але проблема в тому як це
впроваджується Наприклад в Ірландії - це
рамка компетентнісної освіти
супроводжується величезною кількістю
навчально-методичних матеріалів для
вчителів і
поясненням кожній цільовій групі
суспільства А в чому сутність цієї
реформи через те і Бізнес і інші
стейхолдири повертаються обличчям до
реформи в Португалії також як вже
говорив адрес досить Сонячна реформа Яка
теж грунтувалась на Широкий
інформаційній компанії і максимум
роз'яснення і підтримки вчителів
Я хочу звернути увагу щодо нації
центричних предметів коли Естонія
будувала свою
систему освіти то найважливішими
предметами з точки зору їх оновлення і
продовження оновлення а в нашій ситуації
коли ми зараз терпимо геноцид
українського народу вже
новий період геноциду Ми повинні оновити
наші мову літературу історію географію
дивлячись власне з цієї системи
координат і через цю оптику війни
надзвичайно важливим є оновлення
громадянської освіти у Делі Делі
зрозуміло попереду всієї Індії в
розвитку своєї системи освіти
окрема програма національна гордість від
дошкілля 12 класу яка розповідає дітям
починаючи там від Конституції права
згуртування підтримки
відданості національним цінностям
ви почули в презентація андреасашляйхера
про оцю додану цінність нової освіти це
не лише про знання з різних предметів і
Виявляється що
життєво успішність молодих людей
базується на розвитку їхніх м'яких
соціально-емоційних навичок та життєвої
стійкості і до речі багато країн
перезавантажуючи свою систему освіти
відбудовуючи школи завжди базувалися на
оцій доданій цінності наприклад в
Ірландії Зараз проводиться політика
добробуту в школах і це не просто
добробут як ми розуміємо матеріальний
добробут це всі аспекти добробуту
починаючи від емоційного
психологічного морального фізичного
матеріального
яким чином створювати добробут для своїх
родин для країни і так далі І це
наскрізний курс з першого класу по 12-й
хочу сказати що в нашому державному
стандарті базової освіти слово добробут
згадується 97 разів головне нам тепер
зрозуміти як досягати цих результатів
навчання вважаю що для наших дітей оце
категорія Well being тобто добробут
благополуччя в ситуації післявоєнної
України під час війни стає чи
нестержневою ідеєю освіти для того щоб
ми забезпечили їхню майбутню успішність
у Канаді цілісний погляд на людину в них
є спеціальна програма коло мужності яке
б яка базується це програма для корінних
народів які репресувалися
з приводу їхньої національної системи
освіти але на чому вона головне
базується на національних цінностях в
Делі зовсім недавно
відбудовуючи нові школи Вони зробили
пілотний проект школа шкіл точок росту
системи освіти і там впровадили програму
для першого-9 класу яка називається
програма щастя як що таке щастя яким
чином досягати щастя на різних рівнях
від індивідуальності до щастя країни і
далі Ця програма розвивається в
підприємницьке мислення і це обов'язкові
45 хвилин кожного дня окремий урок і
очевидно що цей досвід неймовірно
цікавий для України і демонструє те що
якщо ви хочете щось реально запровадити
мало про це говорити
мріяти що цей інтегрується в усі
предмети розмитим чином А це має бути
цілеспрямована політика з
навчально-методичним забезпеченням для
вчителів і подивіться всі всі країни які
запровадили реальні зміни вони
обов'язково дуже багато працювали над
розробкою матеріалів для вчителів для
учнів і навіть для батьків
щодо учителів Я б хотіла тут привернути
увагу обов'язково по-перше до зміни
підготовки вчителів закладах вищої
освіти Естонія Фінляндія взагалі
перезавантажили свою педагогічну освіту
в Ірландії є важлива ідея яка стосується
нашої базової школи для переходу до
нової української школи це від
ізоляціоністської культури
вчителів-предметників до культури
співпраці
22 години на рік
всі вчителі-предметники зобов'язані між
собою збиратися і обговорювати нові
методики навчання з їхнього предмету
відповідно до ціннісної освітньої
політики Яка впроваджується цікава є
робота з керівниками шкіл наприклад в
Делі програма розвитку кластерного
лідерства
зрозуміло Індія величезна країна Делі
величезна провінція в Україні нам теж
потрібне класне лідерство Тим більше що
таке це кластерний лідерство
регіональний лідерство коли ми маємо
різні потреби регіонів зокрема під час
війни і ми маємо разом навчати
керівників закладів освіти в проведенні
цієї політики
дуже важливе для нас відновлення шкіл ми
розуміємо скільки треба буде інвестувати
в реконструкції шкіл в будівництво нових
шкіл але це переживала наприклад Японія
коли в них сталася потрійна катастрофа
землетрус Цунамі і вибух на фокусімі І
от в цей час коли знесло буквально в
двох провінціях все вщент вони
відновлювали свої школи Цей проект
називається школи тохоку і ідея проєкту
було не відбудувати школи а наповнити їх
новим змістом і щоб ці випускники стали
потім цією основною кваліфіка-
кваліфікованою суспільною силою яка
змінить цей регіон І до речі цей проєкт
реалізовувався в партнерстві з
організацією економічної співпраці та
розвитку він був власне
розроблений на те щоб орієнтуватися на
оцей сучасний компас навчання
2030 і у
школярів формувати те що називається
агентність
проактивність коли ти не пасуєш перед
труднощами А ти готовий вирішувати
складні проблеми і знаєш як до них
підійти до речі ще один важливий тут
момент для цього проєкту це зв'язок з
зовнішнім світом школи не замикалися
собі бо важкій ситуації вам потрібно
співпраця з бізнесом з громадськими
організаціями І от будувати ці відкриті
екосистеми взаємодій було Теж завданням
цього проєкту Я особисто вважаю що це
може бути дуже цікавою пропозицією для
співпраці між організацією економічної
співпраці і розвитку і міністерством
освіти і науки України в сенсі власне
підтримки оцих
побудованих шкіл і наповнення їх нових
новим змістом ще один супер цікавий
проект в Південній Кореї це зелені
розумні школи зараз з лютого 2023 року
свіжий проєкт
перезавантажується знову ж таки кілька
сотень пілотних шкіл вони вирішили
відбудувати приміщення шкіл які старіші
40 років ну тобто мають будівлі більше
ніж 40 років і ось знову ж таки ідея
наповнити їх новим змістом і тут була
ідея дати цим дітям компетентності для
життя в змінному світі збереження
довкілля і зокрема шляхом цифрової та
екологічної освіти причому дбають про
все наприклад як де будуть навчатися Ці
діти коли їхня школа будується або
реконструюється є цілий концепт
портативних класів на час відбудови шкіл
думаю це дуже цікавий в перспективі для
нас досвід
цифровізація освіти Естонія Фінляндія
по-перше відкриті освітні онлайн-ресурси
До речі цікаво що наприклад у Фінляндії
вони відкриті в живому доступі якщо є
електронний підручник то творці
електронного підручника на основі
зворотнього зв'язку від вчителів і
батьків можуть вносити туди зміни
динамічні надзвичайно процеси які
стосуються наприклад
Рівного доступу до якісної освіти
деокуповані території
приклад Канада все починається з Правди
а після Правди примирення тому що це
окреме питання Яким чином ми будемо
відбудовувати освіту і взаєморозуміння
на деокупованих територіях тут дуже
цікавий досвід Я сподіваюся що в нас ще
буде нагода показати більш докладно цей
досвід але я всіх спрямо до цього звіту
незабаром він буде доповнений ще
кількома країнами де ми можемо мати
цінні інсайти і остання остання ідея як
фактор успіху всіх успішних реформ
залучення і комунікації
якнайбільше суспільство має бути
втягнено в розробку реформи а потім про
комуніковано кожному що він має робити
на це треба і дуже важливо витрачати час
про стратегії відновлення які мають бути
різні для різних територій про це я вже
сказала але пам'ятаймо ми у війні але
демократизація освіти є надзвичайно
важлива навіть в цей час коли ми спішимо
ми мусимо почути різних людей для того
щоб вони були справді співтворцями наших
освітніх змін дякую
Дякуємо лілії Михайлівна ми вкотре
бачимо що наша ситуація мабуть серед тих
які тільки що пролунали є найгострішою і
найважчою в Японії
екологічне лихо в нас Каховка в Кореї
декілька десятків шкіл яким більше 40
років в нас більше трьох тисяч шкіл яких
взагалі немає і Ну я навіть не знаю яка
кількість шкіл більше 100 років будівлі
і так можна по кожній країні тому наша
ситуація є і надскладною і викликає над
амбітними і в цьому сенсі от ми
переходимо більше до такого
інтерактивного формату до запитань та
відповідей в мене перше запитання до
пана міністра до оксена коли ви
виступали разом з Михайлом і
презентували візію коли виступав Андрес
і Лілія Михайлівна і ми бачили ті кейси
і майже кожен кейс бери і впроваджує в
нас Ну дійсно там школи то хоку
те що роблять Швеція те що робить Кожна
з цих країн Я думаю що не тільки в мене
в багатьох виникає питання а щось
спроможні ми це зробити а як це зробити
а чи встигне Міністр освіти це все
проконтролювати Міністерство освіти там
а Комітет Верховної Ради Не приймати
відповідні зміни до законодавства як
зробити так щоб всі усвідомили що це
справа всієї держави що це досить часто
лунає Я не люблю це фразу освітній фронт
Але тим не менше що кожен хто залучений
до системи освіти має робити це і не
тільки залучений до системи освіти Бо як
я як це зробити Оксана дякую Сергію
Дякую вам Лілія Михайлівна я дякую
андресу так само вірному такому партнеру
і другу України
безумовно ця ваша ідея щодо використання
досвіду і в співпраці з
організацією економічного
співробітництва буде цікава Міністерство
освіти тому що Як це зробити відповідь
на ваше запитання полягає в тому в чому
наша сила насправді тому що на сьогодні
ну навіть Міністерство освіти перебуває
в трьох паралельних процесах це процес
поточної діяльності і супроводу освіти
той нормальний Мирний стабільний процес
який відбувався і відбувається завжди
процес війни сховища гаджети відповідь
на її виклики адаптація до неї освітні
втрати все що вона нам принесла і процес
реформ так які ми повинні продовжувати
якими повинні відновити ті що були
розпочаті і успішно їх
продовжити імплементувати всі їх ідеї
сьогодні і повинні розвивати розширювати
спектр охоплення галузей реформами так
то ті які повинні розпочати буквально з
нуля з мінуса От і де на все це знайти
сили
І як це все проконтролювати і у мене
відповідь тут одна Тим більше що давайте
так
в в світі немає більш складних систем
ніж система освіти ну в країнах мається
на увазі ніж система охорони здоров'я і
армія так мабуть три такі найскладніші
системи і
зміни в цих системах проходять
надзвичайно складно всюди де вони
реалізовувались це досить складний
процеси це
зміни в цих системах пов'язані зі
змінами в суміжних системах тому що
неможливо проводити реформу в освіті не
змінюючи систему фінансування відповідно
це буде задівать уже сферу Міністерства
фінансів Міністерства економіки
неможливо змінювати
систему державного замовлення не не
входячи в сферу діяльності тої зміни
економіки і інших а-а суміжних галузей
тому
де знайти на це ресурс особливо в
контексті війни особливо коли його мало
і сила українців полягає в тому що
власне привело нас до успіху те що я
особисто свій свою доповідь що нас
привело до перемоги точно не інструкція
Міністерства освіти так або міністер або
Кабінету Міністрів коли розпочалась
війна всі робили на своєму місці свою
справу і от дуже важливо Це комунікація
це діалог з усіма стоїть холдерами в
першу чергу діалог між освітянами чому
ми е-е От у нас уже маємо появились про
нашу візію Так бо всі чомусь оці
очікували що візія - це така інструкція
по якій ми далі будемо покроково
рухатись і виконувати щось хороше або
щось погане або щось що ми підтримуємо
Ви що ми покритикуємо а насправді візія
- це пробачень і про перший крок
стратегування і стратегія - це те що
важливо створити для
для того щоб у нас не траплялись такі
кейси як
нова українська школа ну в Sorry Так
дякую вам Комітет з питання освіти і
Лілія михайльної всі всім активістам Які
підтримували Дякую всім освітянам але
реформа була збережена хоч і втратами
безумовно втратами от але
стратегія - це те що повинно бути
прийнято консенсусом
суспільним консенсусом в першу чергу
освітян і експертів в цій сфері і тому
комунікація - це Перша наша сила і тому
реалізація ідей повинна іти ну
будь-яке впровадження будь-яких ідей і
рішень може відбуватися зверху знизу і
комбінованим методом І от наш шляху шлях
українців це точно не імплементація
реформ зверху
тому що на сьогодні коли ми дивилися
показники
того скільки дітей повернуться до
офлайннового навчання до аудиторного
навчання і бачили результати і бачили
хороші результати Дякую вам всім колеги
за цю величезну роботу то це якраз перш
за все робота громад перш за все їх
заслуга і От вам будь ласка це відповідь
на виклик війни який дали люди на місцях
і тому коли ми говоримо про
трансформації в освіті ми бачимо Так що
всі країни працюють над цим і розвинені
і ті що розвиваються і економічні
Гіганти і маленькі країни всі вони
працюють над постійними трансформаціями
в освіті І от що важливо нам е-е
усвідомлювати Шановні колеги реформа в
освіті - це не подія яка повинна
відбутися це безперервний процес освіта
формує майбутнє це майбутнє змінюється
сьогодні кожен день фільми вносимо в це
майбутнє корективи в них вносить
корективи сьогодні війна завтра клімат
післязавтра розвиток технологій постійно
змінюється
формула задачі яку ми повинні вирішити і
тому
динамічність гнучність і змінність
повинна стать новою якістю освіти тобто
реформа - це те що повинно відбуватися
постійно це те над чим ми повинні думати
постійно кожного дня на своєму робочому
місці І це не завдання Міністерства
освіти виключно чи комітету з питань
освіти Чи Кабінету Міністрів це завдання
кожного освітянина і тоді у нас буде
відбуватися такий взаємний тиск Так коли
ми будемо отримувати тиск на політики
наші які Ми формуємо знизу тому що ви на
місцях ті люди які працюють з дітьми в
школах або працюють з колективами в
своїх закладах уже знайшли краще рішення
ніж те яке запаковане в політиці і тоді
землі виконує ту функцію яку і комітет
обидва Сергій та і весь Комітет з
питання освіти і депутати виконують ту
функцію вони
моніторять що відбувається
засобами інструментами Міністерства
освіти або іншими інструментами і
змінюють політики і отаким чином
відбувається насправді динаміка і вона
найбільш найбільш якісна і найбільша
буде відповідати інтересам тих цільових
аудиторій для яких ми працюємо
Дякую Оксана Васильовичу Якщо коротко
Менше патерналізму більше довіри і
ініціативи це моя ціннісний підхід
Свобода Довіра гідність так
але тут пролунало що візія це не
інструкція до використання для того щоб
візія перетворилася на окремі кроки Ну
звичайно має попрацювати в тому числі і
Комітет Верховної Ради тобто звичайно
мають з'явитися відповідні зміни до
законодавства нові закони які будуть
вирішувати допомагати вирішувати бо
вирішувати будемо всі ми не ті хто тут
зараз в арсеналі а всі ми вся країна за
допомогою партнерів звичайно знову не
втомлюємось дякувати Але тим не менш як
вирішувати проблеми міграційних викликів
як вирішувати проблеми подолання
освітніх розривів і втрат як вирішувати
інші проблеми і перетворювати це на
реальні інструкції в кроки Це мабуть
питання в першу чергу в одну з перших
черг до законодавчої гілки влади до
комітету з питань освіти науки та
інновації тому пане Сергію будь ласка
яким є бачення комітету Яким є бачення
законодавчого органу щодо того які кроки
треба робити щоб повернути дітей до
України щоб подолати освітні втрати і
розриви може ще якісь рекомендації які
зараз є от На порядку денному комітету
будь ласка
ну по-перше дуже незвично від тебе чути
пане Сергію Чесно кажучи від тебе теж
чути пане Сергію незвично
якщо серйозно
птиця якщо ми говоримо про такі складні
речі як наприклад
повертати дітей з-за кордону в Україну
або долати навчальні втрати
тут як приблизно перефразуючи трошки
вакцини немає на жаль навіть за всі
гроші світу немає такої чудової пігулки
яку всі проковтнуть і це все відводиться
і діти повернуться в Україну і освітні
втрати кудись дінуться і більше їх не
буде це насправді дуже кропітка робота і
причому кропітка робота Я навіть би
сказав би що менше законодавчої влади
але в синергії з усіма іншими насправді
тому що немає такого закону як цієї
чарівної пігулки який ми приймемо всі
зміниться ні закон е-е Валерія
Михайловна знає це не гірше за нас закон
про освіту Наприклад Це закон який буде
імплементувати сороками він буде
закладати нові цінності ці цінності
будуть визрівати потім суспільство їх
приймає і так далі І так далі це дуже
довгий процес більше того це динамічний
процес як правильно зауважив акцент бо
це постійний перегляд аналіз перегляд
знов запропону- пропозиція змін
удосконалення і ще раз потім аналіз
переглядусконалення це без приватний
процес тому я би тут Я напевно не назвав
би я зараз жодної законодавчої зміни яка
може вирішити ті питання про які ти
говориш і якщо
але якщо більш практично і це повернення
дітей з-за кордону
зараз вже пройшло півтора роки якщо ви
подивитесь і піднімете зараз опитування
яке робилися серед наших зовнішніх
переселенців рік тому і зараз відсоток
тих хто точно повернеться На жаль
зменшується Люди там адаптуються родини
адаптуються батьки знаходять роботу діти
вже йдуть в школу вони вже будуть
атестовані другий раз зараз і вже
атестовані другий раз вони другий раз
переходять в наступний клас їм буде все
важче повертатися і для того щоб їх
повернути назад коли вони там вже мають
легальну роботу діти йдуть до школи і
мають якоїсь соціальне забезпечення
треба щонайменше зробити у нас
щонайменше так само як там а бажано
краще і оця наша політика рибілз Back
Better вона дуже правильна це якраз наш
не тільки виклик а і шанс на
трансформацію це той момент коли ми
будемо відбудовувати не просто
відбудовувати школи будемо відбудовувати
якісно новий освітній простір
наповнювати його новими сенсами і навіть
не боятися експериментувати з цим
не боятися тому що ми зараз маємо
можливість і по суті ми вже це робимо Я
зараз на іншому прикладі це покажемо ми
навіть ми зараз впроваджуємо
найпередовищі практики в світі хоча ми
цього не помічаємо в усьому стресі Да і
в усьому важкому інформаційному полі в
якому ми живемо Наприклад якщо ми
говоримо про освітніх втрати і подолання
освітніх втрат і навчальних втрат
освітніх розвів зараз
колись коли почалася пандемія якщо ви
пам'ятаєте був перший прообраз
української школи онлайн Коли ми спільно
з міністерством зробили школу на
телебаченні
школа на телебаченні це якісь напевно
вчорашній день закінчились тим що через
декілька місяців коли в країнах Європи
яка розвинена Європи яка покладалася на
інструменти в інтернеті почав лягати
інтернет фізично бо він не витримував
такої кількості потокового відео яке всі
запитували і я пам'ятаю в один момент
коли дружина Президента Франції
подзвонила дружині президенту України і
запитала слухайте як ви це зробили Як ви
зробили Як ви додумалися до такого
простого інструменту який насправді
доступний технологічно для кожного Да це
було тимчасове рішення а далі з'явилися
всеукраїнська школа онлайн в тому
вигляді в якому є зараз до неї
докручений модуль який дає можливість
саме тестування для того щоб розуміння
для розуміння які ж освітні втрати все ж
таки є у кожної дитини і кожен має до
неї вільний доступ з'являється платформа
повір яка сама по собі чудова і має
взагалі інший принцип як убер школа з
такими самими елементами ми впроваджуємо
на що
[музика]
іноді навіть боїться бояться робити
розвинені країни по-перше в них немає
такого викладу як війна як в нас а
по-друге вони справді більш
консервативні ніж ми Нам зараз нема що
втрачати тому ми експериментуємо з цими
моделями і мені здається що єдине чого
нам зараз не вистачає це упакувати це в
один в один великий пакет який ми можемо
дати всім Це питання комунікації зокрема
тому що важко комунікувати коли в тебе є
25 розрізнених елементів і про і давати
їм дивіться в нас є і те і те і те і те
але якщо їх впакувати в один то це буде
дуже Мені здається ефективно І от заради
цього якраз ти запитав про роль комітету
ти найкраща знаєш Ніж я бо це твоє
питання яке ти ведеш в комітеті але ми
2,5 місяці тому провели комітетські
слухання якраз по системі подолання
освітніх втрати розривів нас понеділок
якраз буде follow Up по цьому офіційно
засідання комітету де ми будемо
контролити те що ми запропонували
зробити і отам першим пунктом є
створення
національного плану подолання освітніх
втрат і через те що ми всі знаємо що
робиться але робиться точково нам оці ці
точкові рішення потрібно упакувати в
один національний план і дати всім
зрозуміло карту як рухатись як рухатись
причому дати їх як директорам шкіл
директорам департаментів вчителям
батькам І самим дітям бо більшість цих
елементів дозволяє В принципі цю роботу
проводити самостійно тому в даному
випадку і ми робимо якісь кроки як
законодавча влада Міністерство робить ще
більше кроків бо їм вони є виконавчою
владою їм це імплементувати більше того
це робить дуже багато вчителів абсолютно
більшість абсолютно більшість шкіл але
це результату ефективно ми досягнемо
тільки коли тоді тільки тоді коли будемо
всі разом з енергетично працювати дякую
дякую Сергій Віталійович Що
наступне питання до п Мурата Перш ніж я
його буду ставити Я б хотів би
сказати Велике дякую і вам пана Мурат і
організації яку ви представляєте юнісеф
зато величезну допомогу яку ми всі в
Україні Ну дійсно відчуваємо спасибі Вам
Велике
тепер до запитання як свідчить досвід
інших країн освіта майбутнього є тісно
пов'язаною із поняттям благополуччя в
All being як відказали Лілія Михайлівна
і Андрес
це цей термін це підходив їх
запроваджують в своїй освітній системі
Різні країни вони роблять це по-різному
по-різному це осмислюють відповідно саме
поняття добробуту в освіті теж розуміють
по-різному тому питання до вас як
розглядає що таке добробут добробут
взагалі добробут в системі освіти
юнісеф ваша організація як на ваш погляд
можна впроваджувати його в освіті і
створювати середовище яке сприятиме
добробуту дітей дякую
дякую
[музика]
я от пишу записничку і прекрасні інсайти
надходять і перше запитання
отже отже
міністр освіти та заступник
прем'єр-міністра Федорова
вони пам'ятають школа
отже дуже інтенсивна позашкільна Вони
хотіли б базуватися на результатах щоб
досягнути результати і і отже
отже
спортом займатися фізкультурою щоб
зробити так щоб освіта була проходила
весело і те ж саме запитання де Отже
куди запитуєш дітей в Україні вони
кажуть
що важливо для дітей це досвід школі щоб
вони підключені були задіяні щоб їх
підтримували рівні рівно і підтримка від
учителів якщо подивитися на глобальний
досвід є 5
критичних вимірів
ті хто вчаться вчителі і ресурси для
дітей школи і менеджмент системи
управління системи Отже все про це
говорили але це фундаментальні параметри
для реформування системи освіти а в
Україна
прекрасно справляється з цим під
керівництвом
міністра акцена а конкуруючи пріоритети
все це і яким чином зробити це чого ми
навчилися
разом ми наша організація світової банки
і так далі стрес - це велике питання
Коли під стресом вчителі учні то дуже
важко їм поліпшити їх спроможність
вчитися був і запам'ятовувати щоб
запам'ятали цей досвід позитивно і
ці роки в школі це можливості для того
щоб
забезпечив щоб діти були безпеці і
підключені і є прекрасні інструменти як
ти
ти як Ну як ти там
щоб кожна дитина щоб вони питали щоб і
батьки запитували ти як і
всі члени суспільства щоб вони
підключені задіяні підключені до одного
і це прекрасна можливість тому що
ми підключаємо експертів Отже освітня
реформа - це не подорож на один день це
це і нерівність учнів студентів на рівні
батьків на рівні директорів шкіл і
керівників освітніх установ і звичайно
соціальна підтримка
психічне здоров'я дітей забезпечити таку
ситуацію щоб таке середовище було яке
сприяло усім категоріям А як поліпшити
відносини вчителів
зі студентами ковід 2 роки
війна і стрес завжди ми треба тренінг
проводити щоб вони підключалися один до
одного і щоб забезпечити щоб діти
поверталися і третій вимір
це широке комунікація яким чином Ми
продовжуємо комунікувати суспільством
щоб це було пріоритет і
благополуччя так би мовити щоб і не
кінець Україна набагато більш
деталізована ніж багато країн у вас є
цифрові інструменти яким чином ми можемо
використати ці програми інструменти щоб
підтримувати соціальну емоційне освітнє
процес і Отже кожен місяць і кожен
тиждень ми говоримо про трьох соціальну
підтримку підтримка психічного здоров'я
тренінг для вчителів щоб вони були
підключені задіяні з своїми рівними
теорією щоб ми розуміли стресові моменти
і надати їм відповідні інструменти
цифрові щоб вони могли використовувати
кожному класі Дякую за увагу
до пані Марічки до вас як до мами трьох
дітей дітей різного віку Причому коли Ми
спілкувались перед панеллю в розповіли
що траєкторії освітніх дітей після
початку активної фази війни вона
абсолютно різні і от до вас питання і
питання фактично як до рупору до голосу
тих дітей в ваших дітей і всіх дітей які
очікування в учнівства в дітей щодо
освіти після нашої Перемоги якими є
очікування батьківства щодо тих дій які
він вони очікують від держави в тій
ситуації в якій ми зараз знаходимось
Дуже дякую користуючись нагода Я хочу
всіх освітян по-перше подякувати як
споживач послуг хоча за часів пані лілії
було запроваджено таке поняття що батьки
є частиною освітнього процесу А це дуже
цінує але все-таки друзі дуже вам дякую
за те що ви зробили за останні півтора
року за всі ваші подвиги за часів
пандемії у Діти навчаються 7-9 і 11-ий
зараз класи Доті причому за дуже різних
всі обставин Мій син останні два роки
оскільки жодна з моїх жоден з моїх дітей
не потрапив вже під реформу нуш тобто
ніхто не зможе отримати можливість
обирати в старших класах предмети які
більше цікаві або чим більше хоче
займатися то моя дитина останні два роки
навчаються в двох школах в дистанційні
де він фактично просто отримує оцінки і
виконує той необхідний мінімум і в школі
яка немає державної реєстрації на освіту
але принаймні там Він вчиться саме тим
предметам які йому цікаві в своє
задоволення і я ціну його бажання
вчитися в двох школах тому я пам'ятаю що
коли я віддавала останню дитину
наймолодшу свою дитину в школу і це був
останній рік
які не підпадав підреформу нуш я десь
про себе сказала фух Моя дитина буде
вчитися 11 класів але зараз мої діти
мені кажуть Мама ну як так можна вчитися
Не 12 класів як всі діти в Європі і нам
в такому віці вже треба обирати ким
стати і вони самі дуже шкодують що не
мають цієї можливості вчитися 12 років
що для мене величезного відкриття бо
мені здавалося що діти хочуть раніше
закінчити школу а це говорить про те що
їм комфортно в школі і вони хочуть
більше бути під наглядом під
керівництвом саме своїх вчителів останні
півроку і найближчий рік мої діти які в
7-9 класі
навчаються в Празі Я хочу дуже
подякувати міністерству освіти за те що
стався оцей зсув по
зарахуванню оцінок по реінтеграції наших
дітей до української освіти тому що це
навчання на дві школи і бажання бути
все-таки членами і українського
освітнього простору воно дуже забрало
багато сил нервів І у батьків і у дітей
тому що я думаю вчителі вже стикалися з
дітьми які повертаються А це дуже
вмотивовані діти які повертаються додому
це діти які побачили що там І що тут і
які дуже цінують можливість бути вдома Я
думаю що ви дуже рідко зустрінете учні
які сказав О боже я повернувся в Україну
хотів ще там залишитися тому що діти це
мотор взагалі повернення батьків їхніх в
Україну скільки ми знаємо прикладів коли
діти повертаються нібито в Україну на
канікули а стають в таку позу щоб
повертаються вся родина бо діти не
хочуть повертатися в ті школи хочуть
повертатися в наші школи мені дуже
Хочеться вірити що в цьому році я звісно
знаєте Не
державних і не фоторолог і ми не знаємо
як буде розвиватися ситуація але моє
відчуття що літо 24 року це буде
найбільший потік повернення людей додому
люди які вже скажуть і родини з дітьми
які собі вже скажуть хай там ракет вже
летять ми будемо ховатися але ми вже
повертаємось додому і дуже хочеться щоб
школи були готові до повернення і
реінтеграції цих дітей тому що це
приїдуть все одно дуже мотивовані діти
так з освітніми втратами втратами в
контексті Української школи але вони там
точно не байдукували в тих школах вони
розвинули ті якості які вони тут будуть
успішно застосовувати якості
адаптивності до інших шкіл до
суспільства яке не завжди їх охоче
приймає і до суспільства де та сама Так
само втомлюється від нашої війни і від
українців тому велика подяка що зараз
все-таки
опорне те щоб українські предмети були
більш вивчалися А щоб максимально
зараховувалась те що вони вчили там і як
вони тут далі будуть я я хочу щоб кожна
дитина знала що її тут чекають тому що
коли наші діти їхали туди їм там ніхто
не влаштовував там тестування якісь
умови для зарахування і так далі це не
означає що ми знецінюємо нашу освіту і
хочемо знаєте що нам байдуже і ми хочемо
так ах
яка там українська освіта все зарахуйте
беріть ні всі дуже цінують українську
освіту особливо в порівнянні тому що
Знаєте дуже багато
щодо війни щодо тих часів коли ми рідко
виїздили в Європу багатьох наших
громадян Було відчуття що
ми такі як і ми є тому що ми народилися
в Україні а якби ми народилися за
кордоном моє життя сталося б склалося би
інакше в мене було б інше можливості
зараз дуже багато людей які будуть
повертатися і підлітки в Україну дуже
мотивовані розуміють що скільки
можливостей все-таки є вдома що вони все
ідеально там тому моє моє прохання до і
Міністерства щоб і до шкіл що ми готові
були повертати цих дітей Ну як мама
одинадцятикласника в мене особливо
прохання до представників Верховної Ради
пошвидше Та я думаю у освітян таке саме
до вас прохання бо швидше визначити цю
рамку закінчення школи рамку вступної
кампанії щоб ми не знали До чого
готуватися менше витрачали сил і нервів
на те щоб бути гідними випускниками і
гідними абітурієнтами дякую пані Марічка
ви навіть не уявляєте Які великі
дискусії в нас точать Міністерство
комітет щодо якраз тієї рамки Як тих
правил гри як будуть закінчуватися той
навчальний рік який зараз починається Я
думаю що ми ну в вересні ми маємо вийти
вже з рішенням яке будемо виносити до
зали і відповідно комунікувати і мені ще
зрезонували одна ваша думка ми її
усвідомлюємо але коли це особистий
приклад це ну більш важливо що саме
освіта є одним з основних факторів
повернення сюди для мене це теж особиста
історія рік тому минулого літа це було
фактором повернення моєї дитини Моєї
дружини сюди саме освіта
а все інше це там вже дотичне до цього
класно сюжетна історія це сюжетна
історія яка закінчується так само
починалося освіта це нескінченна історія
вона не закінчується але наша панель
добігає кінця і останнє питання Я хотів
би поставити пану адресу з якого Ми
почали нашу дискусію п Андрусів ви
почули нашу рефлексію на ті рецепти які
напрацювали ви з командою які
напрацювали Лілія Михайлівна
що і як ви радите робити в системі
освіти Де є той важіль Ну те плаче
допомоги яке може організація
економічного співробітництва і розвитку
підставити нам якими будуть ваші
рекомендації щодо подальших дій будь
ласка
дякую вам дуже
мене настільки надихнула
те що пан Оксана міністр сказав
І знаєте школа - це ідеальний приклад і
те ж саме це часто так би мовити от люди
в Японії скажімо
там було відстала Територія А зараз
зовсім інше
і звичайно
оср буде партнером у цій подорожі
і звичайно треба вибрати школи які
будуть піонерами інноваторами і це це
досвід усього суспільства ті школи які
хочуть вийти з зони комфорту І вийти на
експеримент треба під'єднатися
об'єднатися з такими же школами в світі
і звичайно це найкращий приклад
співробітництва і щоб і Міністерство щоб
допомогло ресурсного щоб мати і ресурси
і інструменти для такої і це ті моменти
щоб щоб якраз того око
досвід - це 5-7 років і трансформація
треба звичайно терпляче відноситися час
виділити на це як тільки школи успішні
То вони будуть надихати інших у світі
А ваше запитання
звичайно
звичайно були втрати якісь в освітній
програмі
не тільки відбудувати краще ніж було але
будувати з націленим на майбутнє і Отже
яким чином люди вчаться коли вони
вчаться і де вони вчаться і щоб це
настільки важливо і щоб люди
вчителі співпрацювали в колаборації один
з одним і багато українських вчителів
вони прекрасні очі так би мовити
фасилітатори вони це саме це потрібно
для відновлення відбудови
не треба в якомусь так би в якісь
бульбашці тримати
учнів звичайно інновація звичайно Все
змінюється і фасилітатори цьому сприяють
і
звичайно фокус уваги
так було на
вчити меншим напрямкам але більш глибоко
навчати цим напрямком Оце те саме те що
потрібно у цей період війни і
відновлення це надзвичайно важливо і це
надзвичайно важке завдання для
Міністерства і це звичайно як направити
ресурси на потреби як направити на
більші інноваційних
вчителів і у мене повна впевненість
настільки я багато
зустрів багато надихаючих вчителів і
Україна буде прекрасною моделлю для
відновлення стійкості
по-перше я хочу подякувати і організації
економічного співробітництва і розвитку
вашої команди за цей досвід за ту
доповідь яку ви підготували пані лілії
Гриневич за адаптацію того цього досвіду
партнерські організації ткам Україна в
мене Одна думка що
цей процес він двосторонній і я
абсолютно впевнений що не тільки нам є
Чому повчитися в інших країн фактично
Україна зараз вчить весь світ Вона вчить
тому як
битися за свою волю за свою свободу вона
вчить тому як бути стійким при цьому
вона вчить тому що цінності набагато
важливіші ніж меркантильні якісь
міркування вона вже в тому що демократія
це шлях а диктатура - це шлях в нікуди
тому я абсолютно впевнений що не просто
настане вже є той час коли весь світ
вчиться в нас вчиться в українців
вчиться в тому числі і в українській
освіти Я дуже дякую всім учасникам нашої
панелі Я вибачаюсь перед організатором
ми затягнули але з такими експертами Я
думаю що ми могли б ще пару годин точно
спілкуватись і напрацьовувати класні
рішення я дуже Всім дякую і слава
Україні героям слава
то Ми дякуємо вам п Сергію Дякуємо всім
учасникам дискусії Я пропоную насправді
продовжити спілкуватися тільки вже в
таких неформальній обстановці так тому
що час зробити невеличку перерву парі та
панове Я радий вас повідомити що
завершилася перша половина серпневої
однак звісно попереду так давайте щоб я
вам не заважав А але звісно Попереду у
нас ще багато важливих подій дискусії і
зустрічі тут на головній серії і звісно
в наших клубних зонах а-а яке впевнений
звісно сприятимуть тому щоб освітній
сезон 2023-го 24-го років в Україні
відбувся і був максимально ефективним
для дітей учителів і освітніх
управлінців Отже дивимося на годинник в
15:30 ми мусимо знову ж таки
продовжувати роботу звісно Стежте за
оголошеннями так само в 15:30 продовжити
свої роботи і клубні зони і тут у нас на
головній ми будемо говорити Ну принаймні
спробуємо зазирнути в майбутній
Висловити свої думки щодо стратегії
інклюзивної освіти у повоєнній розбудові
України Ця розмова розпочнеться в 15:30
звісно я нагадаю що між головною сценою
і клубними зонами є зона сектор фото
виставки ви там можете долучитися до
акції яка спрямована на збір донатів для
облаштування укриття ліцею номер 55
міста Миколаїв акція відбувається за
ініціативи Міністерства освіти і науки
України та благодійного фонду сейв
підходьте до сектору фотовиставки
дізнавайтеся деталі беріть участь І
звісно вигравайте призи подарунки Які ми
розіграємо тут після церемонії
нагородження Отже ще раз 15:30
орієнтуємося на продовження нашої
зустрічі дякую
ну і звісно керівники Департаменту
департаменті освіти нагадаю Ми
домовлялися на 14:30 Ну трошки сунулося
в часі Але тим не менше зустріч має
відбутися керівники департаменті освіти
чекаємо вас прямо зараз на головній
сцені керівники департаментів освіти
просто зараз прямуйте до головної сцени
[музика]
ще раз і ще раз оголошення для
керівників департаментів освіти чекаємо
вас на головній сцені
[музика]
[оплески]
канал
[музика]
Отже пані нападали зовсім скоро Серпнева
продовжуватиметься о 15:30 заходи
відбуватимуться паралельно як і протягом
майже всього дня на головній сцені та в
тематичних клубних зонах на головній
сцені Ми запросимо вас до розмови щодо
стратегії інклюзивної освіти у повоєнній
розбудові України у тематичних клубних
зонах вашій увазі такі теми зелений
сектор Пілот нуш та його підтримка
жовтий сектор нові освітні програми у
професійній освіті
фіолетовий сектор майстерня штучний
інтелект в освіті рожевий сектор дитина
в екосистемі дошкільної освіти в умовах
війни синій сектор відновлений відбудова
хто для кого навіщо кейси неурядових
організацій і підліткових ініціатив які
змінюють громади
у червоному секторі ми пропонуємо
доросліду тему відповідь освіти на
виклики війни адаптація зміни та нові
можливості від jain Ukrainian
ну і звісно шановні учасники за подіями
серпневої на головній сцені ви та ваші
колеги можуть спостерігати через
трансляцію на YouTube каналі та на
сторінці Міністерства освіти і науки
України у Facebook тому Я запрошую всіх
хто тут у нас фізично
повертатися до продовження серпневої
займайте свої місця в залі дуже-дуже
скоро будемо розпочинати
[музика]
Ну що ж друзі 15:30 хочеться Вже
розпочинати другу частину серпнявою Я
розумію що потрібно ще декілька хвилин
для всіх тому давайте всі декілька
хвилин є але не більше тому Я запрошую
вас займатися в залі Біля головної сцени
або в тематичних клубних зонах буквально
дві-три хвилини і будемо продовжувати ще
раз і ще раз нагадаю що на головній
сцені Ми запросимо вас до розмови
навколо стратегії інклюзивної освіти у
повоєнній розбудові України в клубних
зонах вашій увазі такі теми зелений
сектор Пілот нуш та його підтримка
жовтий сектор нові освітні програми в
професійній освіті фіолетовий сектор
майстерня штучний інтелект в освіті
рожевий сектор дитина в екосистемі
дошкільної освіти в умовах війни синій
сектор відновлення і відбудова хто для
кого навіщо кейси неурядових організацій
і підліткових ініціатив які змінюють
громади в червоному секторі говоримо до
розгляду тему відповідь освіти на
виклики війни адаптація зміни та нові
можливості від gent Ukrainian Ну звісно
ще хочеться нагадати вам що після
завершення дискусійних панелей
орієнтованого 16:45 на головній сцені
відбудеться нагородження нагородження
вчителів вихователів майстрів тому
звісно теж будемо чекати на всіх вас Ну
що бажаємо плідної роботи дві-три
хвилинки і розпочинаємо роботу в усіх
зонах і на головній сцені і в клубних
секціях
[музика]
ну власне на головній сцені серпневої
вже все готово всі готові глядачі і
учасники в залі теж можна поаплодувати
щоб трошки збадьорити одне одного і дати
зрозуміти тим хто дивиться нас онлайн що
наша зустріч триває Серпнева триває І
звісно у цій другій частині ще дуже-дуже
багато важливої і корисної інформації
для всіх отже як ви знаєте ця дискусія е
має тему стратегія інклюзивної освіти у
повоєнному відновленні України власне
про це найближча година модератор панелі
пані Лариса Шевчук парі Ларису вся увага
ваша сцена теж Дякуємо Доброго дня
шановні Учасники конференції серпневої
Доброго дня всіх хто прийшов сюди на
нашу панель Я думаю що ви якраз всі
знаєте що таке інклюзія
точно
Дякую вам щиро тому що ми будемо
говорити саме про те як прийняти
стратегію що вона може дати і яким чином
хочу представити наших спікерів які
сьогодні є Подивіться на ці чудові
обличчя вони всі посміхаються у них все
в порядку шановне пані Євгенія Смірнова
заступниця міністра освіти і науки
України з питань ранньою та дошкільної
освіти і інклюзії
пані Тетяна ломакіна
уповноважена президента України з питань
безбар'єрності
пані Тетяна
Павло верчинський Паша встань ти
молодець
вчитель інформатики
хлопець який пройшов сідай який пройшов
інклюзію з першого класу інклюзивне
навчання А тепер він вчитель інформатики
мама Наталія варчинська
хлопчики який був з особливими освітніми
потребами А тепер він вчитель
інформатики
[оплески]
Микола
Семенюта Микола помаши рукою
випускник інтернатного закладу волонтер
представник Національної Ради дітей та
молоді
є
Ну і Алла грибенюк це директорка
комунальної установи
інклюзивно-ресурсний центр
коростишівської міської ради
[оплески]
Ну що якщо ми всі знаємо що таке
інклюзивне навчання то ми маємо
поговорити все-таки про дуже серйозні
речі тому хочу зразу надати слово пані
Тетяні ломакіній тому що якраз саме Вона
представляє наш великий проєкт який
прийнятий вже стратегію по
безбар'єрності і стратегія інклюзивного
навчання вона прийнята приймається і
буде прийнята в рамках проекту по
безбар'єрності я правильно кажу чи
неправильно слово презентацію
Доброго дня всім учасникам конференції
для мене над висока честь сьогодні серед
освітян на головній події яка для всіх
вас є важливою на початку року говорити
про
інклюзію навчання тому що дійсно це те
що робить нас більш людяними більш
чутливими навчає нас
взаємодіяти Коли ми
можемо зростати змалечку бачити що люди
різні що в них є різні потреби що в них
є різний темп навчання і ми з повагою
ставимось до кожного і кожної
Отже
перша леді України як ви знаєте три роки
тому розпочала велику розмову про
безбар'єрність але сьогодні ті слова які
вона тоді закладала як основу що
безбар'єрність має стати новою
суспільною нормою як ніколи на часі
тому що зручний простір зручні послуги
доступність освіти Чи роботи все це наш
внесок спільну перемогу над всім не
дружнім ворожим тим що обмежує і заважає
нашому життю каже перша леді
національна стратегія має дійсно
важливий напрям освітньої безбар'єрності
він про те що будь-яка людина
якщо вона маленька або доросла якщо її є
потреба навчатись має мати відкрити
доступ до навчання
і
дійсно до цих процесів треба залучати
якомога більше стик холдерів і Я дуже
тішуся з того що коли розроблялася ця
версія ми знаємо що величезний шлях
пройшла ця стратегія їжа більше розробки
процесу розробки цієї стратегії більше 6
років
але на цій в цьому етапі Ми намагалися
аналізувати всі групи зацікавлених осіб
і це не лише вчителі і це не лише ті
люди щодо лучення саме до навчального
процесу тому що дійсно
ними людьми що здобудуть вигоду тобто
стануть кращими буде значно більше тому
тут на цьому слайді ви бачите що це і
органи місцевого самоврядування
і експертне середовище і міжнародні
організації громадські організації і
просто пересічні громадяни крім тих для
нас звичайно учасників процесу які
дійсно до цього долучення тому дуже
приємно розпочати цю дискусію і пишаюся
всім вами і тим що сьогодні ми це
обговорюємо дякую
Дякуємо пані Тетяно і я хочу розпочати
наше обговорення
з слів мами яка має дитину з ооп і
дитина
вона дуже щаслива Мама що дитина
навчається на інклюзивному навчанні але
У неї була така фраза цікава коли ми
проводили дослідження по якості
інклюзивного навчання ми досліджувались
в 21-му році я працюю в проекті search
чудовий проект і я встану тому ця мама
колись сказала на цьому дослідженні я
дослівно прочитаю добре А ви послухаєте
Дякую всіх Хто слухає
вона якась така у нас ця інклюзія просто
рожева кулька красива класна але вона
постійно лопається і її необхідно
постійно заклеювати це були мамині слова
в 21-му році
А хто знає В нас 22-му році прийшла
постанова яка Почала діяти і ми почали
її діяти по-іншому трошки і я думаю що
ця постанова тоже заклеїли кусочок
якоїсь якраз дирочки або шматочку те що
нам потрібно зробити Дякую всім хто цю
Постанову пробив вона класнюча постанова
І тому ми з вами спробуємо дійсно
якось проговорити що нам з вами всім
потрібно зробити щоб Ця кулька не лопала
чи допоможе наша стратегія яку ми будемо
приймати
обговорювати зробити так щоб вона була
завжди гарно і тільки розросталася Ну що
поїхали
будемо говорити і Я дуже прошу щоб не
тільки наше спікери говорили а у нас
Дивіться скільки є зацікавлених людей
які прийшли сюди для того щоб
проговорити
мене і спершу запитаннячко простеньке
чому рівні можливості так важливі в
нашому суспільстві
можемо зробити Бліц дуже коротко і
кожний скаже або хто хоче сказати люди з
залом У вас є рука Ви також можете це
зробити і сказати
якщо ні я буду визивати як в школі я
вчителька
Женя дякуємо
ви знаєте фантастика в нас сьогодні
багато це головна сцена головна
освітянська сцена країни і ми з вами
говоримо про надважливе це про
інклюзивну освіту Ми маємо дати як
країна як громада як будь-який орган що
надає послуги рівні можливості рівний
доступ Ми кожен по-своєму різний і ми
кожен по-своєму інклюзивний в нас має
стати інклюзивне суспільство на кожному
дотиці
починаючи від документів котрі Ми
формуємо створюємо як Міністерство
освіти і науки і саме головне щоб це
було підкріплено найкращими практиками
що вже є і ми маємо їх підсилити і дати
їм прорости і не тільки знаєте там де є
інтузіасти там де є
класні громадські активісти де є
волонтери де є небайдужі директори
інклюзивно-ресурсних центрів фантастичні
мами котрі просто беруть роблять це
кожного дня Ми маємо зробити так щоб у
кожної дитини був доступ до якісної
освіти
Може хтось хоче спікеріше сказати
пані Наталя будь ласка
А я вважаю рівні можливості завжди рівні
і можливість якщо створити всі необхідні
умови для розвитку і навчання дитини
дякую пані Микола пан Я погоджуюсь
словом все сказано я так читаю те що це
ми всі рівні бо деякі беруть людей тіпа
на така особлива Я считаю ще ні бо ми
всі рівні однаковий незалежности можеш
ходити чи ні то не повезати один одного
тому я думка
Павло Мене звати верхівський Павло я як
ніхто інший розумію чому інклюзивна
освіта важлива тому що я з першого класу
навчався в школі 168 в якій є інклюзивні
класи і ця школа дала мені базу Я через
через те що я прийшов саме через
інклюзивну освіту а не через якісь
інтернат наприклад я вивчився на
спеціальність комп'ютерних наук зараз
працює вчителем інформатики інформатики
та всі мої однокласники які навчались зі
мною майже всі вивчилися теж знайшли
роботу тому це дуже важливо
Я теж би хотіла додати ми будуємо
правову демократичну державу і рівні
можливості це про справедливість це
дотримання верховенства права кожна
людина вона цінна сама по собі незалежно
від рівня знань чи стану здоров'я і
власне Кожна людина повинна мати ті
рівні можливості а держава для якої
найважливіша цінність ця людина повинна
створити відповідні умови
пані Тетяна Я думаю що рівні можливості
або
нерівність ми відчуваємо
коли з нами що трапилось ну зазвичай да
Тобто ми травмувалися або Дитина
народилася з порушенням розвитку або
тривала хвороба або мені той
національності або ще якісь певні
риси за завдяки яким ми вдруг відчуваємо
що до нас інше ставлення і нам обмежують
можливості тому мені здається що рівні
можливості це побачити дійсно в кожній
людині людину попередусель людину а
після того всі ці характерні риси і
дійсно якщо ми пам'ятаємо є така
картинка коли три дитини вони через
забор дивляться намагаються дивитися
футбол да і кажуть що там якщо там
дитина маленька їй просто ящик більше
треба дати щоб вона із забору щось
побачила так рівні можливості це щоб
діти не забору дивилися розумієте чого
вони за забором Вони мають бути на
трибунах оце нас має
заставити подумати і Змінити наше
підходи чи в батьків немає грошей щоб
купити квитки Чи маємо якось допомогти
їм зрозуміти правила дети квітки можна
купити чи це взагалі просто діти не
знають правил тому мені здається рівні
можливості це коли ми допомагаємо людям
які зазнають певних обмежень відкрити ті
обмеження і створити умови Дякую Ви
сьогодні я вперше познайомилася з паном
Миколою Він дуже цікава людина
самостійно приїхав сьогодні з Чернівців
на потяги визвав собі таксі приїхав сюди
на нашу конференції і він щасливий з
того що він це може зробити але в
принципі мабуть з дитинства у вас
можливості були інші правда ж у вас не
було розкажіть бо це просто-напросто
дуже цікавий такий знаєте епізод з життя
і повчальний
потрапив інтернат бо мої батьки
відмовились з народження побув Малютка
до 5 років
такі заклад я даже не хоче нікому по
всьому побажати бути в цьому місці де я
був що він був закритого типу і я був на
другому поверху на третьому інклюзивці
там взагалі даже слово не йдеться
взагалі
Я десь до 5 років Як не більше взагалі
даже на вулицю не міг вийти Я такий з
вікна все дивився як все Люди гуляють
діти а я цього не міг не було
непідйомника щоб підніматися І пандуса
взагалі в цьому і коли був інтернаті А
як ви за свої права потім боролися О ще
дуже важко було боротися зірвав я і
взагалі не знав що взагалі я маю якісь
права мені то не розповідав і не навчав
мене в цьому
такому що я закладі був взагалі даже
навчання взагалі немає
Я тільки Дякую одной нянечка яка мене
навчила читати і трошки математику
навчила мене рахувати Бо я взагалі
не вмію хоч і це не її були обов'язки це
вчити Бо в неї зовсім інше були напрямки
роботи
а вже потім пізніше дали Вже вихователя
але вже то вже було пізно бо те що вона
мені здала говорить Я вже зумів писати і
читати
і
там находится діти які читати не міг не
писати які досі знаходиться Я дуже
важкий час просов я коли поїхав в один
Лагер я розповів про своє життя Ну і про
своє життя І тут як в інтернеті
відбувається
Як
відносяться яке харчування і я після
того коли приїхав мене там можна сказати
не знав Видали мене те що я приїхав все
розповів і Мої друзів які я був групі
Вони потім мене теж були їх настроїли що
я такі що я наробив що я все розповів що
відбувається Я їм став почати кажу я
хочу Ну став розповідати Я хочу щось
змінити щоб були кращі умови ставлення
щоб можна було у вас на другий поверх
щоб ні діти які живуть в інтернеті вас
піднімали на другий поверх і з коляскою
є такий діти ну дівчата що їм не дуже
важкі
і можуть діти собі грижі робити Ну
багато всього
і ми були дуже мені було неприятно мені
Дуже хотілось би всіх заховатися нікого
не бачити не чути але не було чим
можливості
щоб бити за територію не міг не мав
права взагалі даже піти собі купити
морозино чи якісь продукти речі я не мав
права даже не 1 копійки я не тримав в
руках мені не давали на руки
вони ви боєць
Я після того вирішив попросив директора
то інтернату щоб подати на суд мене
особисто бо мені поставити такий діагноз
що ти не розумовий що я не маю і не мені
говорили що я взагалі як зможу
пересуватися по місту а вони Даже мені
взагалі не дали попробувати ще я зможу
чи ні А вони вже собі такі хрест
поставили Все я не зможу і я хочу всіх
станції просто вони до речі було дуже в
соці того що вони побачили я ну розум не
знаю все багато і вони мене стали питати
чому у вас такі діагноз коли до мене це
питання
і я вже тоді були перевезли ще в дом
пристарілих це то вже такий заклад але
там є свій трохи був плюс я мог вийти за
територію через пропуск мені дали я мав
собі день співдолузями чи просто десь
прогулятися
знову вигнутися
але ми так життя помінялося нова сім'я
яку я мріяв Це була моя мрія мене правда
і суд і що одночасно йшов і останній суд
коли ми не був Вони приїхали мене просто
ну неймовірно але де я Де не був Україна
моя рідна ну нікуди не хоче їхати
Дякую Дякую
І сьогодні ми виявили з вашою розмови що
у вас немає навіть ніякого документа про
освіту правда А ви хочете навчатися далі
да мати хоч якісь був що я мав яке
зображування що ну мені за сподобається
коли ви потрапив в сім'ю годувати і
батькам я дякую навчили там нарізати і
картоплю в мене там брати дуже люблю
коли блінчики готовлять це їхній такий
любимий делікатес і зараз одна добра
чудова людина за великим сексом не
прийняв до себе на роботу от ми тут на
футболки називається місто добра
якому я працюю і
я їм дитячим батькам які мене вчили і
тепер я Де я зараз працюю мені набагато
легше мені ну не треба вчити я вже тебе
знаю як там нарізати салат помити
продукти Ну багато тусу мені дають то я
і роблю
звичайно хотів щоб якесь невеличке
образование було щоб дуже цікаво було
Бачите як ви гарно всі
слухали похлопали йому
слава Богу
У Павла була інша історія
Да хотів би додати як я можу вже назвати
його своїм другом розповідав як в мене в
школі було він розповідав як у нього і
каже Шкода що мені не повезло Так що я
не навчався в інклюзивній школі але
бачите все одно в нього все вийшло і
буде виходити але хочеться щоб всі діти
мали рівні права як ми про це говоримо
щоб мали рівні можливості на навчання І
потім на життя
достойне я вам дякую
[оплески]
сказати дякую за надане слово
я можу трохи буду десь опонентом але з
розумінням ставлюсь до тих проблем Що
наприклад Микола пройшов дуже приклад
дуже прикро що такий навчальний заклад
може він ще існує але так Ну я на жаль
це питання до контролюючих органів вже я
хочу на своєму прикладі розказати Я
інвалід другої групи позору я навчався з
шести років з дитячого садку в
Харківській спеціальній школі імені
караленка мені зараз 30 років Я 24 роки
в цій школі як як тільки її закінчив в
12-му році в травні місяці я вже в
вересні прийшов туди працювати І працюю
до сих пір вже заступник директора і
мені От ця школа дала дуже багато Я маю
три вищих діти Зараз аспірант і ну дуже
прикро що у вас такий був опыт Ну так
скажемо так
трохи хвилююсь але розумієте
працюють знають цю школу працюючи в ній
треба Ну інклюзія - це гарно але
інклюзія як альтернатива повинна бути
як от в Польщі це зроблено От наші діти
коли евакуйовані були я там теж був в
цій школі бачив як це все працює там
інклюзія як альтернатива тому що
поки що не можна отак от наприклад сліпу
дитину незрячу так глуху або
відстал ну е-е
інтелектуальні порушення не можна отак
посадити просто в просту школу в масову
Чому Тому що перше питання
матеріально-технічна база
Я коли проходив практику в школі з
інклюзивними класами
Так там була одна дівчинка зі слуховими
апаратом і на коляски був хлопчик але
вони бачили нормально Вони чули вони
писали вони встигали це дуже гарно
інклюзія повинна бути в суспільстві в
цілому з цього повинно починатися все і
я про те що навіть матеріально-технічна
база У нас в школі один лише
брайлівський принтер один і той діти на
благодійному концерті наш хор який є
народним хором Міністерства освіти і
науки України він заробляв на цей
принтер розумієте тобто
матеріально-технічна база не проти
інклюзії но от таких от звір Мені дуже
прикро що з вами так от обходились Ну от
різні є
ситуації різні є
точки зору
Дякуємо пане заступник директора так і
зрозуміла дуже приємно Доброго дня всім
Мене звати Ірина дулякова як керівниця
координаційного центру з розвитку
сімейного виховання та догляду дітей я
надзвичайно вдячна за те що сьогодні
піднімається питання стратегії
інклюзивної освіти Тому що це є частиною
тієї реформи яка дозволить реально
забезпечити кращих доглядів і ми маємо
тут розуміти що має зараз в Україні
місце різна освіта і спеціалізована і
інклюзивна Але якщо ми говоримо про
стратегію то це про наше бажання і
напрямок руху і про конкретні кроки які
дозволять інтегрувати кожну дитину в
освітній процес і надати їм можливість
мати
рівні права в навчанні і доступ до цього
навчання і тут говорячи на серпневій
конференції перед початком навчального
року напевно дуже важливо
загострити нашу увагу на тому А що
конкретно В кожній школі є сьогодні для
того щоб діти різні діти мали можливість
навчатися саме у нас чи є у нас
глобальні виклики з інфраструктурою
можливо напевно найбільший виклик це з
підготовкою вчителів нам треба більше
уваги приділяти підготовки вчителів
навчання їх розвитку і можливості
фізичні навіть та ментальні
постійно працювати з різними потребами
дітей освітніми потребами тому що вони
тільки стають глибші їх стає більше і
педагогам стає складніше Якщо говорити
про стратегію інклюзивної освіти до якої
ми маємо рухатися то вона має мати
відкрити доступ до того щоб у будь-якій
школі дитина мала можливість навчатися
дякую Дуже дякую вам пані Алла хоче
сказати А я прошу запустити презентацію
а зараз мені потрібно буде дуже дякую Я
хочу додати
Наступне Що коли ми говоримо про
інклюзивність суспільства і взагалі про
інклюзію Ми не говоримо про закриття
якихось закладів ми говоримо про право
вільного вибору яке гарантується законом
про освіту на форму навчання на тип
закладу і все це бажання батьків
регулюється бажанням батьків і власне
стратегія розвитку інклюзивного розвитку
інклюзивного навчання покликана ось ці
прибрати із щоденного життя бар'єри які
заважають батькам робити свідомий вибір
і забезпечити власне враховуючи ідеальні
можливості і територіальні можливості і
забезпечувати навчання своєї дитини як
найкращим чином
я вам дякую
Я зараз ввімкнула Подивіться будь ласка
невеличкі якраз нашу презентацію про
Національну стратегію розвитку
інклюзивного навчання на 23-30 років і
хочу якраз під наш обговорення під час
обговорення просто запускати пару
слайдів А ви бачите всі qr-код бачите
можете його відкрити і самостійно
подивитися собі так само
мета ви знаєте національної стратегії Ви
вже сказали що вона має зробити
для всіх можливості однакові мають бути
як для Миколи так і для Павла і для всіх
інших дітей які у нас ідуть в закладу
освіти а мама старту мають вибрати туди
куди вони хочуть віддати свою дитину
ніхто не має права їм сказати що ви
йдете сюди або йдете туди якщо ви хочете
займатися загальноосвітньою програмою ви
обираєте заклад загальноосвітній Якщо ви
хочете займатися за програмою
спеціальною ви обираєте іншу програму
спеціальну програму і у нас в Україні є
такі заклади
основні етапи і ми маємо проговорити з
вами якраз про Ці основні етапи та шляхи
їх реалізації для того щоб ну зрозуміти
що нам потрібно робити Куди йде наша
стратегія ми маємо створити ці умови і
подивіться у нас є певні етапи Я не
читаю Ви самі почитали всього їх два
Ви побачили
і перший надважливий етап наш він
складний але він потрібний
це 23 28 роки і тут у нас є кроки от
Подивіться будь ласка
я все тримаю свою кульку вона інколи
лопається Але у нас подивіться в кроку
першому удосконалення
нормативно-правової бази в сфері
інклюзивного навчання та спеціальної
освіти Ви побачили всі
чи важливий цей етап Як ви думаєте і цей
крок
Шановні колеги звичайно Да я думаю що я
зараз маю практику дуже багато спілкуюся
з директорами з усієї України ми
проводимо з ними різні заняття і ви
знаєте Виявляється що шановні директори
Вони читають закон так виконуючого так а
насправді воно може бути по-іншому і оці
От такі знаєте недомовки або нерозуміння
воно приводить до того що є дуже багато
Чесно кажучи порушень порушень і сторони
того що дітей порушують і так дальше
тому я думаю що це як ви вважаєте крокси
важливий нам
потрібно починати з цього спікери
спікери Кажуть жаба немашої головою А ви
Кажіть да або ні
дякую
дивіться крок другий у нас пішов це
система впровадження системи раннього
втручання
давайте голосувати Ну за те що цей
потрібний крок
а тут була руку піднімаю А ви Ні а всім
іншим не важливо
дійсно так вона є дивіться цікавий крок
Крок 3
удосконалення системи моніторингу
розвитку інклюзивного навчання хто у нас
моніторить
кому це відведено це право Хто це може
робити
чи важливий цей крок Як ви думаєте
важливий
чи есть у нас западання в цьому
хто у нас це перевіряє
поки що державна служба якості освіти
трошки перевіряє але зараз немає аудитів
і багато що ми не бачимо
і подивіться четвертий крок про який
говорив пан заступник
спеціального закладу забезпечення
закладів освіти необхідними додатковими
фінансами
людськими матеріальними ресурсами на
рівні громад відповідно до власних
повноважень органів місцевого
самоврядування
ті хто читав положення яке прийняло і
прийшло у нас і поступило в силу 22-го
року там чітко про це написано хто за що
відповідає
і там дуже багато покладено на
засновників але якось так відбувається
що у нас засновники закривають очі і не
хочуть цього робити
тому що Шановні колеги це такі як ви
думаєте нам інклюзія потрібна дає вона
можливість для розвитку кожної людини а
хто може сказати якісь приклади свого
життя або свого досвіду як воно
відбувається
дозволите я практик я все життя
працювала в школі
малокомплектній де семи сіл з
навколишніх добиралися пішки діти Я
працювала директором школи спеціальної
школи-інтернату для дітей з вадами
розового розвитку зараз я зробила свій
вибір на роботу в інклюзивно-ресурсний
центр і дуже рада з того що я починала з
нуля з самого початку відкриття
інклюзивно-ресурсного центру і я можу
сказати що дійсно інклюзивне навчання зі
зміною надзвичайно важливі для усього
суспільства
відслідковую те що з певним періодом
часу
громадськість дивується так з'явилося
багато дітей з особливостями насправді
дні вони були вони були але вони були
вдома
не спеціальних закладах на педагогічному
патронажі і вони були обмежені у
спілкуванні своїми однолітками на
сьогодні
спілкування цих дітей
звичайних класах в інклюзивних класах ви
знаєте діти найлегше сприймають одне
одного все це йде від дорослих я прийшла
не з порожніми руками я звикла говорити
прикладами і якимись реальними речами я
маю в книжку нашого місцевого автора
Богдан голова це псевдонім хлопчика
Богдан Грабар Він має важку форму ДЦП
він сам не ходить Він не розмовляє руки
його не слухаються але він має
надзвичайно ясний розум Він пише
пречудові вірші і тут багато віршів про
самотність проте як би він хотів разом з
усіма
гратися бігати але його обмеження не
дають можливості це робити І власне ви
знаєте як він набирав свої перші вірші
олівцем пришитим до кепки
спробуйте як це а зараз він набирає на
смартфоні і вже набрав на дві книги йому
хотілося в звичайних людських радостей і
для цього потрібно була мінімальна
підтримка просто мінімальна він знайшов
цю підтримку в нашому ресурсному центрі
ми видали дві книги яка розійшлася по
світу і його читачами і добрими друзями
є головнокомандуючий
залужний Валерій Федорович який відвідав
перед війною і слідкує за нашими
успіхами і представники юнісег були
хлопця вдома без належного і організації
цієї підтримки чи було б це можливо
напевно ні тому я ще раз повертаюся до
того що кожна людина повинна мати
можливість на розвиток на досягнення А
ми маємо в цьому допомагати і робити цей
світ толерантнішим добрішим і сприймати
його різноманітним немає бути
дискримінації за будь-якою ознакою чи то
зайва вага чи недостатньо тієї ваги Чи
це стан здоров'я Я вважаю що кожна
людина просто прекрасна і в кожній
потрібно побачити це дякую
А я б дуже хотіла все-таки послухати ще
пані Наталю маму Паші і вчительку
вчителька яка працює в цій школі там де
вчився Павло А скажіть мені будь ласка
Чи змінилося щось з того в школі яку ви
Паша був в першому класі і мабуть зараз
Так я вдячна долі що нас вона звела з
такими небайдужими людьми які працюють
там відкрили Як то кажуть нам достойно
дорогу у світле майбутнє і що маємо ми
пишаємося зараз пишаюся своїм сином
нашими випускниками і сьогодні почула
про автора у нас також є такий хлопчик
навіть мама не вірила в його успіх
казала мені про що ти говориш дитина не
може навіть ручку тримати у руці а
сьогодні це письменник відомий який
власноруч пише свої вірші Скажіть
прізвище Ігор диба а псевдонім псевдонім
козак Ігор козак Ігор козак так дуже
гарні вірші класу
таких прикладів можна навести дуже-дуже
багато тому пишаюся нашими дітьми і хочу
сказати такі слова що треба робити добро
слухати відчувати серцем кажуть зроби
добро людині воно тобі сторицею
віддасться бо це єдина і неспроможна
путь до свого й до чужого щастя тому як
мама як вчитель закликає робити творити
добро
кожній людині яка має право на освіту
і робімо його
Наталія А що змінилося в закладі освіти
Коли ви прийшли у вас ліфт був так а в
закладі освіти можна також дуже багато
чого казати чим під'їхати шукаємо
автобус спонсорів людей небайдужих
Як дібратися другий-третій поверх також
просимо шукаємо Сьогодні у нас є ліфт
Дякую чи спонсорам у нас є шкільний
автобус у нас є пандус пандуси вбиральні
спеціальні тобто що було і що стало
Дякуємо низький уклін усім хто допомагав
і чув нас додам ще по всій школі також є
поручні по яких діти можуть в будь-яку
точку школи потрапити тобто для них там
бар'єрів немає Взагалі вони можуть куди
хочуть тоді туди можуть потрапити Я вам
дякую пані Тетяна я хотіла підтримати
маму вона зробила акцент на тому що дуже
багато залежить від нашого ставлення я
постійно подорожую регіонами обговорюю
як запроваджуються ті чи інші підходи з
безбар'єрності і чую різні історії є
школа в якому дитина з порушенням зору
Майже без зору не відчуває себе
впевненою тому що на неї вчителі не
звертали увагу а в іншій школі це
сільська школа заради дівчинки всі
селяни перебудовували власну ручну школу
щоб дитина з першого класу могла
відвідувати школу відчувати себе на
рівних і дві школи відрізняються лише
тим що це про різне відношення тому
дійсно ми маємо стати трошки добрішими
можна і Микола хоче будь ласка Хочу
додати ще коли я тут забув в цьому
будинку то що мене в сім'ї то не було то
що і так само і освіти і ми не були такі
думки мислі ти сюди в один стенках так в
тебе час приходить Ну ти майже ну що
телевізор дивився там пообідав поснідав
Ось так день і так роки йшли яким на
жаль не навчає немає і в мене взагалі
були такі думки що хотіли покінчити своє
життя взагалі то що не мав батьків і не
світить і даже не вчили тебе картошку як
нарізатися взагалі
це було але дякую друзів які мене
підтримували сказали що ти не здавайся і
мабуть воно мені зараз помогло якби не
вони і не дуже волонтери Можливо в мене
зараз тут біля з вами не було би
Кожна дитина має право на сім'ю звичайно
саме головне
так і ви його сім'ю знайшли аж 23
роки і потім дає такі що він судився
відсудив той діагноз який йому поставили
сам молодець і це можна робити так і
зараз мені не вірно що я це могу і я
тепер деякі документи я все сам іду
рішаю без батьків без яких допомоги Я
хочу їм дуже вдячні що вони моє життя
змінили вони неймовірно щоб взяти 23
роки я скажу чесно я не одну людину чи
не бачив таку доросла дитину взяли для
себе в сім'ю і я їм дуже вдячний і дуже
великі плін Якби я міг стати на ноги я
так і зробив би
А можете
нути ще будь ласка
може хтось щось хоче сказати от йому
просто кортить сказати щось чи не хоче
ніхто
тоді Скажіть мені будь ласка яке б
запитання ви хотіли задати спікерам
Шановні слухачі щоб вас цікавило
дивіться У нас дуже різні люди у нас
заступник Міністра повноважений
президент
Ну і ми звичайні люди
не хочете есть Будь ласка я мікрофончик
вам дам
Ніби не буде чути
мабуть варто погодитися з тим що ми не
маємо права
як освітяни не створити рівних умов для
кожного Хто цього прагне і в систему
інклюзивної освіти має входити як
загально середня освіта так і ті
спеціалізовані заклади з якими ми на
жаль заклади загальної середньої освіти
впоратися Не можемо
тут мова йде мабуть тільки про
інтелектуальні дитячі втрати а з усіма
рештами вадами Я думаю із підтримкою
фінансової в першу чергу Міністерства Я
маю на увазі
засоби і пристрої які потрібні Таким
дітям Я думаю що наша освітянська
спільнота впорається тому ми разом
готові будувати той інклюзивний простір
з підтримкою Дякую Ви пан директор
Житомирщина Павло
хтось хоче ще сказати щось на мікрофон
вільний церковний хоче нічого сказати
зараз все потрібно Дозвольте одну
невеличку ремарочку будь ласка коли ми
говоримо про інклюзивне навчання Ми не
говоримо про вади ми говоримо про
можливості і актуальний рівень розвитку
даної дитини і її можливості розвивати
ось найближчий крок актуальна зона
розвитку і тоді дитина буде успішна Якщо
ми візьмемо це за основу то світ справді
буде добрішим потрібно починати кожному
з себе
я вам дякую
Подивіться будь ласка слідуючі у нас
крок номер шість забезпечення
доступності і інфраструктури у громадах
у вас громадах у всіх доступність повна
вже
а хтось даже посміхається
недоступна
намагаються робити Це дуже добре
потрібний цей крок нам
не тільки в закладі освіти Ми вже
освітяни знаємо що це обов'язкова
доступність повністю до всіх поверхів
закладу освіти має бути забезпечена і
забезпечена інклюзивно-освітнє
середовище ми це уже знаємо ми це
намагаємося робити але якщо в громаді не
буде Цього зроблений інфраструктури то
Мабуть вони не будуть даже знати що
потрібно зробити і в закладі освіти
безбар'єрність
приймаємо крок
супер крок номер шість
запровадити ефективні системи
міжвідомчої взаємодії та координації з
різними різними органами Чи потрібно нам
міжвідомча отака співпраця колеги
пані Піднімає руку ще дуже потрібно і
каже дійсно що потрібно Ми маємо всі
спільно спілкуватися крок номер 7
проведення національної інформаційної
компанії Із залученням українських
недержавних і міжнародних організацій
нам потрібна така компанія А навіщо
кажіть ви всі знаєте що таке інклюзія
А всі в суспільстві розуміють і знають
що таке інклюзія Я коли перше ми почали
інклюзивне навчання то дехто казав All
inclusive Ну от те Вони знають багато
людей а інклюзія що таке не всі знали чи
потрібно нам доносити що це потрібно і
дуже важливо
мати головами Значить ми приймаємо ми
молодці
слідуючий крок дивіться
розроблення та впровадження програми
підвищення рівень кваліфікації
педагогічних працівників
та задоволення освітніх потреб кожного
здобувача освіти
пане Директор сказав що вони справляться
з багатьом чому але їм вам треба
підтримка щоб вас навчили або Щоб
знайшли ви певні кадри які вам потрібні
для того щоб дітей могли проводити
корупційно-розвиткові заняття і тут у
нас тоже дуже багато таких знаєте
проблем де можна взяти кадровий
потенціал а можна запозичити он слідуючи
дивіться крок у спеціальні освіти у них
є люди які знають багато чого он пан
заступник директора спеціальної школи у
нього три освіти він молодець він все
знає такі кадри нам дуже потрібні на
інклюзивному навчанні приймаємо крок
11 забезпечення якісною оцінки потреб
здоровачів освіти у додаткових сервісах
та послугах
Якби хтось провів якісь певні
дослідження мабуть щоб пан миколін
потрібно раз два три чотири п'ять Отакі
потреби а не закрити в якомусь
приміщенні і нікуди не випускати і не
навчати Ну то злочин проти таких гарних
хлопців і таких добрих людей
тому от у мене запитання якщо ми
виконаємо отой наш план до 28-го року
дивіться з 29 по 30 це другий уже етап
чи піде у нас інклюзія туди куди
потрібно і не лопати буде наш шарик
мама дійсно сказала цікаві слова вона
сприймає інклюзивне навчання вона казала
це воно суперове воно класне що я дитину
не віддаю в інтернат вона в мене вранці
я її цілую відправляю в заклад освіти
Він отримує послуги але бувають різні
моменти і у ці моменти нам треба якось
закрити
Скажіть будь ласка ви щось хочете
донести добавити в стратегію нашу
Так дякую Я зараз мікрофончик вам дам
Я звичайний вчитель Київської школи і
хотіла б додати Я працювала з
інклюзивними дітьми взагалі починала
свою роботу Як асистент вчителя наразі
закінчила випустила свій перший клас
четвертий в якому була дітки інклюзивні
і розумію що є ще один момент який з
якимось стикаємось як з проблемою Якраз
це дотично до того що ви говорили про те
з приводу того що не Всі розуміють
значення слова інклюзивна освіта і я
вважаю що варто додати такий крок як
популяризація цього напрямку для того
щоб
пояснення навіть цього нам прямокут для
широких мас населення адже
коли людина вирішує народжувати дитину
вона не завжди
читає спеціальну літературу не завжди
розуміється на вихо цього ніхто не
перевіряє коли віддає дитину в
роддомі тому Інколи ми стикаємося на
практиці з такою проблемою що дитина
потребує допомоги ми це як вчителі
бачимо ми бачимо що їй потрібно було б
час на за Асистентом в інклюзивній
кімнаті потрібно було б звернутися до
інклюзивно-ресурсного центра а і
виникає така проблема що ти намагаєшся
співпрацювати з батьками розповідати
батькам показувати на те що от в цім
цьому моменті дитині потрібно більше
допомоги більше уваги допомога асистента
вчителя рекомендуємо звернутися до
інклюзивно-ресурсного центру але
батьки сприймають це як якесь покарання
як
не хочуть визнавати те що дитині
потрібно допомога і на жаль зараз
інклюзивна освіта серед широких мас
населення які недотичні до сфери освіти
сприймається як
як недолік не як намагання допомогти зі
сторони педагогічного персоналу зі
сторони держави зі сторони ресурсних
центрів а саме як
намагання показати що дитина якась не
така що моя із батьки це не хочуть
сприймати тому я вважаю що важливо ще
розповідати про те на широкі маси
населення на те про те що інклюзивна
освіта це допомога Дякую ми відчули вашу
думку дякую
А тобі було б дуже приємно якби тебе
називали інклюзивною дитиною
я вам дякую правда ж не дуже Ти такий
самий як всі і я така сама але ходжу в
окулярах отут десь висять окуляри хтось
іще по-іншому Щось я не хочу щоб вони
мені вішали ярлик
якщо у мене є якісь проблеми я хочу їх
сам вирішити або сама вирішити Я хочу
щоб я могла якщо потрібно наприклад на
візку проїхати спокійнонько собі і ніхто
мені не надавав допомогу для цього є наш
проект
пані Тетяна хоче сказати
дивіться те що ви сказали має рацію тому
що сьогодні система раннього втручання
тобто виявлення і роботи з батьками щоб
вони зрозуміли свою дитину краще щоб
вони навчали її розуміючи її
можливі порушення розвитку змалечку щоб
новина того що їм потрібно буде
відвідати інклюзивно-ресурсний центр їх
так не шокувала тому ми бачили цей крок
Дуже дякуємо
саме впровадження раннього втручання
коли в громадах буде створені спеціальні
умови за яких зразу батьків підхоплюють
і це дійсно навчання батьків розуміти
потреби дитини гратися з дитиною
відвідувати дитячий майданчики і все-все
робити розуміючи її потреби
я вам дякую попросили мікрофончик Да
будь ласка
пані Тетяни Я Ольга Будна градник
уповноваженим президента з питань фонду
президента і не підтвердження того що
попередня колега говорила хотіла би
додати що насправді Це також питання
зміни культури і нашого розуміння того
чим займаються інклюзивно-ресурсні
центри тому що коли ми говоримо про
особливі освітні потреби мова йде не
тільки насправді про дітей з
інвалідністю чи там тих хто має такі
потреби тому що особливі освітні потреби
є у кожної дитини і загальне сприйняття
цієї історії теж має змінюватись в нашій
культурі і в нашій історії це не має
бути так що це ніби стигма і це означає
що там дитину тепер ми будемо якось
супер особливо навчати тому що кожна
дитина індивідуальна Да і має свої якісь
окремі особливі потреби це перший момент
а другий момент саму культуру і
взаємодію має бути покладений оцей
принцип взаємної поваги да тому що
насправді Коли ми можемо ми знаємо
розуміти як давайте відверто нас
суспільство не завжди розуміє як нам
правильно спілкуватись один з одним та
якби і в тому числі коли ми поруч бачимо
людей з інвалідністю зараз їх буде
ставати все більше і в тій чи іншій мірі
ми будемо спостерігати різного роду
якби поведінку яка буде для нас
здаватися нетиповою і нам потрібно
розуміти що з цим робити тому це питання
культури воно би взагалі мало перейти
навіть в інший дискурс з точки зору того
що в систему освіти сукупно мають бути
загалом імплементовані в першу чергу
взаємодія комунікація підтримка і
незалежно від того хто поруч татом
сидить в якому вигляді Тому це насправді
історія яку пріоритезує президента і
тому пані Тетяна цим окремо займається
так якби це ми точно Йдемо до того щоби
у нас ставало в країні менше інтернатів
і Ну не те що ви меньше щоб вони в
принципі зникали щоб вона здіти вихову
вались в родинах і це означає що система
освіти має перейняти плавно цю історію
на себе з тим щоби дати можливість всім
бути там в тих закладах де це може бути
забезпечено дякую дякую
я ще хотіла додати що у спілкуванні з
батьками необхідно змінити трішки Вектор
цього спілкування спрямовувати до
фахівців не для того щоб встановити що
не так чому дитина не може а що ще може
зробити держава щоб забезпечити потребу
дитини щоб вона могла реалізовувати свій
особистий потенціал у неї може бути свої
очікування результати свій темп Але це
буде її темп і її величезне досягнення
для когось велика досягнення - це
виграти олімпіаду зайняти на
всеукраїнському етапі перше місце а для
когось прочитати слово мама І це буде ще
більший результат ніж та Олімпіада
Повірте я працюю з дітьми я знаю про що
я кажу тому спрямовуйте батьків на
допомогу а не на порушення на
невиявлення недоліків
так що нам потрібно прийняти стратегію
то давайте вже приймати її це дуже
важливо пані Женя бережіть цю кульку щоб
вона не лопала Я вас дуже прошу
це наша інклюзія коротко додам щоб Ця
кулька не просто не лопнула щоб вона
просто ставала великою великою і більше
могли піднятися ми всі
потрібна
закінчуєте панель подарунками якщо
дозволите я б хотіла б Нашим героям
сьогодні подарувати
книги Богдана голови Як ось цю таку
причетність до Великих змін у нашій
державі Мені здається інклюзивне
навчання це одне з найкращого що сталося
з освітою за останні роки Дякую всім
присутнім хто був сьогодні тут у нас на
нашій панелі Дякуємо спікерам дуже
величезна подяка Хто хоче
фотографуватися Ідіть сюди
Дякую всім кожному дякую дякую всім
ми хочемо з вами сфотографуватися Хто
хоче сфотографувати Запрошуємо Дякуємо
вам надзвичайно важлива дискусія важлива
розмова і дійсно забезпечення рівних
можливостей здобутті освіти для всіх
українців Це звісно завдання надзвичайно
складне але водночас настільки ж і
важливо особливо в контексті
забезпечення високих стандартів життя Ну
що ж Парі на панове ми потроху
завершуємо таку робочу частину серпневої
але ж Буквально за декілька хвилин тут
на головній сфері відбудеться дуже
важливо дуже красива подія - це
нагородження тому Ну так давайте ж
будемо відверті хто має отримати
нагороди знають про це тому якщо ви не
тут Зараз не Біля головної сцени
підтягуйтесь сюди буквально 2-3 Ну може
чотири хвилини і розпочнемо церемонію
нагородження і не тільки церемонія
нагородження ще й розіграшу подарунків
ви пам'ятаєте протягом всього дня я вам
казав що за донат на
будівництво укриття школи номер п'ять
ліцею номер 55 у Миколаєві Так ви можете
отримати нагороди і от одразу після
нагородження три У нас є класних
подарунків які ми обов'язково розіграємо
Отже пані та панове давайте декілька
хвилин і церемонія нагородження
[музика]
ще раз і ще раз парі давай якщо ви є
учасником або учасницею церемонії
нагородження Ми вас чекаємо Біля
головної сцени
[музика]
парі та панове дорогі друзі з хвилини на
хвилину на головній сцені розпочнеться
церемонія нагородження тому усі учасники
та учасниці нагородження будь ласка
прямуйте до головної сцени Ну і всі хто
хоче підтримати своїх друзів колег теж
чекаємо на вас буквально декілька хвилин
до початку
[музика]
дорогі друзі пані до панове Ще раз ще
раз хочу нагадати що Буквально за
хвилину на головній сцені розпочнеться
церемонія нагородження учасники та
учасниці запрошуються до головної сцени
і всіх хто хоче підтримати своїх колег
так само прямуйте до нас одна хвилина і
розпочинаємо цереморію нагородження
[музика]
[оплески]
дорогі друзі Ще раз ще раз вітаю всіх
вас і надзвичайно приємно що вже так
наприкінці можна сказати сьогоднішньої
зустрічі нас досі так багато Оплески вам
Оплески вам дякуємо дякуємо насправді
можна сказати так непомітно промайнув
цей день день серпневої Але найголовніше
що я сподіваюся він дійсно був багатим і
на події на цікаві свіжі думки а
найголовніше що
інформація і ідеї які ми сьогодні тут
почули якими поділилися так вони які
були презентовані впродовж традиційної
конференції для освітян допоможуть
зробити освітній сезон 23 24
продуктивним корисним для дітей так а
головне безпечним та ефективним Дякуємо
кожному і кожній з вас
Ну а ми розпочинаємо цереморію
нагородження вчителів вихователів та
майстрів рада запрошую на цю сцену
нагороджених нагрудним знаком
Міністерства освіти і науки України
Василь Сухомлинський звісно під ваші
Оплески
Оксано Коваленко вчителя математики та
інформатики Чернігівської
загальноосвітньої школи i-ii ступенів
номер три Чернігівської міської ради
Чернігівської області Оксана Коваленко
парі Оксана якщо ви десь тут поруч
чекаємо на вас
Ну будемо сподіватися що пані Оксана чує
нас і стрімголов до нас прямує
Ігора козаченка директор комунального
закладу освіти Криворізький ліцей колія
Дніпропетровської обласної ради
Ігор Козаченко якщо ви десь разом з нами
то звісно чекаємо а це ви за нього так
займе нікому не скажу так тоді ми досі
читаємо чекаємо пані Оксану Коваленко і
Романа сасяка вчителя фізики та
інформатики Дрогобицького ліцею
Дрогобицької міської ради Львівської
області
ну і звісно запрошую вручити нагороди
міністра освіти і науки України пана
Оксана лісового
раз раз
шановні друзі Шановні колеги для мене
надзвичайно велика честь вручати ці
нагороди Я знаю скільки праці вкладено в
цей нагрудний знак який довгий шлях
пройдений і скільки з під ваших рук з
під вашою опіки вийшло прекрасних людей
тому я дякую вам і бажаю щоб все
зроблено вами повернулось вам
стократному обсязі моральними
матеріальними благами І саме головне
отим відчуттям свого визначного
унікального вкладу в розвиток нашої
країни дякую вам
[оплески]
пані Оксана
Давайте будемо підтримувати оплесками
дякую
[оплески]
[музика]
я вас запрошую стати поруч давайте всі
разом ще раз сфотографуємось до нових
фотографи вас момент звісно все це під
оплески
[оплески]
Дякуємо вам надзвичайно і ще раз і ще
раз вітаємо пане Оксана далеко не йдіть
наша Теребовля нагородження
продовжується і представляємо
нагороджених нагрудним знаком
Міністерства освіти і науки України
відмінник освіти
Михайло Бігун вчитель хімії комунального
закладу Жмеринський ліцей номер чотири
жмеринської міської ради запрошуємо на
себе
[оплески]
Анастасія Демидова вчителька біології
війтівського опорного закладу
бершадської міської ради
От написали Анастасії демидров от
давайте це було Все правильно так
Ольга Данько вчителька математики
комунального закладу кегичівський ліцей
кегичівської селищної ради
[музика]
Надія Конончук директорка нетішинської
гімназії Ерудит нетішинської міської
ради Шепетівського району Хмельницької
області
Сергій Осипенко директор державного
навчального закладу дніпрорудненський
професійний ліцей
[музика]
Володимир чеботарьов вчитель фізичної
культури та предмету захисту вітчизни
Миколаївської загальноосвітньої школи
i-ii ступенів номер 39 Миколаївської
міської ради Миколаївської області
[оплески]
Ще чекаємо всі хто має отримати нагороди
але в принципі ми можемо починати вже
нагородження так
насправді ця конференція вона була не
для того щоб
певною мірою тільки для того щоб почути
спікерів вона була для того щоб попити
кави там всім разом щоб зустрітися очима
щоб поспілкуватися це важливо і Я
переконаний що люди до сих пір десь
спілкуються в кулуарах десь там де Їм
цікаво Бо насправді в цьому є ключова
цінність і в цьому і був задом брати на
себе ці ризики бо ви знаєте прошу вас ви
знаєте Ну коли ми приймали рішення до
останнього моменту у нас спочатку одна
трагедія трапилась в Чернігові біда
потім в Сумах біда трапилась і ми
збираємо 700 людей в центрі Києва
були сумніви і ми дуже ризикували але ми
дуже хотіли зустрітися з вами вживу і ми
дуже хотіли більше того щоб ви
зустрілись між собою вживу ради цього і
все це затівалось Ну а заодно і про
початок навчального року поговорили так
добре Шановні колеги дякую вам і
Дозвольте вручити вам ваші заслужені
нагороди
[оплески]
[музика]
оплесками вітаємо наших відмінників
освіти
Ну і вже традиційно в цьому моменті
звісно Запрошуємо До колективного фото
давайте всі наперед звісно Ми
продовжуємо не втомлюємося аплодувати
[оплески]
[музика]
Дякуємо надзвичайно і ще раз Щиро
вітаємо
[музика]
[оплески]
ще нагороди Міністерство освіти і науки
України
подяка корінці Євгенію сергійовичу
фахівцю-консультанту вчителю
реабілітологу комунальне установи
інклюзивно-ресурсний центр черняхівської
селищної ради запрошуємо на сцену
[музика]
а також подякувати
Євпак Василь Ярославович вчитель
фізичного виховання Черняхівського ліцею
№2 черняхівської селищної ради
[оплески]
[музика]
Дякуємо вам надзвичайно
ми організовували дійсно для того щоб
побудувати таким чином щоб обговорити її
проблеми так надати корисну інформацію
для нового освітнього сезону однак і
попити кави сам собою так однак для нас
важливим було ще надати імпульс так би
мовити заряд правильної енергії
надихнути освітян невпинно рухатися саме
самими надихати своїх підопічних і
спеціально до серпневої ми започаткували
відзнаку міць української освіти і ми
представляємо вам пані та панове перших
володарів
ціх цих відзнак Світлана Попова
вчителька Бородянського ліцею номер один
Бородянської селищної ради Київська
область
під час окупації її будинок російські
військові обстріляли з танка і він
згорів зараз подружжя мешкає в
підсобному приміщенні поруч зі згарищем
що залишилося від їхнього житла школу
російські військові використовували як
штаб зараз навчання там дистанційне тому
пані Світлана у себе вдома у дворі
прилаштувала дошку і звідти проводить
онлайн уроки математики і парі Світлана
каже що не вважає себе героїнею а ми
вважаємо А уроки буде проводити так до
самих холодів Світлана Попова
міць української освіти
[оплески]
[музика]
будь ласка залишайтеся з нами
залишайтеся з нами
[музика]
Ольга летенко нагороджується вчителька
лиманської загальноосвітньої школи i-ii
ступенів номер п'ять лиманської міської
ради Донецької області
єдина вчителька в навчальному пункті
облаштованому в розбитій школі один із в
цілих кабінетів лиманської школи
облаштований для навчання одразу кількох
поколінь дітей від другогокласників до
випускників дві буржуйки супутникова
система starlink та електрогенератор
роблять маленьку кімнату затишнішою для
дітей за їхні власні оселі перші парти
займають учні других-п'ятих класів з
ними по черзі працює вчителька Тут
одночасно вивчають математику українську
біологію за останніми партами
розмістилися старшокласники ці
займаються самостійно вдягнувши
навушники та підключившись до онлайну
уроків але навіть на цей маленький клас
гаджетів не вистачає тож кожного ранку
вчителька віддає дітям свої ноутбук і
смартфо закон жінка не змогла виїхати з
міста тому що її літні родичі перебували
потребували догляду навчальний пункт
куди вона вийшла на роботу в листопаді
2022 року після звільнення міста став її
розрадою та Надією на повернення до
нормального життя як і її учні вона
пережила голод обстріли
гуманітарно-катастрофу маючи спільно
пережити жахливий досвід війни вчителька
з дітьми спілкується на рівних як дійсно
близькі друзі ваші Оплески міць
української освіти
[оплески]
[музика]
давайте ще раз Ольга летенко Пані Ольго
якщо ви десь разом з нами тут
Ольга литенко Ми дуже хочемо вас
побачити на сцені все дуже просто Ми
домовились з пані Ольгою на зустріч на
понеділок вона приїде до мене в
Міністерство
для того щоб
розуміти рівень цього подвигу треба
пожити в лимані
я там жив
Я знаю що це за місто
там дуже мало в цілих будівель там дуже
Там повністю зруйнована інфраструктура
ми 95-та бригада стояла там і стоїть До
сих пір в лимані тому вести Я просто
Собі уявляю навчальний процес
організовувати в тих умовах це щось
неймовірно абсолютно неймовірно
Ольга лиденко обов'язково отримає свою
нагороду міць української освіти А зараз
я хочу запросити Іванну Шевчик та Віру
Владику вчительки інклюзивного класу та
асистента вчителя гімназії номер два
червоноградської міської ради Львівської
області ця чудова команда працює з
класом дітей які навчаються з айтрекером
Іванна Шевчик Віра Владика
[оплески]
[музика]
Дякуємо вам надзвичайно і залишайтеся на
цей Лізі області для вас міць
українською освіти
[музика]
[оплески]
Дякуємо дуже і хочемо побачити на сцені
Олександра дорожа директор юнацької
школи гуменецької сільської ради
Хмельницької області Олександр Дорош
[оплески]
[музика]
Ну що ж пані та панове Зараз прошу ваших
таких колективних оплесків перші
домінанти лауреати так
відзнаки міць українського освіти ми
розуміємо що насправді таких нагород має
бути і буде значно більше але ви перші
Дякуємо вам надзвичайно за те що ви
робите Україна і українська освіта
тримаються на вас Дякуємо вам
надзвичайно
історичний фото
[оплески]
[музика]
але будь ласка ще буквально на
секундочку затримайтеся пане Олександре
Це мабуть буде скоріше до вас Ну знаєте
як для Закріплення матеріалу потрібно ж
поставити такі контрольні запитання так
і Мені здається це буде абсолютно
справедливо тому що сьогодні протягом
всього дня здебільшого запитання ставили
вам а зараз у вас є можливість поставити
запитання
тим хто тримає українську освіту Що б ви
хотіли в них запитати
Я не знаю чи
легко вам буде відповісти на це питання
чи можливо ви б не хотіли на нього
відповідати але коли було
найважче що у вас мотивувало Як ви
знаходили в собі сили для того щоб
рухатися далі
мотивувало мене особливо те що у мене 10
учнів з 27 в класі немає домівок теж
і я мала бути для них прикладом Я мала
їх підтримати я як ніхто мали їх
розуміти так сталось
для мене найбільша моя мотивація Це мій
син а також усі вихованці
дитячо-юнацької спортивної школи лідер
[оплески]
Ну а ми навчаємо ну так напевно по-перше
я скажу що ми навчаємо хлопчика якого
комплексне порушення розвитку дитинка
нас донецко не ходить не розмовляє це є
перша дитина в Україні Яка з таким
діагнозом і з таким рівнем підтримки
пішла до школи знаєте спочатку було дуже
страшно тому що ми не знали як будемо
працювати ми не знали як його сприймуть
діти але все-таки радує теж що в
результаті Ми отримали такий результат
що в нас в класі всі діти хоча різні Але
рівні хлопчик соціалізувався і напевно
нас нашим стимулом для нас із моїм
Асистентом було те що в нас надзвичайно
Чудова мама хлопчика яка має таке
терпіння таку силу волі і таку любов до
дитини а хлопчик надзвичайно
життєрадісний за рік навчання у першому
класі він ніколи Ви знаєте Він ніколи не
заплакав він ніколи нам не влаштував
ніякої істерики тобто дитина дуже
життєрадісна дитина має надзвичайно
велике бажання вчитися і Напевно це в
першу чергу було стимулом для нас
підтримати його і маму в такій нелегкій
ситуації дякую
напевно найперше страшно бути першими
тому що не знаєш цих правил які ви маєте
немає ніяких ще
вмотивованих до навчання якихось
таких
знань Які ми ми вчилися разом з
хлопчиком і нас
мотивувало його Жага до навчання тому що
дитина дуже розумна дитина в нас
відмінник в першому класі всюди в нього
всіх предметів на відміну
Дякуємо вам надзвичайно дякуємо дякуємо
вам насправді такі унікальні педагоги
яких У нас дуже багато насправді в
кожній школі фактично є людина яка
робить щось надзвичайне в кожному в
кожній громаді єсть дивовижні приклади
стійкості е-е
самопожертви і ці люди мотивують і нас і
мене як міністра як громадянина як
людину перш за все і мотивують
своїх учнів саме головне мотивують і
показують їм приклад цієї е-е цього
служіння справі само
відреченості і готовності допомогти такі
люди творять суспільство нового типу
Дякую вам ми всі його творимо і Дякую
всім шановні друзі
Дякуємо надзвичайно ще раз і ще раз
Привітайте гучним оплесками нагороджених
відзнакою міць української освіти дійсно
мідь української освіти - це кожен і
кожна з вас пане Оксана ще одне буде
запитання до вас не тікайте не тікайте
шпаргалочками так ніхто не бачив а
сьогодні тут на серпневій Ми дуже багато
говорили про зміни так а дуже багато
говорили про мотивацію про надзвичайні
подвиги теж говорили але насправді ну
нехай це буде таке контрольне запитання
для вас
навіть Ну давайте так і як до міністра і
як просто до українця Так про що ви
мрієте перед початком нового навчального
сезону
проте про що і всіх щоб кожен день
проходив так як пройшов сьогоднішній
день в Києві щоб не було прильотів щоб
не було тривог щоб наші діти змогли
навчатися в онлайні в офлайні в
аудиторно нормально щоб вони могли
закохуватися щоб вони могли дружити
сваритися і знову дружити щоб вони
повертались до нормального життя А для
цього нам потрібна перемога тому Ну Сорі
але я банальний був перемога це по-моєму
єдина і найбільша наша спільна мрія
Дякуємо Хай таке буде Оксана Лісовий
дякуємо
Парі на панували це ще не все це ще не
все
Я хотів би наголосити Що тут у нас
тривога тривога
Давайте тоді ви всі швиденько переходити
в укриття а поки ви переходите Я просто
зачитаю ще важливу інформацію що до 1
вересня триває збір історій вчителів У
рамках премії Global teacher Price
Ukraine яку яку організовує громадська
спілка освіторія тому номінуйте колег
заповнюйте анкети на сайті премії це
чудова можливість вкотре нагадати що
вчителі важливі цьогоріч організатори
також оберуть і профе- профінансують
кілька проєктів по одному мільйону
гривень кожен з відновлення освіти на
неокупованих територіях нашої країни
тому до 1 вересня Global teacher Price
Ukraine чекає номінантів можливо це ви
не стидайтеся ну і Величезне спасибі
всім вам за сьогоднішній день можна
вважати що ми встигли все зробити на
серпневій і будьте в безпеці Все буде
добре все буде Україна Слава Україні
[оплески]